hello for the input bro I didn't even know the game it was part of the warhammer scene
was it terrible 2 seconds late nope now you're not 2 seconds late stop it I'm not 2 seconds
late is it you can be heretic Persian time now yeah
good morning good evening good afternoon
good morning did you see my butt let's not be around the bush here did you see
my fatty I'm really embarrassed she's be re-tweeted it and I'm like no my
genie saw me my derriere we did it was a million out of ten it was a nice
lesson I'm sorry it took me so long I have I did record a video and you can
hear it clapping the video but I need to crop it and edit it because I kept showing
my face in it like a dummy I also took another fool with my nails on and I
didn't have any clothes and I spread my teeth but I didn't spread them hold on I
need to turn down the background ambience this game I find it so hard to balance out
games recently I saw it we're talking about the grand opening of
stroneys bakery then be a yeah I'm a poster later but I don't really like the
video so you can hear it clap in the video that's not a problem no girl at
the door yeah thank you Bob well I was gonna write so for the one for the one
that I've not shown yet I was gonna make it a meme and I was gonna put POV your
stroneys gaming chair getting locked in for an eight hour sweaty gaming session
and then it's me spread and much because I wasn't wearing anything in spady you
typed me 50 for nothing you didn't put a message thank you that one handed to
beat sit on my face with thy glorious peach so that I may inhale thy
sentence taste thy divine honey oh my god sorry and thank you Spidey thank you but
yeah I was gonna make the other one a meme like POV your my gaming chair 50
dollar reduced 25 for each cheek well like I was trying to take the photos and
obviously I didn't have any armor on me so it was really hard to take I was like
oh my god this is just straight up my my clam is out have any tributes been I
learned something new today did you know that ink comes out really fast it can
select and deselect things on your phone screen because it happened to two
every flings which is not a lot but it's quite common I learned that today
yeah let's let it know and so some of yous are on the side of caution and use
like wrap over your instruments and then other ones were like fuck yeah I'm
there's nothing else okay so we're playing vermin tied to so the reason why we
have to stream snipe this way is because of this certain type of game does not
have like use a code and you can play online thing so I have created a steam
account purely for the stream sniping capabilities okay so I'm gonna show my
stream name or code I don't know if the name does if you can't find me because of
the name I'll put in my code and then I'll write down who's played with me and
then we'll go next so you wanted ink anything I seem to be really biased for
audios for some reason and and not just because you make audios but like I don't
know are you squiddling me Ryan that ain't a cake that's the whole
okay thank you the beauty lord 96 real and I like every mommy stream by shooting
my ink on the like button stop that's so funny that's how I leave like a smash
that like button yes okay so my steam stream snipe account hold on hold on
I'll get there it's called scrawny snipes okay and so I'm just I don't know if I
need to give you my code or if you can search that on steam right now and add
me that way and then I'll write down who our first team is second team is third
team and then at the end of stream I'll delete everyone so it's all fairer and
I'll see if it works or not I was expecting to be strong is but you think
I put my butt as my profile picture on steam I put beef laying as my profile
picture on steam like there you are I'm gathering a party did it work oh it
okay that's good right I will do is I'll do two at a time no sorry three at a
time because we can become a group now if you use your legal name on fucking
on fucking with steam please don't add me Jesus Christ my birthday is only in a
couple of months but thank you for the early cake thank you Calcutta happy
birthday in advance even though it's monthly right again if you use your
freaking legal name no you don't don't add me don't be silly belly okay so I'm
gonna accept three no I'm not cuz it's broken what the heck hello hello I've
clicked the box what I do know why is it not working I I can select and de-select
friend to what did we break it no way
hello I need to like oh confirmed okay that makes sense I was like right did
that work or not dad friends yes or no no online right now
they're working after fucks sake why is it so difficult uh does that work
oh right okay we have one reef okay so it worked okay so group one may have
broken toast like a fucking shark oh my god you played this game thank god
thank god thank god someone's for complete this game right no one in my
village you'd ever seen it you don't have the game yes it's a war pass through
leaves us friend oh my god you're appearing offline the empire is at their
heart I have no doubt we will be why is it I don't know if you can hear me spank
that but it's not having it dad is right I'm just gonna accept all because it's
not working yeah it's not working it's like broken one man alone cannot save
every soul from the fires of hell yeah right okay I don't know I don't know if
you can just burst into the lobby because it's not having it okay that worked
so for right so we've got team one again if you didn't get in on time don't
worry I'm coming right team one we have frog on toast we have Loki we have lame
Phoenix funny and together we make oh my god check the trip on the gold war
I missed it don't worry we're playing lot oh my god he's shooting his cannon at me
oh my god I have a cannon oh my god check the drip right right drip check
drip check we've got Sharky we've got dwarven gold and then the last drip
check what we got we got an elven kind of a nature going on a little bit
residency for the back but the weapon check the weapon though the weapon be
glowing okay okay so this is he's a true gold scene he blows on do you know how
to pick your character I think this is the character I used to play and because
it was the easiest so I'm actually quite happy picking this guy because I think I
used to play okay so this team we've got frog on toast Loki and lame Phoenix and
together we make I don't know what we make together babies okay our name is
gonna be babies question mark that cuz that's what we make together babies is
our team name but has to have a question mark it's not just babies and
babies right helm yeah can use the wart any thwarters oh my god how big is this
game
right let me now hold on before anyone's like why you know playing cataclysm
I've no relax I've no play it is this did I do it right this game is you
mongus you want this walk enter the bridge of shadows a bridge of shadows
the way the best map is actually okay I think this is heavy tell for okay we
have a good we have our heading replaying thank you for James 19 over
getting lower war hammer any war hammer any war hammer how about I be the war
and you be the hammer and bang me sorry and before anyone says brain roll it's
of sigmar not sigma okay sigmar okay we're just gonna get into it and I'm gonna
try and finish my tea I'm just gonna get the reference to
wait Carillion of Scots speak again Carillion do you have voicelines in this
game can you like activate voicelines and do see and do see and do see love this
game and love you even if the small fish tag is broken it's so all the Twitter
tags are broken as heck like and Azura thought she wasn't like getting any fan
or and it like got her and like feeling a wee bit upset and I was like oh no like
don't worry like it happens but turns out the tags were wrong and type thing
I was like oh no like it don't worry it doesn't always take things right we can't
hurt each other right by sigma give me toilet I'm sorry right so this is war
hammer basically and in this game you kill the enemies if they in game audio is
too loud let me know though but basically this is a stream type game and I
can play with you and you guys can carry me through the campaign you kill rats
lots of rats I can't believe all it took with me to change my mind about rats
now I love them I'm like oh someone picked up a totem but this is it a fair
fight assassin oh dead is dead oh it's the nice cringy Scottish accent not the
natural one oh I love it I love when fantasy games put in the cringes you
guys deal with it not me I'm doing stuff but nothing's happening am I
dead if I got grabbed right away how did how did all of you not get grabbed I
walk into the room and he just like leaps into my hands honestly shocking don't
let them for was that for us I was tentacle skills oh I can deny the
reflands and voice chat you ready for this I'm gonna make you come tonight
that's all the hair that's all the hair didn't game right okay what's going on
here I don't think I was complaining about the in-game sense I think we're
doing okay what's my ultimate I don't forgot oh my ultimate is me going oh
I'm a god of it if I hit three enemies in a row I get a speed boost the audio is
good thank god so we basically need to hold our stand whilst we're lifting up a
lift you're all gives a critical boost to me oh
get me on the cast then and actually just have someone who sounds normally
squash thanks Brian warhammer is every RPG where you start by killing the rats
but the rats get bigger and scarier also is strongly the real life version of
slum thank you very much oh yeah I'm doing something silly I don't know what
I'm doing I have no idea I'm using all I'm just using all I have no idea what's
going on sorry I'm getting overloaded because the replay went down
you know what up hey warhammer is every role-playing in we start for the get
yes over to raid the lifting platform wait why are you just about all I know
about war how fantasy are the scarven and that one vampire girl was one of the
good guys uh-huh more of a 40k guy so I didn't know it was from the same thank
you dark thank you no dark and a refer what last on what your name is dark and
a like this it's too quiet and reaper sorry I can't figure it um much coming
under why do I have a bone arrow what's going potion of strength okay that's the
healing potion I don't know what this is what's the blue of concentration I don't
think so darkened reaper that's really obvious thank you for the super chat and
talk to him yeah I didn't know it was the part of that universe oh I don't like
that I hope I was supposed to perish him and hold on let me finish my tea and do
we get totems and stuff so she gets good year I thought toms were like you
could me which I do a lamp foil so this the game is like medieval spooky scary but
this is why I wanted to make a steam account because there's so many games
that we can play together and that I would like to be next to my reef wings I
am moving my way over to the reef wings as we speak I'm like English and words
and stuff um but yes oh my god I'm trying to get a sentence out sorry I need a
load that in game volume it's like the game there's loads of games
steam that isn't stream snappable unless you add me which is why I've made this
steam account so we can have a goose on a carry-on or vermin tide and these
kind of steam games together I actually lost a bit of health
what are you doing who are you looking at because it's no me it's no me I'm
popping this I think 100% orange juice would be a nightmare deep glad rock
galactica you want to play that we can do that literally like cuz we've done
this we've unlocked so many games that we can play together for the Empire for
this it's the door I might have to play the elf on ironically because she's
got oh no I probably annoy me if I keep hearing her we voice we found a door the
southern axe bay garrison but yeah this game is apparently humongous I don't
remember it being this humongous walk but it probably came out this big and I
castle crushers don't play that together I don't know much about castle
crushers is it a good party game yeah we can play together
are you squiddin me right now just pretend the rodents are non-subscribers
trying to get free content what the thank you bleeping reaping senpai you're
an amalgamation you said you name your full chest I love it the cannon might be
just waiting are you kid in there get past the gate can I run no wait there's
no run in this game I mean again that makes sense and unless I'm misunderstood
what just pretend the buddhants are non-subscribers trying to get free
content I just broke up you're still forced to subscribe and I'll show up
in your your algorithm for a while because whenever you interact with a
new content creator on YouTube their algorithm gets pushed to you so much
like literally if you like and subscribe on a new person once or look up their
name once like if you type strongy cut was on YouTube right now and then
refresh your page it will probably start spamming that 15k celebration ASMR
stream which I still haven't even streamed but I keep recommending it all
the time it's got like tons of leaks on it compared to any other like pre done
live stream like the stream yeah but you have to like the stream via your ink
only you have to aim it right so if this stream has more ow if this stream has
more dislikes than usual I'll know why okay it's true it's been recommended to
me for days I know someone sent me a marshmallow and they're like I don't know
what you did to that stream but it keeps getting recommended to me even though
it's not like done I'm hydrating I've finished my tea I'm gonna play one
hand or not because we're about to get rats unless you guys want to protect
me I'm hydrating oh shit oh god the replay please we're so thick of the
oh my god but I do fucking later bomb
I'm just afraid every winning or losing I don't know
okay I think that went really well considering that friendly that's not
friendly
oh there's sorcerers in this game okay they seem really weak though what
Reefland is Parkour and over there
defending why do all the monsters go straight for you they know I'm the
weakest team member they literally know I'm the weakest team member what did you
do I don't know why did it good shot you defeated the chaos one by giving it
huh your manlings
wait what is what's the man what you're the weakest reef goodbye
literally the game's like mmm yes you've been playing for approximately 12
minutes I will annihilate you like give me a chance
just give me wait why is my health so tiny I'm all red how did I get rid of
the red what does it mean I just really oh you can't see my health bar it's
perfectly hidden by the UI mmm well I'm getting rid of the UI because of the
grimoires oh we have less health are we gonna make it out alive can we not like
check up the grim words at the end you're making me nervous it's worth the
loot but what if I die potion of speed you'll be fine okay I have faith in the
I'm swinging even though there's the enemies I'm swinging I excuse you why
did I get picked on all the time I'm getting me right now night and shy thank
you for the extended membership congrats on 20k more made that post earlier was
lovely did you like it I'm gonna post a meme and it's just my butt again it's
just in it you know what I say I'm gonna post a meme it's just an excuse
okay I'm gonna fully heal not that it's going that way oh but I'm doing it okay
what's this the heart of a mountain I love the dwarves okay I'm gonna finish
my drink because I keep saying we won't finish it but it's gonna be freezing
okay the refund surely can thank you for becoming a member please enjoy them
what I'm gonna get the unity emote recommit like actually made and I'm sure
that more artists is gonna love it don't bully mama too hard she'll ain't a bra
I'm sitting on my foot and everything I like I was gonna record the audio after
posting and I don't want to worry you because I'm having a really good time
I don't want to worry you but I had a really bad a bomb attack I don't know
it's kind of going crazy right now and I can't identify what the problem is like
I'm very like okay let's identify the problem what's wrong with me but it
oh my god I'm so sorry reflin that reflin was literally getting killed and
the best I could offer was drinking a potion right in front of them oh my god
I was trying to swap to my gun I promise I was trying to swap to my gun oh my god
that was the worst protector ever he's literally getting hooked and dragged away
from me and I'm like go go go go go go stop it I'm the worst teammate ever I'm
the teammate no one wants on the team because I'm terrible I am playing I'm
so sorry reflin I'm literally I'm like oh cheers one less day one less
thanks and I like whoa I don't know how I did that I want you as a teammate you
want me to drink beer in front of you whilst you're getting taken away by the
wrap whoa who who what we're when who's doing that stop it oh I maybe wasted my
there just a little bit oh it's rising okay I understand we're
lifting up someone has fire I think okay it's that reason that has fire
summit who okay I think we're doing it I think we're okay
rattling some folk are into that call it drink holding now that I think about it
is it possible to play left or dead two together I think so like as I said there's
so many games that being opened up to us now that we can play together and so we
can definitely look into what kind of games you guys would like to play because
I don't want to pick all the games like I mean I fucking pick for tonight
I just okay you don't take full damage it's okay we don't take full damage we
did it did we do it I think we did it we did it oh my gosh victorious the
righteous stand right right I think unfortunately I have to reset like
every single mission if that makes sense but that was so good you don't take full
damage in the bubble we can play FPS chess exactly hell bird I got a
commendation chest I don't know what that means but it's working another chess
okay I finished my cup of tea I'm all hydrated Sigmar has blessed you yay
Sigmar's blessings be upon you I've got a peasant strong book completed we got a
quick play bono oh my I don't know what all this is but thank you refling's for
carrying me cuz I don't know what the heck any of the day you picking up totems
and stuff and grimoires I'm what the signal are do you like games with a bit
of story I suggest the dark pictures anthology games what's the name of the
game oh my god let's see oh look at me being the most DPS look at all those
green circles cuz I did the best out of everyone I did not do the best out of
everyone okay thank you team babies question mark and then we go for next
team okay GGs thank you so much refling so for those of you that have had a shot
please I respectfully ask you to leave the game and then those of you on steam
I'll just add everyone and then it's potluck if you get in and in the town
but yeah thank you GGs and then I think for those who've added me on steam you
can just walk in question mark okay yes okay okay this is perfect literally
perfect the refling train is going better than expected not only is it on
time it's early RNG good luck everyone oh no I'm gonna keep playing until I've
got everyone I love this game oh who we got right we have zero we've got dem
rabies like a rabid animal we've got rabies and we've got first dead okay so
what together our team we've got zero rabies and first dead well we so rabies
is a highly infectious disease that ends in death when you are hydrophobic and
then zero I don't know should we call ourselves hydrophobic okay team
hydrophobic we hate war we hate war I'm gonna do a little angry face we're
tree zero deaths by rabies team zero oh maybe we all we should be called the
cure because we're gonna okay we're gonna be called the cure how about that okay I
take it back okay we're called hydrophobic angry face cure it's quite
the team name okay I will select the next mission and then I will be carried
like a prince isn't that right so next we'll do Dean then corn oh I can't read
today convocation of decay Helm guards lost folks but we still have our little
way of keeping our ass together okay I've increased the difficulty I've
increased the difficulty to make sure we can all do our thing I've totally
increased it so much oh we didn't do a fit check actually I need to do a fit
check when we get into the game the difficulties not what you
talking about I 100% increase the difficulty I saw it notice how I'm
shaking my head right fit check fit check real see mm-hmm we've got a fucking
anvil as a hat holy shit you have poses in this game oh my god there's poses in
this game okay we've got an anvil for a hat I read it I read it right the elf
elf is default did you buy this game just a stream site did you buy this game
just a stream site oh no no you didn't you already had it you just thought no
okay okay okay okay and then okay we've got death we've got death mm-hmm death
incarnate I see skulls mm-hmm yeah mm-hmm oh he cooked he cooked he's the
cleric he cooked okay are we ready you should be default key for a movie I
already had it oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to type that I'm not very good I
don't know you can do stuff in the game like that I'm gonna be like role-playing
stuff what happens if we role-played that we're playing a Elden Ring oh we're all
around the fire or humanity has been explored do you understand the passage
of time stop typing why in the chart it was a mister it was a miss input miss
input come the fuck it was a miss input why you believe me why you believe me it
was a mistake I thought I was a moment wait this isn't the way to go where we
go oh sorry it was a 50-50 it was either left or right oopsie gonna put something
in a human Yankee Laurel
okay well speed them up beat them up beat them up beat them up search the
building I don't even okay we're searching we're searching where I'm
searching so hard right now I'm searching all over these beds so this is
how the refling farm looks when it's not being destroyed so everyone has their
own bunk bed very military-esque style and then basically oh right now I'm so
I'm going with the reflings I hate that freaks me out that freaks me out in the
game talks to me like that and then basically what happens is I come into
the room and then I pick a refling and then I take you to the milk and chamber
oh I need to pin my name on steam I'll open my name in chat just so you guys
can add me easily but for those who are coming in a little bit late I'm called
strongy type and you can add me and then we can play steam games together
okay let's let's help the elf in the dwarf because they're currently I love
the oil it makes me feel like a badass I don't know so pathetic but it does I'm
like hi Johnny hi and thank you for joining and thank you for one to play
games with me it was very happy I'm a I got against the refling I'm just working
I don't I don't know I'm working I'm working and making very not to be
slightly emotionally vulnerable for a moment it makes me very happy that you
guys don't play games with me and give off with me and yeah but I'm not gonna get
to I'm not getting too sappy okay I'm not gonna get too sappy I'll behave I'm
behaving can I volunteer for the milking one touch real and true
okay I'm doing I'm doing I think strongy has been hanging around she be a bit
too much the milking chamber sounds like something the bunny don would do should
we be scared no you shouldn't be scared you should let me lead you into
temptation oh wait that's something she be would say as well cuz she just did
alright you win this one bleeding refling Senpai you win this one
because I'm being a death you should ink you should ink yourself no oh my god
wait I need to make that I need to make that edit you should ink yourself no
thunderbolts and lightning and edit okay everyone's here the whole gang's here
oh really Roman soldiers already feel that's cuz I don't use my gun I maybe I
don't know
a little tear I love that England I'm always so cute we're getting high is
okay I hear with boys oh I'm helping refling I'm helping I'm not allowed to
go offline until I've got all the kills and I've got like the most kills in the
game have in that so we just like forever perpetually stream
oh my god so good wait we're okay as long as it got refling with me I know I'll
be able to survive follow the trail of corpses I have a lever to pull pulling
the lever pulling the lever while questing with the reef flings pulling
pulling the lever with my weak little wrists look as go wrong lever I wish I
had Washington I guess it's another adjourn stream look I'm sure I can get
one green attribute because that reef I'm freaking stole them all asking I'm
on to you there we go down there
oh guess he gets the ball okay I don't know what I'm doing I'm just I'm just
slicing I'm spawn killing I'm literally spawn killing right now there's
nothing they can do about it I'm just so MLG for right I'm definitely to go
downstairs
wow get that rat okay I just fall on the reef land and I'm swiping oh okay I'm
definitely not a gun specialist I didn't even know they had weaponry like
that I thought it was merely only I think I did it I'm helping I'm helping
oh wait wait push the suspicious bricks is there something we're supposed to do
or are we just going in circles until we can figure out what happens I'll just
let the reflings guide me you get off your pop guys you do your thing you do
I'm just having a good time oh it's bug me how inaccurate games portray the
great sword move it's so damn clunky okay I'm gonna just follow this reef one
I don't know what I'm doing he's pushing the buttons on the wall
take this take this take this hmm I wonder if Warhammer have any more games
like this speaking of following the trail of corpses I was in a DND campaign
once where we infiltrated at Colton the sewers but got captured so a powerful
NPC bartender came to save us saying he just follow the trail of bodies to find
us oh you play D&D you little nerd thank you tiny spiny yeah Aristo was telling
me about D&D games and she told me like one of our sessions got cancelled and
all that and I'm like I'm gonna pretend I know what any of this means okay I think
the reflings are working together I don't know I'm just following this one
I'm following I'm following I'm following look I have a leash on me the
reflings are gating me strongy you would love D&D nerd the audacity no nerd
isn't a nice way is nerd still an insult these days I feel like nerd is a
compliment to people like us like we love being there I want to get into D&D but
don't have friends okay we're just gonna have to do a D&D together that's the
only option okay there's plenty of these so I'm gonna be cheeky and he'll like
two XP I said what I said nerd is not a badge of honor yeah I feel like nerd
means like oh you're you're like me and like we can play games together making
hang out and meme and stuff whereas like if you're not a nerd it's like how on
earth am I supposed to explain to you which give it a toilet like why it's so
funny to a brain roll sometimes an insult usually it's honorific it depends
on the context yeah if I called you a nerd would you find it an insult it's not an
insult when you say it okay okay it's all about the tone in the tent
here's my little noon who knows all about warhammer lore is you darling sorry
there's a refling under attack and I hate when they get under attack cuz I don't
want them I'm just here for you to oh you're not refling go away I wear these
fun and everywhere okay I think I'm okay there's a lot of blood on my screen I
think maybe next game I'll put it on normal difficulty I mean super hard
difficult I wonder which kind of refling strong he likes to eat more the strong
and confident settler parts for the blushing nerdy guys I don't think I
really mean cuz either way either way it's like I can I can mold you into what
I want I can hypnotize you to be what I want you know in the moment because it's
not like I'm not just like I 100% want this this thing always and there's no
variation whatsoever like no I like the variation who is whispering in my
name thank you anonymous for the tip no I think it's good like I like the
variety so it's like even if you're like well I'm actually 100% don't there's no
way that strongy would change that nice try mate nice try you're funny you're
really I'm helping I promise I'm helping hold on I did not help at all I
came to help bad bad rat you're hurting my
I don't I don't really bad at swapping are we good down where's the other
refling is he down there already okay there you are sorry we're in the old
so Jim Bruce have a chance so when I'm like oh obviously I'm fit enough to do
but like it's a fucking maker break or anything good girl okay now time for
walkies come on now keep up good but thank you for the chat no so the plan the
plan is you know after my gaming session of feeling loved on there may or
may not be an audio but don't don't stun lock me cuz I'll cry don't don't do it
I'll ink myself stop it you're turning me off I'm just following this I can't
reach I'm too short is that actually how we're supposed to go refling I don't
know I don't know I'm swinging I'm swinging though oh I'm absolutely
swinging my heart out I don't even know if we're supposed to go this way but I'm
doing it anyway he looks like the the guy that's gonna decapitate you in
Shrek that's all you got go on oh good I I think I'm going the right way I'm not
sure not again not yet I think I think we're accidentally far away from the
oh god they're fighting as well okay okay hopefully I don't mess up hopefully
don't mess up but we're doing our best that's the main thing even though the
game is coded to have okay they're coming I think we're okay but I'm
defending it they're getting secrets and stuff but we're doing the main quest
okay okay behind the altar is a book behind the altar is a book there is
yank I've taken it I have the book I'm the bookkeeper see who said whole bags
can't be a librarian oh my god sexy librarian did it oh I never said I
never leaked that I originally wanted a schmaksy librarian but and that got
changed in development I couldn't make it work I couldn't make it work I had to
be a librarian paired with some sort of Neko and it's not Neko Mimi Kim Kimono
Mimi the animal words animal use I'm just swinging swinging all day long yeah
I was submitting for it but wasn't happening oh I like whatever that
ultimate is Kimono Mimi yes if we did librarian it would have to be paired
with something like that but obviously she be was formed and it's just a bit
too close to the cons just wrap the ritual what's that just wrap the ritual
what we supposed to do we're to go inside stay inside the circle okay we're
not gonna leave man I hate this ritual I'm just I'm so disruptive of this
ritual was stinky ritual yeah that's what I think about this ritual I will girl
sexy librarian oh honestly that's not bad I will do you okay don't let it hook
yeah oh my god I'm so good at this game do you hear the way my mouse is
clicking right now that's how good at this game I am what do you mean all I'm
doing is swinging and not aiming whoa I did it I actually killed something with
my pistol I'm so good okay I'm just oh we can't shoot him oh okay okay I'm
figuring out hold on hold on don't write me out yet I'm actually helping hold on
I'm not a detriment to the team I'm actually so good just stand in here keep
it up and you will truly become the warhammer trademark I'm getting shagged
by a non-reflin oh my god why am I so low health Danny a drop this to him don't
think I would drop the top I'm gonna drop the top I'm getting scared oh I'm
getting scared is this the end it's over and none of us have healing either we
only have oh it's oh we did it sorry sorry I'm coming stop it I'm getting
stunned hold on I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming I have like one HP in the
dream I need an escort I need an escort I'm so sorry I suck so much of this game
I was literally about to increase the difficulty as well I don't know I'm
nervous I'm not sure I can do it we're gonna make it replays we're gonna make
it to the wayward stone give me the heck out I'm in the bubble I wonder if the
bubble monster monster got run victorious undergone achievement
tempered by war unlock first talent point I don't know what where or what I
do with the talent point what do I do with the talent point I forgot I'm
actually kinda glad I didn't play this because I originally I was gonna like
proper play it but I'm glad I didn't because it's fun just like having it to
experience it with you I like it I enjoy it what color are the pants they're
black today you know what I've had I'm sick of this what color are your boxers
today you're always asking me oh strong either strong no show me prove it what
color are yours today not wearing any blue greenish dark blue not wearing any
that's another you guys don't wear anything while watching me a mummy we
aren't that kind of chat I wrote boxes doorboxes you're not supposed to have
look oh oh that's not me but I did the most damage how I didn't do anything I
did two saves apparently I'll take it I did the most damage sorry but I'm just
that MLG like at level 4 and rolling absolutely rolling black butt to the
side right now okay I have rewards to claim and stuff I'm gonna pretend hero
selection no thank you for the game thank you everyone I don't know how to
level up my character though I'm going to aimlessly wonder around to keep until
something clicks what are you open sure what are my spoils of war open all five
let's see what I don't know what these are unless they're cosmetic then sure
ooh a great hammer oh green things oh more green things and then oh they
make me stronger hold on a minute hold on a minute don't write me out yet I
dare put on don't write don't write me out yet minute I thought this was like
cosmetics cuz I don't I'm no fuss for cosmetics in game right how do I apply
anything I don't know then open these two I don't know what they are but let's do
whoo huntsman bull okay that's not bad these are better right how do I apply
we're gonna quit this stuff oh we got a new team hold on let me write down the
team name I need to figure out where to do the thingy we have your name is like
blurring in we have mr. own to one mr. oh you're a mage I've not seen someone
play the major we've got John reflame and then you can have the dead with you
is it omni omni my glasses right where do where do I level up where do I level
up you'll need to show me where I have a talent point my lady where do I level
up where do I level up go to where I level up press I oh
I knew that oh my god my hero power okay uh-huh oh my god my it was planned
from the start reflame my hero power is a government plot cuz right hi damn it
shoot I'm I just put everything on that helps okay pushback block okay I like
this I genuinely thought they were aesthetics and I was like get them out
here what does that do I am quick to unchain just put everything on that's
okay and then my talent point what is this okay you see damaged just near the
reef one's a bit more vigorous a drill master damaging multiple enemies in one
swing with melee grants health melee kills blows restore temporary health healing
yourself with a first aid kit has more I think drill master drill master
I'm doing again don't add me if you use your legal name seriously seriously don't
be dumb okay it's like mercenaries prayed okay together right let's look at the
team let's look at the fits okay we've got a bit of green going on I love it
ref in the refling colors true and true right what we've got for the mage we've
got a grim reaper safe and that oh you want to high-five yeah I don't know how
to do a high-five I'm sorry I still don't even know how to pose oh he's posing
him with a him with a oh oh oh we're doing dressed in press him oppose him
with a you can always change your talent oh my gosh oh heaven pose right
together our team is going to be called hold tango drop grimoire I don't know
what to call this team your names don't are not easy to congeal
mr. on Ling would be a conglomerate put your name together mr. on Ling
I'm just gonna put mr. on Ling and then a question mark in brackets I'll see if I
can come up with a better name I'm not sure the bones on oh my god that's so
much better than what I came up with you guys you called the bone zone hey that's
the better team name okay I will pick we are now on the home right
mm-hmm I totally put that I put the difficulty up I promise I did oh look
at the pause look at the pause looking like an NPC in Elden Ring what's that oh
you're not a refund going did I do it right oh wait did I not select it sorry
sorry you need 115 wait I can't do this mission no I can't sorry I messed up
sorry sorry I'm just dumb how are you doing it in here
what's this increase the difficulty I'm scared I almost died the last okay have it
right I'll make you a deal we win this one I'll increase the difficulty okay so it's up to the
bone zones keep me up okay I'm just scared hold you to pause
I will hold you and I'll see what emotes I have on my hand holding T then press E so I got a
mouse I can't believe it oh hit him with the oh hit him with the oh yeah that's why
yes of course reeflings oh so stoic so strong chair sit oh my god it's so quick I kneel my reef I
give I kneel to give you a little kiss and then I hit with the lean that's leaning oh it's leaning
against the wall oh I'm going to be sick oh I'm motion sick okay I kiss this replaying
and then I kiss this replaying and then I kiss this replaying if the reefling wants to kiss I
don't think so already we're all ready for battle into the main this level is very dark okay
now I may have put my gamma off a little bit okay that's because I'm blind we didn't get any kisses
you don't get I give you kisses when the stream started I went oh shite so
okay that that almost went terribly wrong I almost died to fall damage I'm not even pretending
to throw any chunders honestly chanda
I wonder how well the skeleton MCC's do
I think there is only five playable characters so you will see
um a lot of characters that you like you'll see the same ones
but I don't know if there's DLC characters or if they rounded if they polish the game off
a rather well and did it that way a blight stormer oh my god did you know I'm part Irish by the way
that's a terrible joke don't laugh at that uh don't laugh at that where are we going I'm following
five characters but 20 classes strong enough
is it a bottom I don't know
I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm winning
I totally know exactly what we're doing but yes we're exploring we're trying to find the black
powder cache so it makes me think the next mission is blowing something up to smithereens and beyond
I'm not sure what other games we could if you guys went left or did to 100 we'll do it I'm not
familiar with it did you see that block though oh my god did you see that block
oh my god sorry that was the most perfect block I will never do that for the rest
of the gameplay please admire it but that's your heart's content because I will not do
I will not be recreating that I'll take it I'm killing I'm killing
I am I'm see the temporary HP I'm getting though I'm really happy with that that's going to keep
me alive longer maybe maybe medium difficulty not so scary okay maybe it's not so scary
left or dead is the only cop game I can afford but there are three more free games like I know
people like the dog on vtuber's for playing apex and all that but it's like it's free anyone come
play it you don't have to you just have to you know give up your personal data oh oh oh no I can't
go insane oh my god refling you can't fit can you that's such a shame you're just gonna have to
ram it terrible that's not terrible 10th HP is a game changer I'm done for some left or dead to
only under what mods are amaz I've never even played the vanilla at least let me play vanilla
first please oh sorry we need to I'm pushing it I'll tell I'm just pretend I'm pushing it pushing the
car pushy pushy car it's gonna break the door oh no it's not whoa that's a lot of loot
that's a lot of enemies got a lot of enemies what is this place the barrel here okay I'm learning
no stop it oh my god he's stop it by the sigma sorry I mean I guess the NPCs aren't that bad
they're doing oh sorry hold on hold on I'm there we go I suspect the gunpowder that would literally
ignite us all and send us into orbit vanilla left for dead is amazing the atmosphere is great
we play it for the first time together I think that would be very sweet
uh I'm helping I'm helping I'll grab this are you grabbing it okay I'll assist you
and by assist you I mean I will I will not aim properly and walk behind you and pretend
to protect you but I'm rubbish and very slow to respond to anything that occurs in this game
I've got two extra barrels
oh what's that I see something over here get farted on by a goblin what are you
ravaged art a piece of ravaged art I didn't know there was culture in this game
how is this game so cultured what's going on here
fine the main car we lost it
um mailed worry not panic but mailed worry oh my god that temporary hp is insane
I'm literally but I know it's all I know it doesn't last forever but
that's good I like it I want more level upies upies I want upies to level upies
okay I'm following this reflin
their army of bones oh there's a health oh you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna pop my health
I'm the only one that seems to be dying in this game that takes hp damage even though I'm swinging
all the time it's that picture of strony with x-tona and now hold on a minute
warhammer used to be cultured but then they stopped letting the dark elves have their bities out
is that real is that real warhammer stuff characters used to have them out they just
just feel rough on this blue hello I'm a wee bit late don't worry we're just beaching
I'm following the reflings they're getting me through this game because I have no idea what I'm doing
wow
fathomless evil what the heck is this chaos in dark eldar had a lot of
sleeveless me if I ever rule of me if I when I make a video game you already know there's
going to be some secret scenes like that oh my god it's me I've missed too many strony streams
being on holidays good to be home oh where did you go happy holidays even though you're back
transport the explosives yes sorry I'm ready I will push it push you can push
away I thought if I could stand on it then I would remote on it and just get pushed through
not only am I a gamer princess I'm also a passenger princess in games if only I could jump on it but
I can't a lot of topless studies I went to someplace on carersboro it looks like a uk then I hope
you enjoyed England school some fucking hours love me football love me wife love me kids simple
these scary boys are you a pillow princess do you want to find that
I was like the idea of hypnotizing you and then just absolutely fucking destroying you
I need to make that audio I just really like the idea of it like I'll make it so it seems
oh my god I can't actually see
uh I cannot see I'm legally blind
I I'm just taking the L on this one holy holy moly I
I'm losing it I'm actually losing it I'm swinging in the dark I can't see nothing
if you can't see nothing at home folks please don't work because I can't see none either
I then again what on earth I'm supposed to do right now I'm gonna just stay I'm gonna heal up
and then I'm gonna grab this because it looks like the reef ones are fine some of the selfish
and take the healing I literally am I supposed to be able to say
where did I miss what audio she's talking about no I'm talking about making one I knew audio
don't tempt me with a good thing they did not get this home
at least the scary boys are giving us some light I mean oh I can see
strongly with the ink would come out so fast it'd bring me like a button
it would I was thinking like if I did the audio I would premise it like oh I'm gonna be like a pillow
princess and it's like surprise I'm gonna be fucking feral on you
I'm pushing the cart I pushy pushy cart
have a bottom jump scare I love that so much it's so cute I'm wondering should I increase the
the piddle size from your little piddle of ink I think I maybe make it a bit more obvious okay I
can see again so that's the good news um actually speaking of seeing I'm putting my glasses on
sorry my cute little glasses that are for literal children because my head is so small for some
reason I have an abnormally small fucking head I just have a quick rundown on the lore I've never
had glasses um and then when I went to get them I got sized um and I was like pick oh sorry I just
punched the mic I was picking out what glasses I wanted and I had to pick from the child section
because my head is like small I don't know why I think it may explain why I'm dumb because my head
is like small and considered a child size head which makes no sense because I have a big forehead
well it doesn't make any sense easier to head pat or like fucking head smack like bonk
um oh the booty lord why are you gifting thank you why are you gifting you don't have the gift
thank you very much uh the booty lord you didn't have to do that
five head and small head at the same time literally pick a struggle
either I've got a freakish small head or I've no like pick one
maybe maybe I need to hydrate in this war
and swinging record
bang the main court
I'm I'm I'm spraying and praying okay oh my god I have a bomber
oh my god we all have bombs that was like all of us on the same wavelength have you not drank
any war yet yeah okay hi jason time
we took mommy's first mini boss what's up wasn't that not the thing that grabbed me at the start
right if you guys aren't healing up I'm literally being selfish and like healing like five xp uh HP
uh I don't know what's going on with me
I don't know how my brain unprocessed the block to reblock again but I did it in in 4k
clip it and ship it it was so MLG pro do a little three don't actually clip it's not exciting it's not
that exciting um although there's a funny pin pal um that's clipping all of emmy's burps so she
let me put a burp short together over she's such a good sport um about anything
okay I'm glad that somehow worked out because I didn't think it was gonna but it did hold on
hey pick up the ammo okay I'm coming minecraft see just because you said don't clip it yeah
there's gonna be like eight people that clip it and then it's literally gonna be titled the clip
that stroney didn't want a nice dodge answer I'll take a widow two minute break after this one just
a yet for a second um unfortunately my in real life HP bar is pretty fucking low I don't know what
is going on with me I'm getting a bit a bit fucking tired of it but being honest like no
it's nothing to do with you like you've not done anything wrong if anything like I'm super happy
because like I get to be a tease um like I was nervous posting the picture and oh my god right
if you've seen the picture please open up my alt twitter right now and look at the picture I brought
the two like backwards and I was like I literally cannot do anything better than like what I've done
and I just had to accept that like it just looked awful I just I was like no I can't do any better
than that so it didn't work and then I used the coconut oil for a photo it looks like yo no I did
no I'm not a pirate I didn't write you on my butt no I just thought there's a number two in the
picture you can't see it I drew 20 on my cheek and one is on my drew pink and then on the other
I drew green because of my hypnosis colors but it was so hard what I don't have a bomb
um I'm helping I'm helping beat them up beat them up make them regret being born
oh my god I'm knocking them over oh
is that all you got those were numbers yeah at least the zero was impossible to get back
well like you know the worst thing was I practiced before I wrote it like I did it
in like my finger in the air um I did it with my finger in the air and uh yeah I messed up
so that's even worse I laughed a lot when I saw the backwards too but then I got a bit distracted
we need to work on mommy's like abilities to do well I didn't uh so I couldn't sit on anything so it
wasn't like I could sit on the floor it was in like one leg behind my head type thing a bit
oh we just nuked that place I deserved um you practice writing numbers well to write it on
myself I like did it the right way but then it came out the wrong way and I don't know how I did it
and I just I had been um like I wasn't feeling very well but I did want to do it so I was just
like right that's it oh we're done oh my god we're gonna complete act one
the moment I saw the cake I just simmed in okay there's an attempt okay I tried my best
it could have been better okay victorious oh yeah hunger in the dark cake of cake
but yeah and then I did a photo oiled up and then that didn't work out because you
couldn't even see that had any oil on and I was like okay I I've do okay I've just checked and
there is indeed a 20 well an attempt at 20 I've unlocked a handgun I like put the coconut like
did you hear that that's my coconut uh coconut hydrate body oil with a
radiance enhancing blend of oil um I like put it on maybe you can't even see it in the phone so
twerk clapping cheek bit one day well I recorded it the only thing that I don't like about it is
because obviously if you have like a big gluteus maximus oh my god did I win you guys took all the
green from me you're so stinky but use that actually mlg pro I'll give that to you okay I'll
give it to you um I can't believe I didn't get one thing are you joking how is in a damage
dealt so weak compared to the last game consequences of the rifling carry honestly
um so yeah and so I have one photo another one that I'm gonna make a memos and basically
would be like POV your strongies game and chair and then that's it that's the meme there's nothing
else to it that's it and then I did record a twerking gif um obviously I did have to put
on a phone for that one so I could not get away with that um thank you thank you very much for the
game thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
okay and then just whoever gets in is local um so nothing nothing better rub some ketchup
on my face for the chair and then you get out of here then did you see my ass on foot
that's right go on my old count right now but yes I did record a video of me
making it clap as I twerk but because I have a big booty I also have cellulite
and I don't know if anyone's gonna be weird and be like oh my god you have
cellulite right we've got vitamin C yeah we've got vitamin C we've got
right we're clearly a British bunch here and then we got half on has a very
unique emblem right we're something British something about London will we
be called the shank okay I think we'll be called the overposing right we've got
horns to grip so rider rider rider rider rider a hardly even nor okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah rate her I hardly even nor rate her question that's your team
name
since I joined your shenanigans and starting to ink in more cellulite she
is very very new oh you're gonna pin the user name oh I keep forgetting to do
that uh what is my name strongy hold on I'm going to pin it in chat a okay
steam strongy snipes terms and conditions bomb in but but all removed
at end of play session with proof
hello love heart we've got no brainworns in this house you're damaging the dummy
okay time to select look at me sorry being helpful well I'm gonna lie you guys
are a bear streamer than me okay we can finally do I don't know what the helmet
means that makes me rather nervous I'm gonna be I'll be honest and it's a
nervous now there's a sorcerer Lord creating quite a hullabaloo down there
what's left of hell Helm guard is difficulty up okay can I can I leave
it on recruit then can I leave on recruit I don't want my first game to be
unveteran to be a fucking boss I don't know do you do you want can we do you
have to do the cake was 60% of your body it was very time for max
difficulty extremely hard party does not meet requirement wait I can't even
pick veteran I don't I don't meet the requirement oh well yeah I literally
can't actually pick it cuz I'm too weak you haven't even got the practice for the
higher stuff no I don't did I select the mission I think so now shucks what a
shame I'm just gonna have to play on easy mode and get carried all through the
game oh what a nightmare I'm saved by the game which is Helm guards room
designed to stop people from billion streamers like that no okay mean the
squadron hold on let me have him with a pose I kneel reeflings for carrying me
through every single game I fucking kneel my knees are breaking the floor
from how hard I'm kneeling right now thank you for carrying me through
everything and not being annoyed at how much I lack any ability to play games
by myself literally literally thank you for not bullying me for being so
video games even though I've played them all literally a spawned out the women
in plain video games and I'm still rubbish at them she is often on her knees
for me I'll make that audio don't think I want thank you for wait thank you for
okay I'll make it boom we got a totem already are we boogie hey you beat the
tax evasion game hell yeah I did it was a good game we're gonna play tax no we're
gonna play we rob a bank next I received a gift are you guys back no don't
buy me things on steam what don't don't buy me stuff on steam I can I don't
that's very kind of you I will please keep your money what's that blue thing
back there I saw it wait there's something blue back here ever do you
but I there's something up here as the music gets more intense gta 5 I don't
know what the gate gta 6 leaks I said there is a book here oh it's an art
piece okay I got it Johnny has picked up a piece of ravaged
games bought for strongy that aren't tax deductible I don't even think I claim
tax I such a headache working when I can't and that doesn't make him right
what do you mean and an ice bilbo mold was used for content I was like look
I'm just put it through I'll post because so I have to post the evidence and that I
used it and which is hilarious think about it deep down hey are we ready
wait what's that reflin on it you okay I'm gonna don't wear a snipe I'm helping
I'm helping I'm helping wow it's not a total waste of ammo does the bow and arrow
person have a better ammo capacity I feel like what's that you will trouble
us no more since being missing in action since leaving to look at your cake
picture interest and before I'm gonna get in a DM from her oh my god you got
like the pumpkin kind of I like the orange hints to your outfit it really
accentuates the French hat I don't know what these are called but I just call
the French gold I like the glowing the glowing is very hypnotic I quite like
the color scheme I said about to send you after review I mean I've seen since
wouldn't be anything out the ordinary for us to our shenanigans are pretty
shenanigans should I say or shagg again wait no that's not how it works shag again
shagging you you see what thank you oh my god I don't know how you're making them
levitate but teach me that can you imagine the stuff I could do three films if I
can make them levitate imagine the weightlessness feeling I feel access to
you oh there's a door did we go through it or is it gonna spawn enemies oh what
is it oh I hear loads of whispering oh it's like a shortcut did we just do a
big loop around I think I think we just did a big loop through the city randomly
sorry my curiosity got the bear of me I won't do that again she can't again no
strong immediate thinking of how else magic can make the freest fantasies
come y'all honestly oh oh him with it him with it up I love how quick that is
what is that even like a second at mid fight alright fights over neat okay need
to rest up after that fight look okay I'm just getting my breath back
no it's like your mouse so high is just the most sensitivity you can sit chair on
me you can tell me chair what a name that one gay heart
what are we doing I'm looking and looking I'm thinking and thinking DPI one
million what's this oh is that secret this way I don't know search for the
bubble the verbal sphere how scourge oh how is this a district it's a derelict
house that's falling off a cliff merchants district merchant district up
my arse honestly merchants we could literally fall off the map no one no
one fall off the map you understand me it's the name of the boss oh that's how
we get across the bridge as if you hit me I was so tall
okay they're not anything
oh sorcerer her controls the way I don't see no sorcerer I don't hear them either
whoo okay this sorcerers seem to be super strong but they can't seem to like
they don't have any HP I like when the games do that mommy sure honestly he's
stuffed your toe that was my toe I just fucking heels on it give me a back chat
it's covering mommy's health bar oh oh I forgot to take that off hold on
is it that one nope is it that one nope is it that one nope is it this one
yep okay that'll do it looks a bit scuffed but I mean you can see oh my god
I'm coming are we feeling
I didn't even know that was a thing okay is that bear or the health bar where
this yeah no I did it you're what I'm coming me at the end of the street
yeah I want to play lots of games with you today and then after I finish playing
yeah I'm gonna do something I'm gonna post the meme I'll make the meme and then
I'll post an audio and then I'll take it a bit easier unfortunately me fucking
stress levels are back I'm so annoyed I was feeling so de-stressed and it's all
kind of come back again
but it's just one of them things like a cycle honestly I'm doing fine though but
it's like one of those frustrating things because I'm quite like logical with
well I'm not I'm one of my wounds so my graphics so I stop that's not funny you
can't say stuff like that and so that completely lost my train of thought
cuz I said that out loud and what I meant to say is like when I have a bomb I
know what's up I know what the reason is I know what the purpose of it is I know
why it's been caused I don't know I don't know why it's happening right now
and it's making me very sick to the point where I can't eat normally at the
moment which is really annoying like I'll take a few bites and then and then I
get dumped with adrenaline and I'm like do you mind does that stop I mean
honestly yes I'm not even gonna argue yes the puppy needs stress relief I'm
not even arguing for one like that is a that's why we're gonna be a cheeky
audio but thank you for the legend kind of real answer why you stressed I don't
know I can't figure out I'm gonna take some medicine I don't want to be a
weirdo I don't want to like make anyone feel weird but if you guys are
comfortable I'll take some medicine and I'll go get something in my tummy and
then we'll keep playing that's okay let's do it let's get to get right get
right get right get shredded get shredded get shredded what's that what's
that food that you shred beef no it's not beef jerky brisket I'm shredding them
like brisket or something no peeled pork column pork cuz I'm shredding them
you know I'm trying I'm trying so do we need to do yeah it's just a medicine I
don't I've never streamed well on the medication that's the only problem
because it's diazepam which puts your brain to sleep so you stop overthinking
and freaking out basically and I don't know if it's gonna inherit my ability to
stream you can find out live here folks yeah I think I'm probably gonna have a
manager come in a bit quicker than I originally anticipated I'm gonna see if
I can streamline it to next month because I'm needing to like just step away
from having any responsibilities other girls sorry I thought you're an enemy
because of the whisper in my ear
and you don't come in to get Benzo what's Benzo like bozo what's Benzo no filter
nice to take some responsibility yeah like I'm needing to just completely step
away from anything basically cuz it's I don't know why see the thing is my
responsibilities have less and I have less to do but I've never felt more
worse and you know and before anyone's like oh maybe take some days off of
streaming my relief is like I don't have to think of anything right now I'm
playing with my refunds we're goofing off killing rats in the game and we're
just getting to the next location I'm swinging my sword we're playing on easy
mode because I'm actually too underleveled I can't do a thing the
responsibilities now have a lot of your control yes that was actually an
interesting talking point if anyone's kind of curious about like the behind-the-scenes
stuff and the whoa and we have a bomb bomb coming in
and it's giving up control to other people when it's like I wouldn't do it
that way that was a big thing that comes into it like I have to give up that I
can't do everything myself and I'll have to rely on other people and if they
don't give me stuff on time well who does it affect does it affect my growth
no because I deal with my own stuff but does it affect their the girls growth
and it's like yes like and we had like shorts people like people who edit
shorts applied to the website they came on board and they're like I can't give
you a short until two weeks away and it was like I'm not being funny but can you
like the gift no no if you're a shorts editor I promise you I really do
appreciate you what you do for the girls and all that but like I can't give you
anything for two weeks and it's like why did you apply right now then why
didn't you apply in two weeks when you're available there's a refund down now
I just got twad I'm getting twad I don't know why sorry was a horde
nothing will get in the way like literally unless I have food poisoning or
I'm literally in the hospital sorry but you're even if I get food poisoning I'm
gonna boot up for five minutes have a giggle and then go off like I need to be
in the hospital and or and then that'll break my streak it's tough taking your
hands off the wheel yeah definitely like it means kind of spoken about how it's
hard because she's like a bit of a perfectionist and I can really appreciate
that the point of view because it is a bit like oh we need to heal Lenny you
should heal oh you did heal everyone's healed I'm gonna heal my missing three
HP don't mind if I do I applied right now because most of these things are
limit times Johnny not limits just join us next week or never yes so we're
trialling the clipping program to see if it's like gonna be worth it I mean
fucking I'm so happy for me and if you didn't know me had a short that fell
into the algorithm program and oh my god I'm so happy like I'm so freaking happy
first that like 30,000 subscribers which is insane I'm just I couldn't be over
the moon and I couldn't be over the moon what I couldn't be happier for her I'm
over the moon for her and like the girls have got new shorts back coming out
like after the stream once I've finished in can see you I'm gonna upload like
more shorts and basically just hope one of them falls into the algorithm for
each of the girls that's all we can do really it's all you know the management
can do is make sure it's like we pay for the shorts they just tell us what they
want to be made not everything is what on earth am I supposed to do I'm I'm just
shooting okay I don't know if I'm supposed to avoid the fart cloud why
did you do that yeah is that 215 KVS like literally if that happened if one
short popped off for each of the girls that's all I could ask for like I'm so
happy that we as management get to pay for it and it doesn't come out of their
income it doesn't come out of you know it's not like we reserve like more than
20% like it's not 20% goes into the agency the agency pay for their shorts
with it all that jazz all that goodness and I can't tell who he's looking at
replay no oh why do I keep drinking every time I want to help a replaying
why did I just give up and start drinking oh I'm out of ammo I don't know
what Luke that is but I got it I love how you girls
Johnny has a drinking problem straight to the I'm like refland's gone what's the
point gives up and starts to be flown about to die cheers I'll drink to that
no it's cuz I'm so distraught are you drinking to cope with the stretch of it
with the stress of watching the refland suffer I think so mommy can't stop
drinking to escape our problem exactly I'm out of ammo I don't know if that's
gonna be a problem hopefully nothing grabs me or a refland that needs to be
shot from afar we fling panic response vomit a strong ease but drinking oh we
did it already GG I got an achievement the plot thickens complete act one why
yes I'm I'm paying attention to the plot and Warhammer yes yes I know exactly
what you guys are doing really well I'm really proud of you all have been doing
fantastic we have as I said I've got new shorts coming there's actually a really
funny short she be coming out from the collab you know how we watched their
collab I got a short of the one where we're she be spits in Emmys mouse and
Emmys like and I got it and it's really good and and then the way they edited it
so Azura didn't talk until the end so it looks like it's just the collab
between Emmy Mercy and she be and then at the end is there comes on with her
fucking sexy voice and we say good girl good boy thing it's just such a good
short hopefully it does alright but yes all I want for Christmas is one viral
short for each of my daughters that's all I ask for so they all have a chance to
be seen that's all I ask for for the rest of us oh my god all right then I
guess we'll all go fuck ourselves what the fuck save some accolades for the
rest of us Azura is close to 10k oh yeah AC just hit that milestone so that's
gonna get posted later did more damage than the rest of the team combine
literally one how do you say that with your full chest two you're in trouble
hard carry on a single gg have fun thank you so much fortunately my ping wasn't
too bad that's right get connected to Australian servers we're gonna do a bit
huh we're gonna do it huh I'm stunting on you with my Aussie connection that's
right 100 ping 200 ping 300 ping okay next brief link me come
and we take a small break for medicine I don't feel like I need it anymore see
this is why as soon as I communicate and see my problems out loud all of a
sudden they go away and I don't need it and like I don't want to turn into one
of them streamers that like say everything negative under the Sun but as
soon as I say like I don't need it I don't need it anymore I'm like her
power level is as high as her ping oh okay right here we go we got diddy we
got child Brad what's your name Brad and then we've got recon crusader we
put on you can read you say other crusader yeah crusader so you spell it
okay we have right let's check the fits okay the fits aren't bit more of an
architecture there's a few cylinders on the butt we've got an eye patch and we've
got a golden
what tell you crusader and thank you for the game I love
I'm in time to in love for my people to play it it's such a good game it's very
good for accessible stream sniping wise yes I thoroughly enjoy it I don't think
we're gonna finish the campaign I really wouldn't mind booting up this game
again for stream sniping reasons okay what would our team be called DCR
RCD R CDR DCR disser disher okay our team name is this her with an
exclamation mark no with three exclamation marks okay this team name is
disher spelled d-i-s-s-h-e-r with uh capitals all over disher I hardly even know her
exactly yes I literally write that as you type that okay we are official in these DLC downloadable
content kill yourself in mancraft act one of no act two I sell yin lui the bridge of
shadows has been a boon but it seems our enemies have gotten wise oh lesia says
there's interference in the winds of magic centered around an old elf temple
nearby take a wander have a gander and put a stop to whatever they're up to with
a lot of work to do and we won't stand a chance if we're left marching up and
down the countryside right okay I can't do any I can't increase the difficulty so
no one complain about playing on easy mode thank you
sorry if this appears like a question but I was curious about when someone who
applied to the clip of program might expect a responsive accepted I think is
getting processed either today or tomorrow by management if you don't hear
anything please don't take it personally I am trying to min max exposure for the
girls and obviously I think it's fair to say the clipping program is rather
generous and so there's a lot of like we need to obviously we get 20% from the
girls and but we need to min max a we need min max a fucking feature for
agency simulator game in real life though and so if you don't hear anything
back please don't be insulted that that doesn't mean we hate you or anything like
that it just means we are trying to find like the best possible thing and I
believe we're also going to display those who are a part of the program on
the website just to kind of be like you also kind of the girls may oh my god
we're in a forest and the girls may also I'm not gonna force them to don't want
to but I will personally link clippers on my YouTube channel just to be like
exposure cuz clips are fun and hilarious and I like them and you know I'm
on my high we already played needy streamer overload in real life never
playing vtuber simulier video game
love me love me do all love me love me I don't I don't know what type of I've
forgotten what his character name is cleric are you cleric you maybe are
you a buccaneer I don't know are you French be honest thank you French we
need best in slot clippers I mean kind of true he's an inquisitor a witch
hunter okay we are to locate someone okay
already feel was that bomba okay we've been has bomba probably much safer in
the hands I'm sorry we flint drink this drink my ink to your ticket take my
ink hold on can I pose on you and put please oh we're in trouble it's okay
it didn't hurt it doesn't hurt how does fire not hurt he's worse than French
he's a pawn was a pawns I rhymes with something that's British slang for a
fiddle in a fiddle in here's are we didn't pick up lines on thank you
anonymous for the super chat I'm so sorry you can send you can ask questions and
chat and literally if it is a question that's related to something like you
can ask for free and if you're worried about getting timed out mod if someone
asked a question that's related to the agency or something that does seem
valuable to know please don't time out if it's been repeated and I perfectly
dodged their question every time and the way that popped off was perfect okay
thirsty time I will repair one HP upper-class nobility oh that is even
worse oh no I bet you he doesn't even know what he's never watched the scheme
on YouTube I can't believe it I'm gonna force you guys to watch the scheme with
me okay so here's a bit Scotland lore and there was a TV show that filmed the
real lives of people that lived in a scheme scheme is a location where the
government pay for your housing because you know poverty and strife and you know
not got job etc blah blah blah blah but the problem was this was real people's
lives that they were broadcasting and it got cancelled in terms of they couldn't
continue film production because it was like wildly inappropriate now we have
shows called like Jeremy Kale or we had it the equivalent is like Jerry Springer
but Jerry Springer is people's lives like enhanced or you know standing actors
that kind of thing no this this stuff is real people's lives they're fighting
drug addiction they're fighting poverty they're fighting like all these
attributes I have the art art art art and all that kind of thing and basically
the scheme got was about Scotland I'm gonna make you watch it I'm forcing you
to watch it to be like just so you can see about what what Scotland is actually
like because a lot of people picture Edinburgh and like oh it's Harry Potter
s because it's like all tiny buildings there's like we have a nation that's
addicted to methamphetamines we have heroin problems in Scotland
oh what's this help help help help who or what was that are we okay oh jeez
alright I'm using ultimate for this fight that's intimidating and there's so
many so it's just like the US then basically yeah and drug addiction is
really an interesting subject I might do a full stream dedicated I like the
education side of it I find it rather and where are we going I'm following you
guys okay you literally you're going this way you got caught in the green
world when it's summoned by a blight stormer okay one I hate like because they
gave me the suck I don't want to suffer my sister I actually said about the same
time you didn't fall into addiction I never had an interest in it cuz like I
always gained I was like chugged my cola but I wouldn't do it like my mom that's
right mama cuttles you're getting a spanking on stream she smokes and one
time I snapped her cigarette so she was so annoyed at me oh I got into a big
trouble that day oh did someone say sniping well that missed I was rather
embarrassing okay I fall doesn't glass go have the highest meth users oh I would
believe it 100% would believe it I wouldn't go to the first second and
strong he does indeed say that I'm the sniper for one
her addiction is a rethink real and true that we are so huge because all the
spanking from my mother right so I used to get here's a chair so you know like
some people like oh I grew up my parents were having so my dad never hit me but
my mom hit me and she just spanked me with this fucking orange sandal and it
still haunts my nightmares okay I still remember the fabric of it I remember
the absolute stinging fucking pain of that fucking thing and do you want to
know what happened when that orange sandal broke I burst out into song and
dance over the happiness of this fucking sandal finally broke and my mom laughs
at it and I'm like I bet you laugh on it the chancla the yeah literally the
chancla thing are we supposed to go this way or are you guys trolling me I'm
not being trolled I think I'm being trolled okay I'm just following you guys
funny how the spanking translated it I thought no I mean I would leave that's
different wildly different great we go all the way around where I'm struggling
to get up God ultimate I'm using my ultimate I'm using my ultimate okay the
reeflings are helping there's a lot of flashing on stream I'm so sorry if you
have epilepsy please close your eyes please close your eyes if you have
epilepsy just you're just supposed to listen to streams for everyone oh everyone
seems to have temporary help nobody ever says I think I think proceed through
the wild I don't know where to go I'm just wondering is there a map that press
M for map geez hold on I need to shoot the gunner
McWay for Prince Ali my mom used to spank me and one time when she did she
burst a bloodbath on her hand because of the hit oh my mom told me one time she
sent me to nursery and she was to hit me like extra hard and she was like she
was getting me changed ready for nursery and she was like she was like shocked at
the bruise it left on me and I don't think she ever like spank me part of that
V one of you people need to heal right now there's a box right here someone
needs to heal so the Lord is your mom has the upper cake and made it so it is
a bomb and I made my washboard no she's the only hit my arm so I wasn't as bad
drink oh I'm helping I'm helping see I actually helped and didn't drink for
once I'm so strong liberator object to finish the level to complete the
challenge what's challenge has anyone had a parent who got so they started
choking you no I've not done it I've been very lucky not had to deal with that I
just got spanked for me it was a fly swatter main was an orange sandal and
it still hunts I know exactly I still remember it to this day I remember the
sound of it as well
ill drink I don't know how much is I'm just a man in the
main was a bell offer foxy you got a bad then Jesus also your print why did he
never talk to me I mean it was a bamboo stick oh my god like a whipping
stick oh my god well anyway at least we do it consensually no our rape old age
oh I didn't even know that was a thing does anyone have a bomb I'm spanking I'm
spanking God you guys are so good at this game just give me oh I didn't realize
you could cut the veins all that makes sense we are in a word so I don't really
know why we could cut the veins it's Estevan no Estevan's pretty she's a
pretty man they're all pretty Luna's very cute because she's so like bright and
colors because she had like doesn't Luna have like a light brown back or
something and it like she honestly looks like she's been photocopied or
something like that they're very cute as I said I wouldn't have thought much
about rats but then we embers came along and I have to admit I've got a wee
soft spot for them now because I'm just like oh that's me oh any other you know
like like new association yeah I've got it what is this oh this is the broken
temple of the elves fetch me there's so on ironically a spanking makes you behave
you make me cry in tears if you do it in a punishment can away oh no I didn't
sorry I didn't mean I a literally last second it clicked that that was the
grabber king of rat I just got cut head you're feeling very brave for playing
that game I would never even touch that attempt at the healing here someone
needs to heal now right now I'm not leaving until
oh my god I'm a medic oh my god I can heal the replays I'm a medic Stan still
Stan still I'm a certified nurse I promise
thank you for the 10 gifted memberships why are you what's going on why
from being something what's going on why is everyone being so nice to me today I
mean you're always nice to me but what why are we giving monetary value for
things I'm getting nervous did something happen am I supposed to do
something you already heal us with your voice thank you thank you be for the
10 gifted membership congrats to those who caught it with your face and for
those of you who don't know what that references it's not really a reference
but there is a character from kung fu chaos called candy and she sounds like
that and she goes in your face oh my god I can heal I'm healing the elf where's
the elf Stan still oh my god I'm healing you oh my god make it oh my god I'm such
a little healer you do not heal yourself all game and then the one time I
heal you I'm calling out that are you kidding me doesn't heal all game the
one time I finally do it literally so much trouble right now and took the
portion as well so now I'm pushing this feels good huh healing others yeah there's
a lot of things that go into making a man feel good you know that right maybe I
can help you do this thing how to achieve they gave you the portion back all
they did I don't know how you did that how did you did you pick pocket and
somehow put it back in portion smells right if I was hired by a game
development team this is how I would deliver the line oh that portions fall
and then this is how they would ask me to deliver it oh I the new that portions
meaning there you go that's what they want that's what they always ask for
oh my god medic time medic time hold on what one this one I'm healing I'm
healing I'm here please stop moving so I can heal you please hold okay there we
go healing did I put on the wrong person I put on the wrong person well that's
embarrassing right I'll let them fight I'm gonna go get the other thing and the
pop-chart oh yeah mommy Jimmy Bezu from generation one indulge her full legal
name where's the potion was it not here it's got 30 yes I am ecstatic I was
talking about it earlier it's so nice that we finally got like on the trending
for shorts and so I'm very happy I'm so glad for her and she actually has
another one that I think has potential I mean I see that about everyone's short
I'm like everything has potential to go viral because I love them and I'm bias
okay and but she recorded another one she says she doubts it's gonna be as
popular and I'm like I don't know there was a lot of goodness in it okay well
this looks like a boss fight if I've ever seen one a little battle dome a
little arena if you will Brian I can imagine all the pepsi floor and fan
mascot costumes oh my god stop I might need to commission that the girls would
absolutely adore that hold right hold on
hold on hold that thought
right don't don't leak it don't fucking leak it I'm gonna put in Jen chat right
now can you guys send me pictures of your pets when you're next available no
major rush it's just for I can't wait what would the excuse be no major rush
I just say no major rush I'm not even gonna in I'll just put I'll need to show
you Gimli and Vigo make sure you Gimli and Vigo because I want to show them
they're their friends from across the water is that believable is that
believable they're gonna be like strong he's fucking lost the plot what the
fuck is she on about is that believable I think that's believable oh I just want
to show Gimli and Vigo they're friends from across the water that's not
believable is price us well I mean I've come out with more crazy things I'm
sure it's fine thank you Blazing Reflink Senpai appreciate it I want to show my
cats pictures of rats I mean that's even worse when you say like that okay are
we okay what's the plan whisper with okay so the plan is whisper whisper as
we're gonna go in there whisper whisper and then we're gonna fuck them up okay
are they agree they agree does the elf agree does the elf agree to this plan
okay the elf goes mm-hmm very still it very still okay right you guys go first
cuz I don't know where to drop down okay I don't know where to go first I'm gonna
just let them do it okay oh wait it's like into the battle don't okay I thought
it was like a path down or something three real real line the ether ether we
need to put oh my god I need to protect I need to protect hold on him with a
pose I'm protecting I'm protecting I'm protecting I am alting did we do it wait
all three of us need to be on it huh oh my god no I'm messing up I'm so sorry I
understand I understand I'm so sorry we fling I just done did your work because
I'm really small-brained is that it okay that looks like it I'm so sorry don't
don't let me cook oh there's a refilling in trouble I'm not touching that I'm not
touching anything ever again without express consent because oh my god I don't
know how I met up myself I'm protecting I'm protecting Elena with a blue
little literally oh you mean that really obvious thing that's obvious that I
didn't do and completely messed up oh my god I was just so singing did did they
do it I don't need to I don't want to move anything I'm just gonna let the
reflins cook sorry I'm gonna let them cook I'm gonna just swing my sword okay
I'm gonna just take aggro I'm helping by taking aggro okay I'm taking aggro I'm
taking aggro why yes of course I'm helping my team yes and before this is
the only reason I get the most kills is because they're having to do puzzles
I'm just me man I like that how I'm gonna get getting their head in the
animation in the death animation like the detail of like chopping their wee
heads off it's a bit morbid okay it's a bit morbid but whoa I don't like that
next ASMR instead of let me hold it please let me touch it well at the
sequel to please let me hold it was gonna be let me stack donut rings on it I
don't know what you think about that I thought it was a good sequel and I'd
like continue and I'd be like right fine if you're not gonna let me hold it like
so I think I fall asleep at the end of please let me hold it so I was gonna
wake up and I was gonna be like I'm gonna go to the bakery and then you're like
why and I'm like because I'm gonna stack donuts on it obviously if you're not
willing to let me hold it at least let me stack donuts on it I do you want onion
rings what would you prefer onion rings or donuts I feel like doughnuts is the
mean though let me play horse shoe on it honestly
stand up shape up or shut up oh that's a good model
stand up shape up or shut up what is going on what did we do
did we do it well we certainly lose certainly lose like we did it mission
objective survive oh we already done we did it we did it we finished the elven
temple we finished the elven temple and no one died yeah mommy slips up by Agra
should I read that plot oh my god I have one person's pets confirmed already
they're falling for me they have truly no idea what we're oh I got talent point
cuz I'm so talented your next not safer order should be refilling has been fair
oh you're a fair moment we did it we did team disher we finned disher that map
how how do I have no accolades special kills elite killed range kill melee how
were you doing double what I'm doing damage dealt damage to monsters 107
that hit damage taken 150 headshot 71
headshots seem pretty easy like even sorry not easy hard carry the boys smell
coffee faster oh is that a boy a smell that's bro oh that's how I imagine I
would sound I might make that on a flume I might make that oh that's bro bye
thank you so much for playing me please okay team number six step up team number
six step up who's coming oh my gosh we have hydro stream snipe yet I don't need
them hydrum hold on we have ruin ex desolation whenever I read the word
desolation my only association with it is the desolation of small or small I
don't know how to say oh my god he's having me with him oh he's having the
grimpos well see the fit oh we've actually got a bit of a fit going on for
that the war why is your stuff going purple oh press I for
no talents okay increase power by 5% for everybody for every nearby enemy the
more the merrier increase cleaver power I'm not sure what that means every five
hits grants a critical strike but critical strikes can no longer occur
randomly the more the merrier I'm not sure I can't join for some reason I'm
gonna keep going so don't worry you have a really long days I can't see the
rest of it and we've got hydro ruin desolation and day one earth with this
team name be I'm looking at the fits the fits aren't saying much they're not
saying much I guess cleaving is your character's power so I guess leaving
limb split any cleaver the game has a bug in it where you can't join I don't
worry we're still playing for a while I'm not I ain't done yet Brian ladies
grab your lads and lads grab your gnats it's time to up the difficulty
mama okay only if I can do it though cuz I need to rely on the loot boxes to do
it thank you the booty Lord what we got ush it's so gonna put me up a level wait
that's putting me down I don't want to shield hold on let me open up all the
loot boxes and then I'll see if I can put it in I can't join the lobbies fill
but I'm still doing more missions I ain't done yet I'm supposed to like manually
open them up oh my god oh the dopamine I didn't get any I've had enough of you
loot boxes and your shenanigans oh it's a shield a talisman a charm
into the nest recruit no pickups will be found in the mission why would you want
right okay and then press inventory executioner sword whoa fight oh I got
an achievement quite the find equipped a rare item
handgun sure put it up and then necklace only have one a seal yes put it on
if it's better than what I got trinket respawn speed stamina recovery sure is
this enough to level up I don't know yet hold on is it let's do act to the
screaming bell I do like the little print the tinfoil has your both of it and
the will party does not meet requirement required hero power 115 is there a new
refling that's never played this game before in the lobby it would be you the
elf because you're only level five but you have an aborder that's not right wait
how does it look at my power okay well we'll put it up if the reflins oh sorry
wait I did that wrong difficulty we can't put it up right now but that's fine
we'll put it up the next game once all the reflins are qualified it's based on
your power
Sigma I've not named us what would your team be called I don't know what to call
it based on your name
water dragon turn on the dead water dragon team that's what a rubbish name I'll
name I'll name us something based on the map oh are we literally in a in a cave
let's call it the big wet cave this is our team name the big week and we all
know what that refers to the big no how about the gaping wet cave wildly
inappropriate okay that's what we're in I'm not making it weird it's literally
what we're in this spelunkers oh that's even better we did it reach the
screaming bell how why is your weapon purple I would like to know how I get
I assume maybe it's just level or something like that you hit him it's a
fancy skin Peter when I can't believe with the damage up I can't swing my
swinging my thing swingy swingy swing I think that's got runes on it I do be
extra savvy I wonder do I have extra reach because of my weapon type it must
have extra reach try holding down wait that wasn't enough to kill him where did
he go
I'm down look is gammy by gammy by origami and you're not see this is the
path weapons have different yeah I prefer the other one oh my
refling I'm sorry I was late to stream for literally one minute I'm sorry it's
a misunderstanding refling you don't have to drink yourself the dead no oh
shit I'm thinking of a cornered myself accident whoopsie
ultimate I think I'm okay I think I'm okay my first refling don't need to drink
because I'm late I'm reloading I'm so sorry that was a worst time that could
have gone anywhere else you better heal yourself and you should heal yourself
quite literally let me die weak when mommy's your point zero one seconds late
to stream death from alcohol poisoning after 30 beers I can't patch you up
because I don't have the cane that patches you up elf drink your elf
drink
how did I get a heal up I didn't even heal what does this elf have healing for
us all oh I'm not very familiar with the classes just yet but I assume I'm
probably gonna I'm getting out there hold on bomb a time
bomb a time I did it hey still up okay that's what I thought because he just
literally survived see for to the faith I'm gonna concentrate so hard I'm
concentrating so hard right now oh that's right all the ink I'm gonna
emulate read all your body language to know exactly what to do and what not to
do it's on fire join us I'm joining nothing I'm on the good side good guy
see you get again mommy's gonna concentrate all over her chair I mean
I'm about to one spoon in I don't know when we're going off though I'm enjoying
playing with me concentrate so much all of them oh god he's trying to recruit you
to MLM Sony just murdering that chaos we're literally nuke them spawn nuke them
and then shot once so this is where I sell my wares from our farm because we
would that's how we make our money we sell like whole organic like chicken
eggs and stuff and like whatever we're going oh why did he just ignore a g
just tell me I'm not sorry I hear whispers right in my ear when the
whispers are directional mummies and join the game and once the stream longer
how will I ever survive I can't believe it it's not possible honestly we might
actually finish late the first sequence at the rate we're going I do have food
that I can microwave if we need a break for a moment and actually maybe we should
do that how about after this round I'm gonna get foods I'll get a cola I'll
get water I'll rehydrate and I think we could probably finish this chapter I'm
not kidding weapons up fight like it's payday or I like this guy's phrases
fight like it's payday not to be confused with my day oh dear we fling I think
we're in a slight bit trouble but okay okay nope you're in trouble it's not me
I'm firing I'm firing he doesn't really seem to care much about me I'm gonna be
honest okay we're good we're good we're good don't worry about it don't worry
about it oh no I don't have my ultimate yeah I just used it so I'm gonna push
them off the edge of the map okay we fling same to go in these stocky I
don't that canny be comfy oh it's got spikes on it right if you remove the
spikes still in theory that canny be comfy like that would be the worst
milk in session ever sorry imagine yeah like literally being no like being
forced to stand up whilst like wait what's the emote button up no I've done
it again I'm no don't look and chat that's embarrassing I've forgotten what
one is stop oh I just use my right I can't stop no I don't know how I keep
typing why only that's that's too many things there's too much of a coinkie
dink going on okay okay let's go the next area cuz I'm embarrassed now the
mode is holding you okay I was gonna do that because the why is the chat button
my ridges these are an assassin I don't know what an assassin is we green one I'm
afraid I have yet to learn the enemy's names perhaps I will learn them whilst I
chow down on I love cranking it are you crank it oh yeah show me your crank
right now and by it I mean my gun oh you didn't even see it be my gun are you
cranking so hard right now oh yeah okay this is the new gun that we have to use
wait why are you what why did you just pass out after spelunking what do you I
don't have heels for you cranked too hard literally perished ran out of HP from
cranking like what no I'm not you're next stinky stinky fart man we are rubbish
design I've got a better design you get right leave my reeflings alone she says
she almost whacked one of them didn't recognize the dwarf with me when
strongy postage why you passed out you're all I'm spent I can't I can't do
any more we are swinging we are swinging
I mean my healing and by it I mean my healing
oh shit all the briefly needed it more she's sorry I'm a terrible medic I'm
sorry oh my god it is a man spank spank spank as we get for getting any ban for
we just can't even celebrate their key because you both but we don't actually
hit them let me take care of you never pass out from the blood for from the
one pump one pump up hold on a minute why am I getting into this he has
kannst only cranked I'm you so no why can't Oh
I like the cold on the rain and the sky is darkened and there's no helping some
oh my god heel pain right I need to heal the elf elf where are you
Elf stand still cuz I'm going to jerk my
Why why does no one one here am I actually that bad I made it no I say no no you didn't want my heels
No, no, I'm not saving you. You didn't want my heel. My feelings are hurting every feeling you've hurt my feelings
You must make it up to me
I'll be calling you a pop again. It's no no no no pop time. It's game time gamer time
For tonight
You want to save it for in their super low health not just a wee bit, but there are 50 health is this does this heal more than 50 I
Need percentages. I need fractions. Is it three fourths? Is it one half? Is it one thirds?
Where these medkits do why wouldn't you let mommy touch you exactly?
See there's some reeflings that are great for
What I
On higher difficulty here's are so rare get into the habit of not using them
Okay, oh
What was that? Oh, no, yeah, we boy
Destroy the screaming bell how the chains must be the chains it is the chains. Oh, yeah, oh
Oh
He looks like the guy from that one video game that has multiple additions pretty awesome
He looks like Kratos
Okay, there's three things already done that bill
Did you guys do how many man you guys work fast
Okay, it looks like over there is now
Ah
We can't help you everything. We're coming. We're coming. We're coming. I think I'm stuck. Okay shit shit
I I literally I don't know what to do. I can't help it. I can't see him. I
Fuck got myself stuck if anything you guys help on. Oh
My god, you fell off the map
Oh
I'm swinging and swinging. Okay, we take no gravity deaths today
Destroy the belt. Oh
The hordes are infinite
So when I started the game the tutorial thing was like there's never peace
So are we just fighting to stay alive really?
Over anything
That was really easy, I'm quite glad with that one. I have a bomb, too
Even need me I guess I do
The world is like mid-apocalypse so it never gets better trying to stop rat armageddon
What unique story
Ratmageddon
You will not succeed. So is it helpful like we never make it better
I'm cleavering
Got a side swipe all three of them. Oh, that's friendly. Sorry
I
Maybe need to put like an outline marker on you guys
Warhammer universe is actually a really dark place. Oh, that's such a shame
There is no happy ending at all. Oh, no, that's such a shame
I
Was like when like we defeat the evil and we get to live happily ever after that thing
Her warhammer fans wait, so when like a new installment or storyline or whatever comes out in Warhammer
Does everyone just unanimously accept it's gonna be like the most depressing literature they've ever read
Yes, it's always about I mean technically the gods
Decided forget this and then they went and made new iterations of the world, which is worth in the current
Orcs disagree universe plundered into chaos and ended battles their idea
Basically, yeah, but occasional moments of badass or something. Oh, that's GGs. That's such a shame. That's the lore
Like you just agree
In warhammer 40k suffering is your happiness and death is your only solace wait, so is death scene like
Is it very like oh you're very honored if you like got a lot of kills before you died type thing
It's called grim dark for a reason honestly though
Thank you stash power
See I'm getting educated about warhammer because he's a thing like oh you know warhammer whatever
But like if you make it sound oh, I actually did something I killed the most elite
Agro melee kills
Yes, I use a melee weapon and most revised
Oh, yeah
I'm so good
Thank you again stash power for that too much us the deeds will be called the emperor's finest as a quote
And warhammer 40k humans have to sacrifice themselves by millions a day for the survival of the race is that dark
Are pregnant people even a thing everything the deed not deep oh
The dead will be called the emperor's finest because they gave their lives for the empire
Grim dark no happiness or shining light there's only one small step forward and 20 back because of that one small step
No one mentioned dread not sir mungus death isn't even great because you automatically get sent to heck
Why?
That's so bizarre. Thank you Evelyn. Thank you. Thank you. I am gonna go
and get
drinky food and
some foods in my tum tum and
Then
We'll get the next group in and we'll do the next mission
But I heavily recommend we all get up and stretch and get some food and I'm gonna get
cola
Did you guys see that bird tick tock where the bird goes coca-cola and maybe money thing in war hammer
The best and you can hope for is one on your own terms
Also, most story lines end in blazes of glory or depending on what writer is on deck
Fucking stupid shine killing a whole bunch of nuns for fighting demons too. Well. Oh
Thank you, Chris
For the tip it's really funny hearing Brian say Scottish slang
What did you say really fucking stupid shy? Hold on. I'm getting Brian to say that again. That was really funny
In war hammer the best and you can hope for is one on your own terms
Also, most story lines end in blazes of glory or depending on what writer is on deck
Really fucking stupid
No good guys because even the art really good guy emperor meet like million souls a day to stay static
Whoa, I didn't realize how dark war hammer was
That's crazy
Enjoy the rest of the game and stream and proof when he says it rest well sleep well
And right I'm gonna quickly grab some food and then we'll bring in the next batch of hooligans
And and we'll have more streamstaping shenanigans. I didn't say we might actually be
Hold on. I'm just gonna check out the missions really quick to see what we're looking at
But I think we could definitely finish we may be able to finish up the first map
and
There's four maps, okay, so what we're already halfway
So it take me what four hours to get to here. Maybe five hours not a big deal
So then the next time we stream snipe it would be
There's only four levels
Wait we can finish the whole multiplayer theory
And
Not to yeah, okay, I think we're playing the whole damn game man, okay curious
Yeah, there is a race that has to do the most sadistic stuff to people
Like making people on the front you're keeping them conscious
Chaos God is a music
Burn the witch purge the heritage suffer not the Xeno to live
Yeah
Thank you so much very large
I'm guessing that's a quote from some other game
Everyone in all has iterations of Warhammer's fantasy 40k age of Sigmar isn't a but hold on
What do we burn apart from witches?
Wait, aren't we the Xeno? I don't know
Oh
Can do all map one now and then the two three four next time. I'll see how it goes. Okay, right. I'm gonna
Take a Pog's champus and I'm gonna go for a tinkle
I'm gonna heat up leftovers and we'll get some food and then we'll bring the next team in, okay?
and
But yeah, oh Xeno's are alien
There's aliens in this game as well
Okay, I will be a moment. Give me a couple of minutes, please
And please do hydrae and stretch and
Get some food as well and do a tinkle because it's not good to hold the lock
Do it do it now
Okay, I'm very bad. Give me four minutes four minutes pee and microwave stuff. I don't know, okay
How so sienna and neither the witch salt fire
Nor the disciplined wizard my tutor hopes to show
Well, that's
Good I used to think so but if I can't be one I must be the other that's what I was taught
Looks like the twin-tailed comics return salt spire, what do you make it speaks to dire time to have
But promises victory record old sigmo more might actually pitch in certainly if we deserve
You
You're an engineer now
Always was sudden in my heart
Just letting it shine if that's all good repression is bad for the spirit. I never repress anything
I have noticed
You
I
Thought in
We won't take a look at the action or more repeating handgun. It's sticking something fierce
Oh, so this is how it's going to be. Is it
Fixing all the people's weapons for you engineers love fixing things
Not sure about how the rest of us mistreat them. I've got a large part of that getting the complaining in the front
I
I heard loner speak of your father
He sounds like a stolen soul
I he was certainly that rigid inflexible
Certain of everything you see
Precisely the proper role model in this wicked world
He's all that too. I can't say he was wholly right about it
Hi, baby
I got cola I got water. I've got my chingney
I'm just opening the door because
Why are you gifting bro? I wasn't I was yeah, I'm okay. I'm not even on the pc
I'm amt
I'm literally half way across the room right now. I'm gonna open the door because the pc heats the room up
But the like the actual coast is full for the cat
Thank you so much
There's a gifted membership. Holy crap
What's going on? Is this because I posted my ass be honest?
What's going on?
Did anyone puke while I was away be honest?
Money ritual to summon mummy knows how it works for me
Not a part of my interest right? Who have we got on this beloved mission?
We have quests. We have callie
And we have gar funkel
I'm tempted to go back to karak gnawn and join the engineers
I'll be hold on I need to
Holds off. Excuse me real quick
And we're in like this like
Was too hot so I'm using it as a blanket. I picked a little bit but I cleaned it up like a big boy. Yeah
That's cute. I'm glad I left to get dinner and come back and spinny's left those
That's it. I'm never eating again
The people who have the most power within the empire have a code innocence proves nothing
Uh-huh
The people who have the most powers in the empire have a code innocent
Sticky shred, thank you for the super chat
Um, we didn't know that wait pearly
Pearly and more why why are you giving me so much money? What's going on?
Did I do something special to
earn this
It's not clicking. Why are you giving me so much money?
So my favorite war hammer 40 k lore is the orcs power of belief
If they believe in something no matter how broken or stupid it actually is it somehow just works
For example, the color red somehow makes them go faster. Are you squinting me?
Oh cars go
How much for my name to be written on that?
Brian
You can't ask questions like that
Um
Hold on
Uh, thank you stash power for the super chat and the booty lord
Favorite war hammer lore is the orc power of belief if they believe in something no matter how broken or stupid it is
It is
Momolo, what the fuck are you?
Please tell me you have no debts to your name. You're saving your money. You're eating well. You're eating steak every night
caveman eat meat like
Thank you so much for the gifted memberships. Please make sure you're looking after yourself first though. I promise you
Things are going very well a velar headquarters. Please don't worry. You don't have to do that. I'm very supported. Thank you
Holy shaito is is it war hammer that everyone's excited about?
Oh
My gosh, momolo cast get loved stony stony flails around at it. I'm like
Orc spaceships are just junk wait, there's space battles in this game. I thought it was
I thought it was medieval lore
Why it's not medieval is it?
at all
How much to get my name written on the cake?
uh
Oh, we're gonna discuss my doughnut thong shortly
Because I wanted to make sure that no one's gonna hate me or anything
A vermin tate is kind of because it's an apocalypse, but actual warhammers that sci-fi
Okay
Hmm
I'm a bit of a sucker for
Sorry, I'm choking. Excuse me
I think I'm a sucker for
medieval kind of sentence and sci-fi
um
Sci-fi fantasy
He don't okay. I'm eating right now. I'm so sorry. Uh
I need to refill for the battles ahead
Because how am I supposed to do all these fights with no energy in my body?
I saw I'll take the tentacle everyone
You're so direct today. I wonder why are you squiddling me right now?
Oh
Okay, that was good. I'll give you home. Thank you
4k is a spin-off in the year 40
Is it in it's not in the same world where you be and I'm eating
My chinese aunties noodles and they're delicious
For the butt of his job the butt of his job
Kinda same gods and similar story, but different same world before it doesn't use in the future. So humans did prevail
I know you guys have you know, I'm getting a hungry for cake right now. How odd you guys
It's funny because you're trying to summer up summarize something so expansive and vast for me to like comprehend
So it's like good good for me to take things at face value and be like
Okay, different universe, but kind of the same but later and there are gods
But I don't know what happens to the gods in the sci-fi part like it's good to take things at face value like that
I'm quite hungry for cake too now that you've mentioned it
How much to get you to take the photo again with the two on right? Oh no, don't let me do it again
Do you want me to reattempt it?
I can reattempt it. You don't have to give me any money to reattempt it. I was gonna post
Hey, I took a meme photo and then I took a video of me clapping while twerking
Mama two different universes that overlap warhammer fantasy
Vermintide setting is more comedical while still grim dark while warhammer 40k is full grim dark and futuristic
Oh
Okay
I see
I'll do it again and write 21
I mean I can write the one is the two is so hard because like
I have to stand up and basically twist my oh no someone left. Did you have to go?
No, someone left the lobby. I didn't take your name off the list. We lost our brother we did
If you forgot to a reef when I'm like, no, I'm not putting my tackle out there
Are you squidding me right now? I have glazed the donut for me mama
I shot so as I said I put coconut oil on me, but it never
No, no, no, sorry
You can hear it after string you're allowed to hear it when people ask we what's my favorite cake is
I say straw me shortcake
Unstable connection one sec, uh, you got sniped out of it unfortunate
You don't have to do anything you're not comfortable with me. Yeah, I know I don't
Although I completely shaved for it for some reason
Um, obviously I have the full full, but uh, yeah, I only put out the full full
Thank you, rilke kadmer's quest the booty lord 96 and gaming kitsune 99. Okay everyone
Stop giving me money and just use the chat feature. Um, no, I know it's crazy
But if you look a little bit to the right, uh, there's a chat box you can tape in there for free and see all those comments
You guys are giving me too much money and I'm starting to get I'm starting to get nervous. I'm getting a bit shaky. Okay
I am a goods and services tinder gal
Um, I've not put out enough goods
for the money
So let me cook a bit longer
I wasn't even trying to join. Oh, don't worry. We're playing for like another couple hours
Get supported get supported get supported
And we could do that there's a chat function
The money funds more warhammer
I'm not on the dev team for warhammer
I still
There's a chat feature wear underwear
Shut up and take my money
Honestly, it literally is that I've almost finished. Sorry. I'm eating noodles which causes me to suck them
And I know that it's not very nice hearing chewing sounds
Hmm
The last time I ate on stream
Oh, sorry, my stomach is internally farted if you heard that
Okay, we flimble bend over for a spanking because either way ink's coming out of you
Thank you bow star me caulker. Um
You've ever been much of a sporting short as on me
Coached a bit of middend ball back in the day
Oh
The money is if you ever decide to start buying warhammer it's called 40k because that's how much you got to invest
Thank you
Support for the bakery
It's free for a reason I didn't pay you all it for a reason it's a free reward
You're giving me money
For something that is a reward for a milestone you've already helped me achieve oh for fun sit right enough enough
I'm getting raging and I know
Enough right enough
Do you understand enough?
Enough
Let me air net let me upload more ASMR let me upload more free things. Okay, let me air net and can't just be giving me it
I
I'm financially stable. Don't worry. I hope so everyone fucking you better be financially stable
You better not be in debt. You better not have a shouldn't loan over your head. You better not have fish better not flat
Oh my I can't even read that word
Oh
What whoever left before rejoin it was Cali that's supposed to rejoin if he's able to get in
Oh my goodness
Me the engineers trade
It's so loud
Thank you
Mns 188. Thank you. Mo Malo for the gifted memberships again. Thank you. John omni
Thank you. Sleepy fennec and slam pu slam pu
Slamp you I'll slam you after this stream. I can assure you that much. Thank you the booty lord as well
No
What are you too good for my money take my coins and stimulate my lines
That's such a good motto, but
Right before anyone goes fendom relax, but if there ever was a fendom tuber, there's your fucking motto right there
For free
Every flim gave it to you. No copyright. No nothing
Because that's literally like the perfect motto for you
Give me your coin and I'll stimulate your lines. There you go. Oh, you're your fendom
Hmm
Stop donating mommy hates me. I like
Feeling like I've earned it. Oh, no. Wait quest is left quest. Did you just disconnect?
We were about to go in
How did you manage that? No
right
Let quest come in because he was supposed to do it with us
Don't go on the thing yet though. Don't go on the thing yet. Okay, we still can
Can he not come in? Oh
My god, oh my god, look at my baby
All of them
Wait, did I block the game? Wait, did I block you from being able to join because I just did that
Oh, yes, you're appearing offline invite to game
Does that work can we do veteran are you trolling you wouldn't wait it can't cancel it f10 to cancel right get that the fuck out of here
You have already earned it. Oh my god. They're dropping like flies
Vealers biggest haters straw knees on brain. She had to create her own enemy
But you do deserve the money. I
I like when
I feel like I've earned it and I've not put out enough content recently to earn it
Does that make sense? How many reeflings are left to play? I don't just quite a few to go
I've been waiting
Um
Sorry game crashes. I think you're like the your game is allowed to crash. It's not your fault. Uh, uh, fort
Brashen
Urgh, are they german?
Okay, we can do veteran our first veteran game
But you stream every day. Yeah, but streams are stress free. I don't get stressed streaming
I'm completely relaxed and devoid of any stress when I stream literally this is like
You know in like, I don't I don't I don't mean any nastiness when I say this but like
I'm either very lucky that I don't find it stressful. I don't find it chore. I don't find it
something that I dread like what I dread when I wake up is
Oh my god, I'm gonna sound tired on stream and the reeflings are gonna think I'm not interested when it's not
It's just I'm tired
And they're like I dread hitting end broadcast because then my brain floods itself with like you
Said you were gonna do this this this all these days ago and then you've done it type thing like that
That's what I'm at, you know
Take that what you said. Are you saying that inking for with us is stressful? Oh, no that part is not stressful. Are you don't?
We're gonna inking together
No, that's see like once the streams finish
I'm gonna get my 3d all set
Apparently it's under
You haven't missed a stream. Have you seen it?
What's better mummy or spawn plane we don't need more content to want to support you stream every day and make it all full
I'm glad you could
We'll never think that we know how much ever you think
Stop being nice to me. You're gonna try to make me cry whilst we're trying to destroy
We're trying to save the human race in vermin type
Okay, whoa, you're like a necromancer properly. Oh your hair's on fire like junk rat
Sorry, I have overwatch brain on
Him with a pose hold you him with a pose
Right the wind little one junk rat overwatch mentioned
Mummy the reasons here because you're in sickness and in health. We are here for you to love mummy no matter what
In sickness and in health
And brain worms and in confidence
Oh, what was that I'm pouched mummy is only allowed to leak after stream true and real
Oh
I have to say this is a very good game. I'll enjoy I hope I was received well
I feel like this is a very well polished game
So I hope it did well
Kill you need a bar
I love vermin type too. Okay, mummy is only just average among the best of the best
So it's not
I've been wondering mummy's past couple of streams handed out more content, but check these you can't find anything
My alt twitter
I put something new up and then I'm gonna put a meme up today in an audio
Fight like who's paid I I'm gonna get off the sledge. Yep. I'm getting off the sledge
I
Like is paid I
Right who or what
Okay, we're going we're going
I come with the ultimate
And ultimately accept your support or we will make you cry happy tears. Okay. I will accept your support. Thank you
I think I just find it hard
To be like
Thank you. And that's it. I want it to be like, thank you. Here's this. Thank you new a smart
Thank you meme that we made together
Thank you this stream that you want together like
And you're suggesting left for dead and I'm like well now that we can stream snipe each other
It's not a problem. Um
So of course we can play left for dead too, you know like that that's like my thank you
I guess
It's me. It's not just verbally like of course. I appreciate it. I just find
That there's
It's not that it's empty to say. Thank you
But for my personal preference, I just want to offer something a bit more. I want there
To be like so obviously if you support me
You know it helps out with the success of the girls as a whole basically
Like obviously we've got something exciting coming up, which I doubt anyone's gonna guess to be honest. So get fucked. Um
Type thing and then it also like helps with the success of me because um I
With my
Come once the you know the company
Um has made return on investment
I can start looking at my income and being like well, I think I can afford like an all outfit that maybe looks
Sorry, I'm burping up my foot. It looks like a bit more like me type thing and like
With that like I would do new role plays and new things and like the hypnosis streamer
Aren't really well. So I want to do more hypnosis stuff like I mean I always wanted to do hypnosis stuff, you know
Who goes there and you guys are finishing the length for me. You've got strong a brain roll. I'm sorry, but you've got level
You've got tier three strong a brain wrong. Sorry. You had to find out this way
Wow
Okay, let's go
Oh, that's the bomb
I do like the bomb mechanic in this game
But wait, is that a bomb a reference to the hit video game the binding of Isaac?
I can't see him. How did you snipe him? What the heck?
You must have been a college
We are gaining the strong to them. I'm rubbing off on you
I'm rubbing off. I've got my chair spinning on its own. I literally were sideways playing on my seat there
Where are we going?
Where are we going? No one's knowing although it looks like it's down here if I've ever seen a place to go
And before I've done this and I'm just dead on my own because I'm a dumb dumb
River ale I don't think I was supposed to come here
I don't think I was supposed to come here
I'm on my own. It's fine. I'm I'm I'm big girl big girl big strong girl not scared not scared at all
Not scared not scared not scared not scared not scared not scared. Okay. We've been saving me. Thank god. I wasn't gonna make it alive
Oh my night and shining harvest
Where have I gone? Oh, no, no that reefing's on his own
This is the worst week. I could have made this any worse or
Not to be confused worse the sire trout
Oh my gosh, I hope that other reefing's okay
I'm swinging. I'm swinging. I'm swinging. I'm swinging. I'm swinging. Okay. There we go. We're safe
What's that secret I don't know
The reeflings are here. I'm rubbing off on you. Yeah, I'm rubbing on you right
Open against it
Whoa, what's this?
Who's about to charge?
Oh, I see him
Ah
Sun look I stunned him. I stunned him. I'm helping. I'm helping. I'll be
I'll be I'm helping. I'm helping. I'm helping
Yay, I helped. Oh wait. We need teabag. I'm
He's all stitched together
I'm mutated or
Light work
Rat brothers rise stony calls for aids the reeflings will answer real answer
I follow the green outline. Follow the green
Follow the green outline
Some magic stuff going on over there or something I can hear a lot from the face
Ambience more hammer to ambient face more
No, I'm just following you. Don't don't look at me for directions. You're the one who's played this game. No me
Don't look at me. No, you go find the way you go. You gotta show me where those reeflings are
Is it this way? I'm standing guard. Okay. Okay. That's fair. Well, so I still have to figure out what the goal
Oh, wait, you guys were doing like a wrap around
The cake is posted stony calls for aids
Bro, I felt so brain dead like typing because I knew the numbers were wrong on my butt
So I was like typing and I was like I literally couldn't figure out how to like write it on myself
and
Like I just couldn't do the two and like my brain was short circuiting because I was like oh wipe off and do it again
But it's like I just never did it. I just like went for it. And I'm like, what was I thinking?
Oh
I'm just no very smart. I'm just no smart. Honestly. Oh my god. Wait, we're playing hard difficulty. Whoopsies
Who is brain like that?
Okay, I'm just fighting demons right now
Get out of here get out of here you stinky man
No one was focusing in on the numbers. Thank god
Thank god
Because it's really awful when I when I mentioned it and you guys were like there was numbers and I'm like, yeah
I drew on my
God, you guys were not kidding when you said there's literally no heels whatsoever as soon as you go up in difficulty
I'm trying to get some heels for you
Oh
Are we okay
I'm trying. Oh shit
Hopefully that works right a hipfire works in this game surely
If there's a spider on me right now, I think I'm going crazy
I was focused on something else the male brain is simple some may say
We playing there's a healing there. I think the I think the dwarf needs to heal in the most right now
Uh, I guess I'll hold on to the medical supply
Yes, thank you
I mean, I didn't notice the numbers. I mean, I love your honesty about it though. Like, yeah, I was focusing on something else
You like my book
Naughty you're all getting a spanking. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks
I
I'm happy to take up strings if you're anything. Are you watching my butt?
Thank you for the gift
We flings we're making a ring
Mummy you're rubbing off of me my thoughts or voice in my head. Have a Scottish accent now. Oh, stop. That's so cute
I love that so much
Oh my god, wait, I need to do like a heavy Scottish accent
Uh, what would your internal thoughts be? I have no idea
Actually, what is the average internal thought of a refling?
Please do not say puke
I'm here so you can't say puke. That's not allowed
I wasn't paying attention. I'm sorry. Uh, I think I'm gonna have to chug jug
Oh, dear. That was silly. Sorry. I should have paid more attention
I literally just got jumped. I don't pay attention for one second and vermin tight. I'm starting to understand why the lures like this
Get right get right get right. I'm reaching the inner courtyard. I'm reaching the inner courtyard so hard right now
Oh
I don't know if I hit him or not
Wow, I'm swinging
There's supplies here
What is it one mid kit? I'll carry it for oh, no, no, no, no. I need to heal you. I need to heal you
Oh
Oh my god, uh, this is hard with the totems on regular difficulty
This is not easy like we're already lower health than usual because of the totem
But the heels are non-existent
I thought you guys were being dramatic saying like oh
Okay
Oh my gosh, it's just an onslaught
They're never ending. How fast do they breed? Oh give me three of a hold on
Oh, I need to be able that was embarrassing. Oh, no, just
Took on so much unnecessary damage
Are we even going the right way? Yeah, we have to be what's the other leafland doing back here? Is he timed out?
Is he popping fireworks in there?
Is that a sound effect going wrong pick up a tone shisa right dad drink this
And confusion to our phones
Okay, okay, okay
They breed almost as fast as you
But it took me a year to birth my daughters, okay
There are five of them just dating in there
We gaming now
I think that I don't know if there's a sound effect that's misfiring right now. It sounds like fireworks popping
Sorry if you can hear that I can I can definitely hear it
If you alternate between heavy and light attack you can combo only sweep that's good against hoarders
I was not bluffing when I said the heels get rare. No, you weren't literally
I thought it was
this is like really bad
And the music's getting tense out of nowhere
Leave me alone
Take the ammo
Who defend the gate how to what's the point of defending anyone? There's no one here. No one's alive
It's just us and the onslaught
This spawn camp the gate I guess
I gotta cheat no one's one second
Fire the cannon at the cat poles, okay
Hold on. I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm coming to help. I'm coming to help. No, no, no, no, no
We're helping we're helping I don't have a heel unfortunately. I don't know where they're hiding any
Do we need to drop these totem things I don't know
I'm helping
Oh
You did it
aim
Aim at wall
I have no idea. I'll protect you. I don't know what I'm aiming at. I'm I'm just I'll
I'll pretend to freaking help
I'm spamming you aim it. I'm spamming. Don't worry. I'm fighting. I'm really good at shadow boxing. I promise
It's actually one of my favorite hobbies
They're not gonna give up their tomes they are loot boosters. Did I get more XP for them?
I mean, it definitely does make it harder since it steals all our HP
Oh
I'll get scared. I don't know if I'm gonna survive
Something bumped me in my butt something poisonous
Loot the cannon we're trying there's so much going on
Uh, I guess every time we get revived and picked up we have some of our health back
Oh my god, the cannon ball is all the way over there
Uh, uh, maybe I can take aggro. Is that even a thing in this game? I don't know
Oh my gosh, I don't know how to do the cannon ball. I assume it just bring over
Oh my god, there's so much growling. There's so much
Oh my goodness, is that you?
Are we winning? I think maybe I don't know. Oh no, we need to protect the reflin. They're really low
They're really low. I'm protecting. I'm shadow boxing so hard right now. They're not even spawned in and I'm already swinging on
I'll try no refling. Oh my god. I thought you dropped it
Did you do it? Is it done? Is it over? Is it over?
I destroyed the cat vault
Break the siege what we need to do that again
I don't think any of us have enough HP for doing that again
It reminds me of shibali and this is shibali
The growling is just the feral reflin
What are you doing nothing just swinging around
Follow the reflings follow the reflings
Help the reflings help the reflings stay with the reflings stay with the reflings
Escape through the bridge of shadows. I'm trying
I'm needing to adjust to my little gamer chair
His tentacles too slippery. He's dropping his balls. That doesn't work at all. Oh, we did it
We won our first veteran difficulty or whatever difficulty. We did it
We did it. We did it. We did our first victory on a hard mode on a hard mode
That was a bit more stressful
I didn't enjoy that there was less health. I I actually prefer the health being everywhere. I can't believe it
so
Grim wars gave us an extra 200
level up
Her a foot knight
I'll a sword and shield if I wanted to do that. I don't know. I quite like the big sweepy
the sweepy action
Let's start blocking and pushing. I don't even know I could push
Spoils of war chest upgraded
We get like a a chest every time
I'm observing the system. So depending on how well we do
We can upgrade a chest into like an ultimate one. So it means we get really well
We've saved
The foot knight
Did I get one thing? I didn't
Bra, I didn't get one thing. I got 69 headshots though. So nice
nice
Higher difficulties give better chest that tomes just multiply it
Okay, I mean are you playing against other people?
Uh, I'm playing with refling. I made a stream sniping account
So not anyone can add me but stream sniping adventures
The fortnight metal pan
I just
Emma
And I booted up my PC
Because I need me to get that fortnight battle
Oh, yeah
Things and stuff. Let's go open one, please since there's only one
I'm in the battle pass kicks and I can't stop I can't even stop singing that. I need to give that rest. Yeah rest. Yeah
All right
Uh
That one's a big boy
Got a big meaty swing tom. I'm sorry. It's it's not even it's not even closely. Did I even name us?
I didn't even name that team. I'm so sorry, right? What would quest cali
gir funkel
What would I even call that team
Wait, what's the name of the difficulty?
Veterans I'm just gonna call
As the veterans because we that was the first time we ever won on there
Thank you
Thanks for the game. Thank you call us the disconnectors. Okay, I'll put veterans and then underneath I'll put the disconnectors
Because we did have a few connection issues the neglected studio and the lost ones unarmed
Okay, you have moat on me
You're fun time's dead ahead
The forgotten
Okay, I put the verns the disconnectors and then the forgotten as well
No, wait the forgotten is like so negative. It's a sinky. Bye. Bye
Do you not miss the army life sergeant comrade and army comrades?
Comrade
I know we've got harsh actions. Let's get it on the verns. Okay
Tiger site, you haven't played with us before
No, you haven't okay tiger site
I will put your name down. Is there any other reef ones that haven't had a chance?
Dash power you haven't been in
And then who's gonna make up the third member that was fun. You enjoyed it
Yeah, you liked carrying me through the game and I didn't have to do anything because I'm I'm a weakling
Call me a weakling because I'm I'm weak and terrible like me
And I have awful reaction time as well. Is there any reefing that wants to invite themselves into the load?
I've added all friend requests. So yeah, if you've not had a chance yet
Dear strongy, I'm thinking of growing a mustache to see if it looks good on me. Can I borrow your your clam curls?
Does that mean fanny flaps be honest
Clam car rolls
Are we out of reeflings is everyone played?
If everyone has played oh, no, is that someone who hasn't played yet? Okay, no, there you go
You've not played
Written in the wrong color pen
Do the
Okay, we have tiger site. We have stash power and we have dodomo
On the right
I got my wisdom tooth pulled out because it was pushing on my other teeth and
They gave me kakora mod never had it before hold on wait, I'm gonna put my hoodie back on because I'm getting a bitch
I'm getting cold
On
She wrong is all right, I don't have the theme landing strip if you will. Oh, right. No
You didn't see the picture yesterday
Oh wait, I understand now. I get it. I get it. Oh my god. I'm so dumb
I understand what you mean by saying I want to test out a mustache. Okay, that makes sense
Okay, but the reason why it doesn't make sense with me in particular is because
I'm hairless
Okay, right played 400 vermin tide one, but only three hours of two. Oh no is vermin tide one better
Oh
People need to warn mommy
Yeah, so I've got my wisdom tooth taken out
And
Shawnee's confused because you asked for here she doesn't have basically I was like, hmm
Uh, I took kakora mall
I felt
Violently ill like so ill right we're gonna try vermin, but if I mess it up then we we'll get off it. Um
For about like 45 minutes like nausea sickness illness and then it just dissipates
Out of nowhere and like you feel so euphoric because
Like you don't feel sick anymore and like the pain kicks in and I was like, oh, I see why people are addicted to this now
Um, so I I didn't take it anymore after that. I was like, fuck. I'm not touching that shit again. Um
It made me
Sounds like an allergic reaction to
While strong is fat eager lass is indeed quite a burden to bear
I don't think there's a refling among us that would complain about carrying it. It was a pleasure
Oh, I didn't enjoy it. Thank you coif
Yeah, you guys like carrying me all the time
I'll maybe uh, you know how like the
The whenever it's like pharaohs that are depicted there. It's like cleopatra like on those like, um
It's like a platform that's held up by four people
Instead of that. It's just me being like touched on my butt and picked up by
Oh
My three reeflings in a war
and vermin type too, so
um
A pagoda
A pagoda is the platform
A palikin
You guys are giving me new vocabulary. I've not yet unlocked
Although we're in a dwarven mine
Back in the mine done and done your pickaxe from side to side side side to side
Palak palak palan king
Prince palakine
I'm
Enjoy learning new vocabulary though
It's funny
Well, I'm not sure I could live in a dwarven mine
I'd need to I need like a little nature strip in a patch and I feel like it'd be so cold and especially it would get so dark so quick
Who is
Garevelin
Oh, that's why
No, ow, I can't
Okay
You
Right, no
What are you
Okay, I need to be careful with my hp because we're not playing easy mode anymore. It must remember not an easy mode
Not an easy mode not easy mode
Don't be any worse than me
Me pray me praying that all the reeflings I'm playing with actually don't know where the
Okay, this is like a back off kind of thing. So if I block okay, I can like block and push back. Okay. I'm learning
Only been playing this game for three hours and I've discovered that I can do that. How lovely
Okay
Something took me long enough
I held off a heart on mine
How far away are you?
She's looese reefling
On the other side of the map
Are we playing legendary we're playing veteran right now
Actually, I've not named this team
You're all wearing green except green
Just instead of duck duck ghost is green green red. Okay. That'll instead of duck. Okay green
Green red. That's what we're called
Oh, I never even checked if the game was making my stream like have I been lagging
Have I been lagging this whole time and I've not paid attention
Could have almost now you're good. Okay. I'm glad uh, I'll pick this up for
Now, I guess and then I can heal a reefling if they go
I don't think so. It's okay. Okay. Literally. I got so excited to play with you guys
I forgot to do the old test that it's not lagging anything out
because sometimes um games will like lag out the
Beach of her model wait am I going great? Are we supposed to go here?
Oh, it's so bright
It's making me yawn. It's fake sunlight brain
It's fake sunlight
My brain
I've not been outside in so long. I just yawned at fake sunlight
That that's when you know, it's bad. That's when you know, it's bad
What yeah, because when you get exposed to the sun for some reason you
I'm trying
Vampires Johnny you're into the sun suck ink
Oh
Spamming
I
Don't know where I can't see anything
It's like chaos one minute as soon as that goes down. Oh god, that's so hypnotic though and making me sweepy
Kill the vermin before it throws
Okay, I got the ragged art. That's you know, we're doing good
Can you like sneak up on that you can't
No, oh he said fresh me. Oh he wants to eat me
Oh apparently it was board day the other day
I redirected into serenity from being here
And she was like in her mouth and I'm like, what if I just redirected into
I have no idea what's going on
I need to heal that reef one that's half health. I will heal you don't take one. Do I heal him? I don't know
Uh, uh, uh, I don't know. Hey, no, he's half health. That's dangerous
Okay, it only heals 50% so it wasn't always he has a potion
Well, someone has to be the heel slag of the team
Spank even though it was dead
It's funny trying so hard to be a pocket mirth. They were digging into the ego
I want to play overwatch together, but I don't think I'm allowed to because it's so boring
I think it's so boring. I'm not allowed to make it the stream snipe game
Because they released a new character called Juno who does healing and damage
Like from the same gun like Anna and I was like, oh, okay, I don't want to play
But I don't want to bore. I don't want to pick born
Oh, where you going?
Uh, what did I do? Did I just stand here?
Okay, I'm gonna just follow the reeflings. They seem convinced to go down this way. I'm a foal
I'm following the reef
A healing draw
That's actually quite scary when the game whispers randomly
Oh
Reefling no, I did nothing to help but hope you're okay
Right, let's get on this lift type thing
Everyone on the elevator
What did I just do
We're not are we moving
Did we
That was not a platform, okay
Oh, why is that reefling going that way? I don't know
Might as well grip up. I'd see no reason not to all things considered
Oh
Mr
Uh, I'm just following the reeflings. They want to go this way so follow the reefling reefling reefling follow the reefling
There's another boot
No big the lords are HP
We
Wait, you're going back haven't we already been here
Oh, what? Uh, this looks a little dangerous
Okay, how do we get back up we have to go around
Ah
Oh, that's why you went underneath because this is how to come out of it
It's not real there honestly. Hmm. This is clearly a lift because there's a platform and a lever
Why yes of
Okay, I'll the dwarven mains are very detailed though
I almost not too many believe them
I miss
She seems to stab pretty quickly
There's ammunition if someone wants to
I think those are basically all the books. I remember. Okay. That means we can have health this time
Maybe
Okay, it seems like to hit maybe I can get another
Oh, I never checked if I could upgrade my weapon after buying that batch like a open in that loot box batch. What's that? Okay
Hydrate moment. I can't believe it. I can't believe you're looking after me better than I am. Okay hydration check
Oh
There is a healing car do you guys want it more than me?
Our dad take it now. Okay. Let's let's not stall. Let's not stall. All right, let's go. Let's go
Last one is in the main car
How did that miss that was terrible right no one saw that I was embarrassing
Whoo, that's a lot
The names of the I like how the areas of the map all have different sections as well. It's not just like welcome to map
That's it
I may have to watch some vermin tide one gameplay because
I mean if this is
It but but just older then I don't see why
We couldn't be cheeky swords and try that game as well
Oh my goodness gentle gentle easy easy
Easy easy
Easy
That's a lot. That's enough slices
Oh my goodness
They don't need heels
They all need heels but me because I'm selfish and I keep chugging everything along the way
Okay
Don't think there's anything to go back on the original floor. Okay, right if it's one of those games
Or it's like well you played too. There's no much of a
Good, I wonder what our kd ratio is because this this is never end in fate
Neither reasons on the floor getting nervous when they like hold back. I'm like, am I going the wrong way?
Up the stairs to the right is a main for
In here, ah, I see
Okay, there's a healing draw in this main car for someone
They don't have it
Okay, there so some got here though
You've played too. Would you like to play
A wish a worst eight version worst graphics worst quality of life in a harsher grind full
Now when you put it like that
Play dark tide is dark tide a game
I've literally never heard of it. That sounds there. I don't mean it isn't like I've never heard this game
I'm not gonna bother. I mean like I just
Haven't heard of dark tide would be
Hick for something similar but different. Oh
God those things are like so freaking
Fourth coming they don't even like winding down your first
They start shredding you. Um
Mr. Mann. Yeah, you need drink
Oh
I can't even I'm literally
Oh, no, I'm stout grieflings. I can't do anything. You're just gonna have to come and save me
Hmm
Dark tide is like this but sitting so it's very untied but with guns. Okay. Okay. I might consider it. I might consider
Let him get up
I'll look at gameplay a vermin type one just out of curiosity and then I'll look at dark tide
Um when that game came out, um
Hell divers
Sorry, I need to
You know what
You know, it would be funny if I was a cheeky shit
I would mute the stream and two but then
Far down the mic to the reeflands in game
And no one would believe them
No one would believe them. Why would they?
Um, I don't know if the elf elf. Do you want to heal on that just so we don't leave it behind?
No, how we didn't they couldn't prove it. I still have your stream open. You know, yeah
That's fine. But what I'm saying is
Would anyone believe you?
That I muted and then farted and the make in game audio. It's not like you're recording it
Why would you record it?
Revolting could be worse. Don't me it right. Shall we take shall we go?
Shall we shall we shall we shall we?
Reach the top and don't stop
I reach the top and I can't stop and that's what's bothering me
Should we do I want to be like you?
I want to walk like you stop like you
Shoo shoo dooby-doo
I need it to again
Oh, no way it turned around just as I was lining up the shore
The fiend is down. Oh, I hear him. I hear the grabby boy. The grabby boy is coming
Okay, oh hook route that's what you told
Grabby boy, who do we get to the top right? I'm taking the stairs
Okay
Get this
That scares me every time they do that
You two just shut it shut your gob
I see that'd be me if I was like
Shut your gob
Where are we going over here?
I I do hate that rattling. I can't get them
I don't know how I'm supposed to do that
We're called uberserk. Oh my god, we have a team name. We're called uberserk
Oh, that's so cool. Oh my god, we're like a hero's team. We're literally the avengers
Or more hammer the ubers right five. Oh, so you can't have more than five
Oh, I have a bomb. I have a bomb bomb
Okay. Well, uh, no one's no, I didn't I didn't miss. It was a miss
That was absolutely terrible. I couldn't have messed it up anymore
Even your fire
Okay, we did it
I can't believe the if he stayed up there that would have hit but that bomb was absolutely awful
If we find any heels it needs to go to the me
You
Two and a half millennia
Is there no heels at all? Oh healing. I see healing
I will heal. Oh, oh shit
Uh reefling that needs help reefling mage come off. I need to pick up the book again
reefling mage come out
It's a gun right oh wait you healed shit
Uh elft up it on you
My quivers dry, uh, it would be dry, wouldn't it? She's such a tight tight bitch
There I healed I'm such a good healer
Oh, wait that thing's coming out. Oh
Oh
Where do we go now? Oh wait, I dropped that book. I need to go pick it up again
No, okay, you guys are holding books for me. Okay. Teehee. Sorry. I'm really small brained. Where are we going?
Here here. Okay. I'm following. I'm hmm. Oh, yeah. Okay. Okay. We're back on track. Sorry
Got a bit distracted there. I didn't uh, I didn't quite know what the heck I was doing my apologies
For being a fake gamer
Ooh, I picked up some ravaged art
Unfortunately those glows aren't healing but I'll deal with it
Healing
Another witch hunter got it nice
Shawnee later insane
I don't know why whatever like a lemon says the word dry. My mind is just like
Oh my god
Oops
Okay, I need to stop getting distracted. We're not playing on easy mode
Stop getting distracted. Oh, no. I messed that up so badly
Oh, no, no, no, no
Okay, oh
Okay
Okay, I need to try hard. I need to try hard. I can't go down the reeflings need me
They'll start puking down the make-and-game if I end up dying
I could heal myself. I don't want to be selfish though. She won't I might let you heal myself or do someone else want the skill
Hmm
If no one picks it up, I'm gonna heal myself
Okay, yeah, okay. I got it. Okay. Someone wants potion of concentration
No
Shawnee if I refilling without that HP, would you want to keep them to heal? Yeah
So I can do too much
But it's more valuable if the reeflings are alive than me because I don't know what I'm doing
I'm literally just swinging and tingling in right now
There's more healing at the boss boss
There's no more
In this level in particular
There's no more me. I don't I think I need to heal this reef one. Hold on. You don't need help
There we go
Mommy has low self esteem
I don't have much confidence in my video. I wouldn't say it ruins my like self esteem or anything
But I'm aware. I'm just not a very strong gamer. I just enjoy games though. Like I enjoy gaming have fun
Why am I getting a black reared? Am I missing something?
What happened I just lost all my HP for like nothing
No, if you want to go for mass insecurities, uh, you need to go for
I don't know
I can't I don't have any insecurities and hypnosis anymore because you guys were so nice to me about
About my hypnosis stream. So like I feel really confident and like that I can pursue what I want to enjoy with the hypnosis
um
Like I'm not
Yeah, I don't have low self esteem. Like I know I'm bad at games
Like if I know I'm bad at something it doesn't
Why am I in a ditch? I literally just fell in the water
um
I don't even like insecure
I
Try to think of anything but you guys are so reassuring like I just feel good about everything
and
Yeah
You guys look after me so well. I don't really have any insecurities anymore
Like maybe at the start of streaming. Yeah
Uh, but now it's just like, I don't know we're having fun. We're giving off. There's not really anything at all
You're loud stinky parts. Yeah, sure. I'm I'm so embarrassed about them
I'm gonna be honest. If it wasn't taboo, I'd be fucking farting down the mic. All I please
I said what I said
Um, but because it's taboo, I don't do it
I
Cause it's been made embarrassing. I get embarrassed
That my root is too emic shitty boy
Insecurities you can secure ease knots exactly. Thank you the beauty lord, but it's truly
I thought that was music starting up. That sounded like the
Mm-hmm
Spirit of the sky
That's where I'm gonna go
When I die, right
Hydration check and we're about to do a boss fight. I'm a chug maku
Okay
We feel okay, they need to heal more than I do
Uh, so what I have a heel you have a heel
I will heal myself pick this up and then I can heal someone on the battlefields. Oh, there's even more
Strony, what's chug ma?
Chug on my balls or something like that. I assume I've just walked into that
I don't know what
Chug maku
Got um too easy. What is it?
It doesn't even sound like a sentence like oh chug ma chug ma ink
I'm no scared of this boss fight
I'm terrified
I assume we can't hurt him. He's called the spain mangler
Well, we did it now. Who's got a bomber?
Why are you going for me? Oh my god, he doesn't get stun locked when I do my ultimate
Oh my god, he doesn't take damage
Oh my god, I don't know if we can do it
What
No, no, no, it's not happening
No, no, no, no, no
Oh, no. Obliet
I can't get up. What the fuck on your feet? Kruber? Kruber's trying
I'm fucking trying. Oh my god, wait, so I only have temporary health
Okay, how do I heal them?
Escape. Did we just run to the end before we die?
Oh, no, that's like the first time we've almost perished
Is this the way?
Uh, okay
Are we gonna make?
Mummy down, I know
One day I'll learn about blocking. I don't know what you're talking about
I don't know what the armor is. Can I upgrade my armor?
You know, do we? I'm not quite
Uh, is there a mage about to go down because of lack of heals?
Look see
I'll survive. Are you sure you're like temporary one HP and a dream?
I'm trying. I'm trying. I don't know. Oh, there's the stone
Are you gonna make it?
Imagine if you really needed revive just before we enter. We did it. Oh my gosh, Tisville flesh then
Striking back complete act two
Victorious into the nest
Okay, we can still maintain veteran difficulty
Okay, I'm gonna unlock me lootie box
And then
I'm gonna upgrade my thing
And then we go for act three
Yeah
So we've got a regular a peasant spoils. It's now called commoners coffer merchant coffer
Uh
Oh no
We got a soldier's coffer
Okay
One day I will not be the weakest member of the team
Today is still not that day
Did 3000 damage?
One two
Are we gonna play this again another time? I'd like to if we don't like finish the full campaign
I think what we'll do we'll do like is it chapter one we're doing right now chapter one acts one to four
and
And then
We'll come back to it another time like as I said now that I've got a steam account for stream sniping
You have one hour and it will be tomorrow to try and be a different day
It's 8 a.m. It doesn't work like that for me
um
But yeah, no, I'm definitely I'm happy with this game. I enjoy it thoroughly. I'm having a good time. I believe
It's not putting you to sleep so much
Let's do the other chapters in another stream
Oh, but I was gonna finish like this first this one here. Wait, hold on. Let me show you
Sun's going down
Dark deeds away. Thanks for the game. Thank you for playing. Yeah, we'll do this one
So we're going to finish act three and four and then that's that one done
And then we'll do these three together. I don't know. Do we buy the dlc or not?
Get out here. Jesus
I'm trying to give me a heart attack
Just wanted to see what was actually inside not fucking that
It's still on saturday you finished the first two chapters already. No these
We'll do act three and four today because that's only one two three four five
Five five new
guys
Mommy it says two new friends of class. Yeah, sorry
Right, hopefully you guys can carry me
Let me get you in
Okay
Who's not played
Uh, I don't know if the reeflings are starting to go to bed. I'm not sure
If you
You can literally just join my lobby once you accept it on my friends request list
singing my barber
and if you've not played
Then come join in if you have played with me not yet save the dlc for if you really enjoy the game. Okay
Yeah, but only hell. Yeah, only the first one to do
Um
I don't know how to say here in japanese
Thanks for the stream strong bond
Strong boom has everyone had a turn yet. I don't possibly
Goodbye to those who go thank you
Hang in
Wait, no, wait, that's not one there's a one one here. Thank you brain
Are we running out of reeflings? I think I might have successfully stream sniped all the reeflings
That want to play. Is there anyone in chat that hasn't played and is added but it's not happening
That's not had a chance. I haven't been in yet. Are you all my friends was?
Are you are you broke?
Is it not working because sometimes there's a glitch apparently just says you're on
Playing other games monster world, you nerd
It speaks to dire time. Wait, there's a warhammer three. No, no, sorry. I thought that said vermin type three
I misunderstood
It says it's full it's not
It can't be there's only two of us in here
I was trying to see your eyes. I believe you. Oh my god. You're like pirated out the weather. Oh, you have like
I can sign you up with a minimum of procedure and paper
The connections timing out check that game chat if someone's trying to join
No, only two have registered
You gotta try hell diver
You guys don't need to carry me in hell divers. I did play it
But I struggled to get into it, but I only played it when it first came out. There's only two people
I need to remake the lobby
Sometimes if you're offline invisible doesn't work. I'm not offline. I'm online. It says there's four people in my lobby. What the heck
How is there four people and I'm online?
I
Just to say there's four people in my lobby. There's only two
It's bugged. I can't join. Okay. How do I
Quit I mean exit to main menu. Are you sure?
Right, okay, we'll get the
Sorry
No, no, don't give me cut scenes
Okay, gazillionaire and ta'odomo you both come in
Because you were like already in if that makes sense
I feel weird about hell divers after what that sony situation
Yeah, and then the worst part is they made the development team take all the flak for their decisions, which I cannot stand for the life of me
Is that a galleon gun? Did I just unlock a galleon?
I think I think it is
What we got 50
Power mean fast attacks wide sweeps cloud crowd to put cloud control
Wait, that's only that's just a wee mallet thing
Yeah, I want like a big two-handed like f you equipment
Hold on head empty. No thoughts just the third
And together we will make
I don't know gazillionaire ta'odomo head empty. No thoughts
Speaking of head empty. No thoughts clearly me
Cloud control silver nitrates
Real answer this
Sure, I'll try whatever this is one. Oh
Oh, I love that. I'm here for that
My stamina my 28 percent push block angle. I think that actually sounds really good though
But time feel
increase the duration of potions
I don't even mess with potions. I hate the temporary stuff. Lucky rat skill. It's Demi's rat skill from her design
16 percent stamina recovery. Sure. I'll sit down
Strongest
Try holding
So that's what my stamina bar is this little thing with the gun
And just forever
Oh my god, ASMR
ASMR
Oh, yeah, you feel the tingles. Are you feel the tingles? However you like happen
We are going to play against the grain
Rot to blood raiding parties are cutting loose and the fields are browned us then again
I don't need to tell you what that means for the poor
That live in their path
You're heading to morgan's loft biggest farm in the area if there are survivors
And I hope there are you'll find them health captive do what you can every prisoner freed
Is one less slave used by the enemy and repay
the dead in kind
if you follow
And we pay the dead in kind if you follow
What does that mean? I don't know. I don't understand
And the trinkets lock and try equipping something with curse resistance
And I don't have anything
I'm too much of a baby
Level
In we go take one of them out for everyone they took out
She actually has a denial
Where did that come from am I being dumb? I don't need to tell you what that means for the poor bastards in their path
You're heading to morgan's loft shoot while holding the right click
If there are survivors, oh hold right click and then shoot the gun. Oh
You read the gun up in the fire. Oh, I thought you were showing me that I could wind it up. Sorry
Oh, I just realized
Maybe I should be the elf if I like the fire we should he make to eat in the background
I'm read love the gun in the fire
I
Didn't pretend to be scarecrows
Oh my god, I love this
Okay, maybe I should be a gun specialist
Hold on a minute that that 40 key warhammer game doesn't sound so bad now that I'm playing with guns
Hold on a minute
Maybe we'll be getting that one in
Not instead as well as
That's fun. I like that
Oh my god, is there a little farm head together?
Oh
Okay, let's go
Swing swing swing
Are you proud of me? I use bloke for the first time. I didn't even know there were more of them
No, no, no, no leave me fling alone stop it. Are you alive?
I'd rather just swing on the wee one
I'm proud of my streamer. I'm did it. I blocked I'm sometimes walking
Something's dribbling
I'm swinging
The little pickaxe that then
Wait, hold on
Is my heavy attack a big sweep or is I like that? What's this?
A bomb bar
Uh, uh, you need it more than I do. How do I give the healing drop to the elf?
The elf requires a healing drop. Where's that? How do I give it to you?
We've done the wrong way
Uh, oh no, we just claim over
Ha, ha, sorry. I had to stand on them now that I'm using the block. Can't let them know
Can't go go let them hook up
It only took me what four hours to learn how to block properly
Oh my god, absolutely just raking and dakin
You mean I could have blocked from the start
I mean
Oh wait his armor protects them
Oh, I do thoroughly enjoy
Hey
That gun
Thoroughly enjoy that bad boy
You can push by attacking while blocking
Mm-hmm. Oh dear. I believe they've killed the townspeople
Strangely, I say this unironically. There are folk that get up to legendary difficulty without ever learning a block properly
Honestly me if we kept going
I'm wondering if we could test out a difficulty like ramp it up
And only my best warrior reeflings are allowed to show up and we'll see if we can we won't do any of the tomes though
I don't want any tome problems
Oh
Wow, I love this
Okay, I don't know where the poison one is but I have to admit this is mighty satisfying this gun
Wow, wow, I'm loving this
Oh
Next you need to learn how to dodge. Oh god. What is it left jump?
Assassin
Oh, did you see that embo right on his freaking head? Oh, there's a healing if someone needs it
Hmm, I'll take the med kit so I can heal someone manually and then someone can take the potions
There's a potion back there
How are you liking vermin tide any possible dark to you awesome saying a dark date check her pc. She's bought
How dare you these are my me fling
Yeah, we're in the game with me earlier. What are you talking about bought and I can't be bought in
The religion doesn't even match together
And if the game literally is like this
Like dark tide but with guns. I'm gonna watch some gameplay of dark tides
Because I'm loving this gun. I didn't realize you had like such a variety on the weaponry
I'm very nice very satisfying
It's far more gun focused. It's adorable how you love healing us wait until we play over watch if you like me
Though the horns are scary because I know that means like it's gonna be bad
They're good at doing like the music tension like the string kind of island
Type bill there's enemies approaching type stuff
Uh, it's so satisfying when like all four of us come together and just like swipe swipe swipe
They can't even get a hit in because of how much we're decimating them
I'm wondering if I actually aimed it would do anything different, but I don't think so
Oh
I had to I had to I had to give him the false impression that he could swing on man
There's an enemy inside
There's an enemy there's a mage
Oh
What
There's a mage doing something but we're not interested. Sorry don't come to the door
Is this a dead end? No
Oh, it is a dead end. I thought we were climbing through that hole you can fit in it
Can't you dwarf?
Uh, right so that was a dead end that's okay
Dark tide is fun, but you have a preference for vermin tide. You can bomb the end of the barrel to open it. Oh
Oh, did we mess up the barrel by accident?
Was there a secret that way?
And we got a bit too excited
Oh, he can take three hits
Hmm what
No, I'll loot that. Why not?
I've got a key
Oh
Uh, would you like
That sorry it took me so long to register something bad was happening there. I was like, yes. Yes
What am I doing? Unlock and go through the barn. Okay to the barn to the window
to the barn
so the heads fall off the
vermin tide
Is that the name of the enemies or just like this section of the world?
Let me in knock knock
Knock I
Am
I don't know why my gamer senses weren't tingling
There that was probably the most obvious thing because like why did the doors not open right away?
I'm trying
I'm trying I'm taking agricultural. I'm about
Oh
Oh my goodness
Okay, who needs heels the most I think I might now actually need heels for
I'm being selfish. I'm sorry
Go on without me. I've disgraced you from my gameplay. The rats are called Gavin
Vermintaid is like an army of the Ratman. Okay, we will destroy the Vermintaid
The army we would we will destroy the army. We will destroy the Vermintaid
We will destroy. Yeah, it can't be. Ah, that doesn't make sense
Claiming the letter claimy claim. It's pronounced gave in
Yeah, they're all hanging
That's your ultimate
I'm just falling. Oh, there's a bookie
He got it home. A Vermintaid is what happens when the scaven don't back stab each other for a week
You mean they actually learn to cooperate and now they may
Oh my Vamo, I can't shoot them
Okay, that was good cuz I literally was over
Me fly
Reload smooth
I
Can't I don't I don't even know how to ping in this game. I don't think they have a ping system
Vermintaid is their world for the apocalypse season of vermin maxing. Okay
It should be the main one getting healed as you skills, which you should use more gives temp health
I think I'm so low level. I'm not at that bit yet
They're so dramatic I
Like how they're just hanging out. They're like, yeah, I was on patrol yesterday. The boss didn't give me a raise
Oh my god, I like slicing them in half rather satisfying when limbs and heads start
Your all gives you and everyone else
I don't know the music
But I don't think
Spooky scary vermin tape with all the rest of plunder
I don't know the lore, but I don't have to know
As you feel there's so soon a pom-pom spooky
I'm swinging hard as I can. I'm using my ultimate to gain temporary HP
I'm trying I can't do that the same time it's like picking up
What happens when he sucks me
No leave my replaying alone don't do that again
I
Don't have any I still don't have any munitions does anyone have anything
Okay, right we do have some ammunition at least as I'm really listening to any song exit. I got you
I'll start singing Mary season
I won't you
I was a really difficult song for her to sing that was probably
If I had to rank all the songs for the difficulty levels Mercy got the most difficult assigned to her
Defo-defo-defo
Me I was just shitposting so I don't count. Oh, look at that dodge. Oh
Oh my god, this reference so good. Oh, you're blocked. Oh
My gosh, that's all them schmooze
Johnny that was ammo behind you. Well, I am special needs
I
Strongly if you ever have a moment I'd strongly recommend listening to the doom of carbs our short story
Is that a warhammer story?
Do people is it like okay? This is gonna sound really bad, but in the scp world and people can
I'm suck so badly. I suck so badly. I'm so sorry
Um, I'm so sorry again just whacked it
And
The NACP people can like voice stories about the world is like warhammer like that. That was that is thank you
Craig guardsman
Push attack on great stars. I'm gonna
Breaks their poise as well. Take that. That's what I think about your poise. Oh
I don't like that
Free all the prisoners
I'm trying
Yeah, the more hammer fan base has tons of folks that do that kind of content
Okay, okay, okay, I understand it. I'm learning more and learning more so people can like also do there. Please let me in. Oh
What are we doing in here? Are we having a moment? No, are we not supposed to be in here? Oh
Okay, okay, we were just taking a moment to recover that's all
Hold your attack while blocking it said downward it does a downward slash
Yes, I see it
We're definitely low on heels
I
Don't like this
And just hope they can save back far enough some left on my own devices
Did any writer on lyrics for the song? I've never heard of that version. No, I'm
Gotta only know her current performance name. She's uh, um
Since hour since hour was the both AC and me covered a sins song
and
What I tried to do was cover a popular song that was similar to the theme of the girl so
And Amy did a song about pumpkins because she's a little pumpkin if you haven't figured it out yet
She has a voodoo doll, but she's also an adorable little pumpkin
And I see as a polar bear and she's totally not a furry
So she did a song cover that's called like him for that furry ship
Mersey did why won't you notice me senpai because she's a yandere she be did doing your mum because she's like a milf and
Azura did boobs in the thumbnail just because she has absolute fucking massive honkers really and then I did
I'm just a memer but like obviously I could kind of choose it's not like there's a popular song about cuttlefish out there
That's like really well-known and mean if I so I tried to make them related to the girls because most
Agencies like they want like a super try hard song and you know
Maybe like a Japanese cover of a really popular song type thing and it's like just
Just some you know if the girls want to do any other song covers that's fine
But that's what I asked them to do for debut and if anyone wants to go further. They're more than welcome to it
It's not a problem an issue anything like of that need. I'm so down here. I'm so dead
I
Give everyone that temporary HP
No, I'm getting I'm not gonna survive this little thing. I
Don't think I'm
Gives up it's probably better every fling has at the me because I have self-heals
Yeah, you guys take the healing because I have my temp stuff as well
So I can constantly pick myself up with that rubbish
That I heal
As there is close to ten thousand
Everyone and then I can release the artwork. I'm so excited for you all to see it
I want to see everyone's reaction to it in the comments on Twitter
There's a cost a pretty penny and it was kind of like a start of course that I didn't have to do
But I wanted to do it because I wanted to see us all together and it's very cute
Those are human. Sorry. Those are humans
Every fun war I've also had to the old world war
They have this thing the cancel of 13 and the one seat is left empty for their god
Oh, I like that kind of stuff where they have like symbolism and all that. Oh my god. Are you okay?
I
Was he not dead?
He's just fucking going apeshit in there. Oh
My god, are you?
How I
Just got absolutely mental he was a whirlwind and world-winding through that
I'm trying to like catch the ones that get stuck behind us
You stop that
God they keep coming. Oh, it's the end of the map. Sorry. I'm holding this up. Sorry. It's the end of the map
Wayward stone wayward stone
And I shoot from in here
Are we in
Return me to the soil as opposed to what the strats we are darling
He's a slayer his whole thing is going apeshit berserker to war honestly
I just turned around and look at the the pathway out of the barn and there's like 50 surrounding
I'm just whirlwind and through them
We did it because I didn't name the team. I'm struggling to name teams now. I'm being so dumb
Asking not to be cremated. I don't know what to name the
What do we do?
That was how don't move okay, I'll say don't go
And then the answer is
I'll put doko equals cocoa because you can't ask me where I am when I'm here every day
every day
I got an accolade
Look I got saved. I have to boot any move myself at the way, but look I got saved. I
Have an accolade one save. I did it. I'm the healer
I'm doing all
While many people do narrate the stories unlike SCP the whole Warhammer universe isn't public domain
So performance rights aren't necessarily guaranteed
Also, hooray for stroneys horde shoot a rock. We'll have her on deep rock before long
Deep rock galactica has guns
Thank you
Thank you for playing
How many mission I don't think we have hardly any mission
I know you're trying to be curious and say thank you. Thanks mom. Thanks
What are we go? I think we're like hardly anything left
Empire and flames. We've got one two three four maps left and then we're done
We have done
Part two one. Okay
Is there any refling he would like to play that hasn't been able to play?
Who's the next bunch of refling let's find it I'd play deep rock any day
There is a means of Moria game that we could play together
I was gonna try and find Veeja Bruce to the but I think we'd get to bored of it cuz it's Lord of the Rings
And I'll fill up with it cuz it's Lord of the Rings even though I think the mechanics weren't that good or something
I can't remember what the feedback was on that game, but it's like mechanics are a bit okay
I've played already so I'll wait until we know
Anybody else who hasn't gone yet
Speak now in the YouTube chat or forever hold your peace. Okay
How does one join so you can add me on steam because I have a streamsnaping steam account called
Strony snakes and if you have vermin take two don't buy it just to play with me because I'm really sure the game and
Just as a disclaimer and but it means we can play streamsnap games together and I
Wait to since I did
Yeah, I still haven't gone in but it's looking like my connections when I love it
Join your game, haha, no, I can get you in my game
I'm going to buy it so I can play with you next time buying four copies. No, that's not how you're supposed to do
The Lord of the Ring games with Dorf was like a survival gathering game, but had fun parts
Yeah, I think it was like
When a dwarf disgraces themselves so bad they have to go into exile they become a slayer
They swear off armor and turn their hair into orange mohawks. Oh, they're not killing shit
They're depressed about not being dead yet and drinking
That's a very
specifically I
Think we ran out I forgot to install the game on you
Oh, okay, peppermint you've not played have you?
Bro
Gotta eat copies
You gotta buy double-digit amount of copies of nice anything else
Oh
No one has a claim to the game that everyone's played that wants to pay
Then
Did she say I had to buy it to all the reasons stop it
to
What getting 10 copies of vermin tide 10 of dark tide are we running it back with old reasons?
I
Unless someone wants to make a claim that they're trying to get in doctor. No shame. Thank you for coming to memba
I appreciate it. Is anyone claiming that they've not had a shot yet and
They want in but they can't get in or something
As everyone added me that can add me I'm called Stony Snipes and I'm on Berman tide
No one's claiming so I guess any reefing that would like to flee I claim to have a shot but no environment
Can't wait for the strong and call sponsored vermin time to string into your arms. I'm really enjoying this
I think I might force you to play overwatch with me
Okay peppermint
Is it lit and okay stash
power and
Then have fun
Have fun and have fun like my clothes. Damn. I was too slow. I can't in the moment. I'm cooking dinner
And there's four of four
Glacier alright, this is team. Glacier. Oh my god
Glacier the way to spell that way like it team. Glacier. All right
I'll get an exit. Yes. Oh my god, your skin is actually rather terrifying
The fire is burning you alive in there seems like an old mate of mine has been whispering in balthas are guilty
Emporium of wonders. Oh
Oh
Kill yourself
Sorry, that was a bit dramatic
I kind of be arsed when games do that when they put something in it looks like something you should interact with and then the games like
Party does not meet the requirement. Okay, we're going back down to recruit. Thank the fucking maker. I can go back down to recruit and
Minecraft and
So you buy cosmetics
That's what I'm saying. Look if you take this room into consideration
If you look around the room what sticks out most do you if you ignore what they've actually outlined
It's like oh the pay the pay stuff is the most highlighted and it's like so well then what's this?
I don't even know what this is to be honest. I'll figure out later do but you know
You can make custom lobbies and overwatch so both any man friends
Fun fact they added that to the game years after release. Okay. Maybe it's not as bad as I once thought
Oh
Thank you origin for the tip and quest as well
I
Would like to remind you guys you can't say things for free and
Okay
Yeah, you heard me
Right, we only have like four missions to go and we're done though ready
I'm gonna be extra cocky this game because I know we're on the easy
And there's gonna be health everywhere I get to be a healer
Shark fish games can sometimes be greedy dark titan example for the PC players. That's all the gammy wait. What does that say?
Us an elm heart, okay
Really broly legend a really
Really
Reminder that super chats are free for now
No, what that that's not free if you charge yourself
You know, I'm starting to think you guys are in a fin dome
Cuz it's something going on here something's no cotton. I
Hear the enemies, but I don't see the enemies
A
Wide ber a wide ber under the development team. I really like the way they speak in this game
You just realized hypno fendom the worst combo
What combo is worse?
Hypno
Specification or
Mobile that isn't even a message
Now I don't mind
Specification, I don't mind it
But some of the stuff I've seen on it is so fucking predatory
And it's like fucking with people I
I
Like that the enemies that are highlighted that they're actually sorry, I just tried to beat them up with a potion
Both are equal
I don't mind it like I would give it a fucking shot
I don't mind it and but this stuff that I consumed like I consumed a lot of hypno content at one point
to see what other people were making and what I would enjoy making my version of or my
thing of
Oh my god
So much is like fucking with the mind of the person. I'm like
So when I say I like to mind break you
What I mean when I say that is I think
Personally it would be H word if you were like if you tried to fire work to someone else
But it wasn't as satisfying because it wasn't me now obviously that's gonna wear off
That's not like a permanent actual mind break thing, you know
But some of the stuff I consumed I was like, oh my god, you need to be locked up like what the fuck some of the stuff was like
Fucking with like gender identification and I'm like no
It's just me for some of it. Oh, there's a ladder
When I see like
No, there's definitely cute
But the language it obviously used in the majority of it is like pretty like oh my
Yeah, no, that's what it is. It's literally verbal abuse layer. Just like some sort of like audio that you want to
And it's like and like a lot of it is like
You can ping stuff with tango
Help
Helping
Hypno's the best when you're like the person doing it like
I don't like any of it. Oh, you don't like hip-no-all or did I misunderstand?
Are you just mean that kind of that cat grave?
Where am I going? Sorry, I'm a bit confuzzled
I don't
You don't like have no oh no
Do you find like the the ASMR stream that I did hip-no like cringy or is it just kind of like soothing cuz I'm like being chillin
Consumable some debris. I don't like hip-no-self in general, but I I mean, it's all right
I've messed up I shouldn't have come here
I
Famine
You're going to the Michael that's still counts as one
Ha ha get it. It's the Lord of the Rings reference cuz cuz I like Lord of the Rings and stuff. Yeah
What's going on
I
Do love the hacking and slashing it's very satisfying. I wonder how much the time the dev team had to put into like
We put this like the core mechanic. It's like we have to be able to
Where the heck did he go? It's like we have to make it satisfying and warden for players to hack and slash
We
Spent eight months on perfecting the head being cut off by the weapon because there's more than one weapon. I
Don't know where that majors
I'll try and get these guys
Okay, I'm getting these guys as they come in or not
Refleens get doing a do my job
Bomber someone's dropped the bomb
And I was in the toilet
Okay, I'm pushing them off of us because there's too many I
Will use block I would remember to use block sometimes
Out out out my organs, please I need those I actually need those I know it's hard to believe but I need those organs
Ah
Yeah, I think maybe I'll force
Maybe try overwatching a membership stream
And then you guys can't believe me for just plain really basic cuz I'm not like play
Now that Juno's out
I
Trust me darling. Oh, are you posing on us? Wait, how did I join you in that pose?
Wait wrong one. No wrong one. Hold on. Don't look. This is embarrassing sit on a chair. There we go
You didn't see that
Mommy and reason for hanging out. Can you do it, too?
It's someone coughing
I this body's still alive. No, they can't be there dead
Look guys pose and we're just done. Maybe I've called us glick it
Maybe we should I just call us the posers because we're just so we're literally soccer team
There's a grim rebar there. I don't know if we should get it. Can we grab it?
I don't know. It's too much. It's too much distance being made
Oh
Stop it. I was aiming for the bad guys
Well, they're all bad guys. Right. Are they going back for the book? I don't know what they're doing
I don't know where the book is. I'm just following you
Look at them dodging skills. I'm so good
Gremors are the ones that eat up your HP. We are on easier mode. Do I state that?
Because I'm so MLG and I'm so used to veteran difficulty that will be okay
Oh
I'm staring straight at the post. Okay, we did it. Do you know isn't it? Wait, she's not even out yet
I've been lying to I thought she was out because they came out with a trailer over something
There was a time that I knew every book location. Definitely don't remember most of them anymore
You little vermin tide in brackets affectionately. Okay. I'm ready
We made it we're in the cellar. This is actually Mercy's dungeon
I
I'm swinging
No, they revealed her and did a spotlight. They do that about a month before. Oh, well, I'm in no rush to play
I won't force you to download it just yet. Sorry
I
Was gonna say these wine barrels are humongous. They're fermenting some crazy
They've still got the wax on they're like massive baby bells, I don't know if you have baby bell. Oh, no, I think you do
Baby bells are like a wee ball. Well, we wheel of cheese like a really tiny wheel of cheese
And they have a red wax on them and you peel them off and it's quite satisfying to peel off to be honest
Okay, I made it out. I'm swinging. I'm swinging
Okay, I will use the block button when I need to but I think I'm swinging so successfully against these enemies
I don't need to block them
Maybe in a harder difficulty
Okay, are we okay Danny to do something?
Yeah, they're real two weeks more until general drops juice
I know they have to like hype up a character to get people like come back to play in it, but
It just feels so rubbish now
Why are you go okay? I'm getting nervous when you trying to explode next to me. Oh
No way I accidentally send that
I'm swinging
How do you just swap between them so quickly I
Feel like it takes me so long to swap to you something
Okay, let's get just like me for real for real
Baby bells and dearie Lee
Oh, I didn't mean to do that. Sorry, I think I ruined that
There's another barrel here, okay, I
Love that gun so much
Dark dark tape. Oh, no
I
Got killed in his own home
Hear that rat. Oh, there's tons of heels up here. I
Could hear
Hold on hydration check. I'm drink that cola. Come on caffeine
I
Might get a nap I think well do is on that way up to stream and then I wake up and
We can have a lovely day together and then we can search for the black powder
That's a lot of enemies, but they are getting slain slain your enemies
I
Die will you
Take this and this
Okay, maybe I should start paying attention to the floor a wee bit more
Oh
Then enemies up here they're hating in the garden
They're just lurking in the shot. What are you doing like treatment?
They just that was the the vermin tight empire. What do you do?
I just hear gravel and everywhere it makes me so nervous
Oh my god, that's brutal the guy on the door
They do not hold back in this game
I
I can't okay. I'm pushing it along very slowly. I'm coming
Being
Nap after she I wake and polish my bean
That's such a good mole
That's such a good mole. Is that fire spill her ultimate?
I'm pushing the car. I'm pushing the car pushy pushy car
Are we
Oh my god, I love how much range the weapons have in this game like I feel sorry. I missed that but I knew what to do
Like it feels so satisfying like actually being able to reach the enemy
It doesn't feel like I'm having to do anything
Will you ever play scp secret lab? Is it multiplayer?
I know about scp a little bit what I need to do sorry. I've got an edge
You need to fill it. Okay, let's go get the bits and bobs
Uh
I can't even reach on
To complete that game motherfucker. Oh shit and to pop that
Kills them instantly has a drink to celebrate
I'm just getting absolutely scheming this game right pick up a barrel down there somewhere. Okay, I assume it's this way
Uh, that's just a heal
Uh, it's up to get down. I know that sounds silly, but sometimes games do that on purpose
Where they're like, oh, do you want to go up? You have to go down
Okay, it's not in here. That's embarrassing. Maybe it is
Back below just protect your mage. They know what they're doing
Who can pick up a bomb?
Okay, okay, I followed me. I'm sorry. I'm sorry the perry flint's waiting on me
Okay, now we
As if you survived the I refuse. How are they survived?
Okay
Defend the basement
I'm a big strong slammin
Oh, I need a scottish. I'm not strong anymore. Please don't leave me. I'm gay
It's a lot of cheese
It's 24 players to an scp map
Oh, we might have to give that a shot if it comes if it comes on kind of game
It's 64 players it's free and it's communications on okay
It's a high risk high reward stream
Push in a light push, okay
Owie
No, you're not allowed to do that. I was about to push the car and you ruined it
Uh, yeah, I need a little bit of protection on the cart, please. I'm pushing. I'm pushing
Wow
I
So I want to do to the high table
Oh, I don't have my ultimate so I can't push them off of us
No
I'll revive you get up reefing you can do it. I believe in you
Don't give in. All right, we can't go that way, but this has been open
It has cons with proximity. Oh, that's funny though
I like games that have proximity chat because like if someone screams all you hear is like
Like in the distance type thing
Now that
She's delivered. I brought the boots
Something's killing me. What's oh my gosh, I can't reach you replaying
Oh
No, oh no
Got it
Stop right, I think we're getting stuck here. There's a heal here for anyone who needs the major heal
No
He's like killing me. Okay, we're just getting him up. Okay. There we go gang violence
And it's trying to do like the whole like oh, I can go to the left a little to the right, but I wasn't working
Because I was panicking and I forgot how to do it in the moment
But we did it
Are we letting repeats join now? I think so if no one claims that they've not like had a chance to play
Then yeah
Oh, well, I tried
Hey, but if you haven't played you're allowed to claim that you've not played it's fine
I don't mind at all, but we did let repeats in this round just because
I think I have I've either out
Uh, I'll walk in the reeflings because they are getting a bit tired, especially for time zones stuff
and
Oh, he's like literally a loot goblin
An incinerate bomb. I don't even know there was different kinds
They're all bombs to me
Oh, are we done it says escape. Oh my god. We're actually so good at this game
Uh, escape through the wall
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, skip through the wall
We did it
I'm just installing it now corner jump is to get the last bit
You power and doors can't grab it. Oh, I'm asked to go back
I mean we're this far now. It's not big deal if you don't get it
Spamming dodge isn't good though because it won't work. Oh, they all got it
Not the beard
Victoria's empire and flame
good
Oh, wait, no
The empire's us. We won the empire to succeed
I'm almost level 15 and then I get another skill point
I'm level 15. I get another skill point. Oh
Oh
I received a chest for my accolades because I'm just so
Hi, sorry. I hope you're having a good time. I had worked today's on the neighborhood
Oh, please don't worry. I always do more stream sniping pain
I have been putting the stream sniping stuff on the weekends, but I don't know some people work weekends
So maybe that's not the smartest idea
I'm going to try some stream sniping stuff
uh
Maybe for members as I said, maybe when overwatch update comes in regional
Should be able to change my subclass
Make me
I got accolades get the heck out of the way. You're ruining the picture
No, get the heck out of the way there
Accolades
Ah
Why did I keep frog? Oh, it's my fringe. I was like, why does it keep saying my other eyes and bling? It's my fringe
I must be emo
Okay, next friend
Hitchhots
I don't know. I can't remember how big I was that uh like this big. Yeah
Return to the keep soon TM
Um
More melee kills more head clicking most revised. I'm just so good
And most damage taken. Oh wait. No, actually, I wasn't the most damage taken surprisingly considering all things
239 melee kills
Anyone can join now or new people, uh, is there any new people? I think I've got one new friend of course
I don't know if you have the green yet
I'm not opening up my chest, but thank you for playing and we'll see if there's anyone new you
If you're on my friend's list you can literally just button when someone
Soldiers coach she gone. Oh, yeah
That's right. Give me more of that coach gun business. I'm all about it
A maincraft server would be fun
I thought about a member's maincraft server, but I don't know if that's weird
I don't know if that's weird behavior or if it should be a like
Because obviously you didn't want greeks and going on
Uh, right inventory great Sarge
I've got something better now
Oh
Alec fresh off the boat rapid fire piercing full middle alchemist full minute
Power versus gavin up power versus monsters up. I'm not and then my trinkets the same
Yeah
Wow, I love it
Back to a row server would be nice paywalls and okay to
That's common. I've seen a few people do members. I just need over a minute to finish installing
Sort as on game me
cost a bit of mid and ball back in the day
It's on the ground. Fine boys. I'm kneeling
Hey, so why did you stop now couldn't face it off to the
No, that's a big
Now I reckon some enterprise in sort cut the cables on the lift
From the foush leg
Gone in a flash and me asked some very pointed questions
Okay, let me write down
There is game chat. Yeah, I can talk to them like this
And there's invoice game chat as well as like they can hear me through stream if they want to listen to at the same time
I don't know if it's disorientating watching stream at the same time and playing in game at the same time
It's like
It's only because of the the background game noise
Oh my god, Deutschland
I'm just i think he's the german
I don't I don't know if he's german or not. Oh, his name is literally badder. Oh for fuck's sake. Of course. He's german
Dommas, okay
Oh, no, no, I'm not
No, no, I'm not
What the pt on the on the next means another country
What country is pt?
There's a place in america called portland is in there
Oh, yeah, I don't know any portuguese
I don't know any spanish. I don't know any of it
Mail and stream shopping
Uh, is anyone all right. I'm good whenever right lucky mo hasn't had a chance
Omni am I going crazy her view had a chance
I
Omni you were part of the bone zone
And recon crusader. Did you have a chance?
You were just her
Omni darlin. I'm so sorry. Can I ask you to leave because you were oh for fuck. He's already gone. He didn't give two shit
Okay
Right lucky has a claim
Where's lucky are you even in game? Oh there you are
I'm ready
Okay, and then recon you're fine
Wait, yeah, wait. No, wait. I fucked that up
I should have been re recon that went out and omni you stayed
I'm so sorry. I'm too small brain to understand. I should have been omni that stayed omni apologies. I'm a brainlet
I'm sorry
Apologize I did that wrong
And I am dumb. Please forgive me
I'm just happy to be here
Right, this is obviously
I can leave and come back if you want
I don't know it's omni. Do you want in it's technically it should be omni first if you mind. I don't know if you mind though
Shawnee ironed her brain out for sure
Oh and listen. Oh, well, then you're both getting kicked out if that's a new leaflin that hasn't had a chance to play yet
We're happy you're here. Yeah
That's all good
You're like that fucking bitch
Yeah, I fucking care
Go down. Let me play with her
Wait, who is that new friend request you need to Lee clean you can't just sales add
You're only online
Outlasted all these
I already got a chance to be fair
Okay, I think any repeats may be out of those what they're wanting them because those are new
You're adding me, but you're not on the game. You're trolling me. I'm being trolled by my recoil
What is making that all of you
You know one moment they were there the next oh look at me you have scars
Lanny boy you played you know you saw span
After leave good day. Good night. Bye reflin. Thank you for hanging
I just wanted to be friends with strong. Wait, you don't even have the game. Are you trolling me?
Oh, wait, we're going to try and get lucky and that lucky
Yeah
Yeah, I'm getting trolled. I'm like, oh, there's a new person that was to come in and play
I'm getting trolled right
Lenny boy. Wait, hold on. I'll say it in game. Lenny boy and
A recon crusader. Can you leave because I think there's two reflins that haven't had a chance to play yet try to come in if that's okay
Please
Please I'm on my knees
Sorry, okay, I'll take that as a yes
Okay, wait, let me let me take out these names
Oh, I know lucky you're supposed to be in this lobby
I swear to god you're in my game right who hasn't played
I'm so scared of search takes a lifetime
Okay, lucky made it in and salty lemon that was there we go
This is a full batch of non-repeat and then lucky more
What do we call this?
Dad
Dad lemon dad's lucky lemon gang fuck it
Dad's lucky lemon
This is the name of the team. I'm sorry. Dad's lucky citrus. How about that citrus?
What a fucking name. I'm not named. I can't be named anymore. This is getting terrible. Oh my god. Check this
You know people charge for that. Oh
Damn
She really said you get a preview and nothing more you get a preview and nothing more
Gone
And what makes me people happy not at the feet you got paywall. We literally got the teas and we got promised the future content
Where did you go?
No, wait, are you still online?
Sentimental garden lemon
You got bad connection you actually offline are you pulling me?
Lemon
Did you're fucking PC and you could sell it to the stratosphere? I couldn't handle it. I got too scared to connect to me
It's really nice of you to make sure we can get a fair chance to say yeah
I don't want anyone feeling like that except kind of fuck
And try and make it as fair as possible plus we're getting very close to the end of the campaign
So the next uh if we finish the campaign
um
The only other thing we can really do is try
Literally one two three. We've got three more to go
um
Go go we can play veteran go
Go
Go I I don't want to play veteran, but I guess we can play veteran
Sure, have you done the jump puzzle in the castle? No, we got this we got this
You could replay on cataclysm
That's what I was going to do. I was going to replay the missions on a harder level and then anyone can jump in
It's hard
So am I right now
You can do it
Okay, here me and the boys me and the boy. I want a glowing sword. Why do you get a glowing sword?
No, I don't
No, I'm going to go inside
Right world forest locate the
Gull
site
rough
The name of some of these places is like I good luck being able to say it
Why can't it not just be like I go to Costa Rica?
Like that's easy to say
I
Wonder if I should give the major try or the bone arrow lady
We've got scaly boys on our team
Just call it the gluck got you know what that actually crossed my mind and I went to myself
No, that's too much brain rot and didn't say it out loud
I held myself back from saying it and then you're telling me that you come up with it anyway
Or as bad as each other
Was me that way in in there
A bonkin goes just because you haven't paid two thousand us dollars to obtain the sword in game
Stop is that the actual reward?
I
Chat reflects the streamer exactly
You're absolutely done though
Right, I must remember we're not playing on easy mode. I'm not playing on easy mode
I'm not
Wait, could I not
Level up a perk point and then I forgot to do it. I have a terrible feeling I forgot to level up a perk point
Um
Oh my gosh, this doesn't sweep the way the other weaponry does
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying
Ever
Why so many coming from behind
Literally
I don't even have a heal for you
Fetch me their soul
By your sale
It's like a push forward type thing for the heavy attack on this weapon
Yeah, wait
Did you know that a passive insult in oh, I might wait you where's the witch? I need to give this to the witch
I need to give this to the witch
Because the witch it doesn't feel good. I will give it to the witch now. It's the witches and she can heal
And it goes
Well, guess cleave is limited on halberd
They heard about your
Cod zombie rare. Oh
We can play cod in all of that
Oh, wait. No, I think there's ip issues if you play cod on pc
I need think there's some games where it's like it's too dangerous because the ip reveal or whatever
and
I think call of duty was on the list for like one of the games you absolutely do not do because it's like a big major mistake
Oh my god, I need to start using block please
Fuck sake I've got a bomba
I'm getting scared
I'm getting the gatlin out
I'm getting the gatslin out. Sorry brain. Oh, shit. Absolutely brain rot
Bomba I'm throwing a bomb. I'm throwing a bomb. Goodbye. Not my problem. Not my problem. Oh
Maybe a little bit my problem. I don't even know how I'm alive
Oh, I'm falling down. I think I've activated the next freaking attack. I'm so sorry if I have
I think it's like location base
Oh, no, starting will find our ip's and visitor how
Common
You all know what these gaven are in real life. What do you mean?
I'm gonna sneeze
No, I'm not maybe I'm I might it's coming and it's going
It's shy
Oh
Florida people hi on craig we got what?
I thought you were gonna be like oh the development team like made the noises of them
Through this like unique animal type thing. I didn't expect that. I'm gonna be honest. I didn't expect those lower notes
But there you go
What I remember there was like that bath bath
Bon salt sniffing
Media that came out about
everything
Which was rather interesting that people were sniffing back on
I don't know the bath salt
I don't know what were to go what we did we come from I'm so turned off and so turned around I'm not turned off
Well, I'm not turned on either in the middle of the game. You know what I mean, you know what I mean, okay?
I can't I can't see him fucking pulverize and rats
We're beating
I messed up with him so badly
I messed up so so badly
Turned off
Stop it. You're turning me on
Of course, we know what you mean
Okay, I might deal with these one
No strongy you can't just keep swinging at the enemies without aiming
Okay, what happens if I did though?
I'm gonna take this one because I suck but everything can take
I need to put it on I need to put on the mage right. I'm gonna heal up the mage when I catch up
So do you do you cleave on halberd by doing a little one into block
I need to heal the witch
I did it. I am a healer
I am not allowed to reward myself
30 seconds of vibration. I don't know if you guys have ever seen that stuff. Maybe I'm gonna
Tee hee about a lair dude. It's the funniest thing ever. It's like
When you when you heal
you're allowed to
Like put it on or something or I it's just bizarre. It's the most bizarre thing. You should
Oh
I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. Everything's fine
I'm on my own
But I'm gonna be okay
Okay, I'm fine. I'm safe safe and real and true
Are you running it with old reasons yet? They're still new. This is a new
Law, I don't know if anyone's wanting to claim
They're new after this one
We did have one last run but then we got a few I don't know if people are downloading the game or not
Bonk
Wow, okay, there is a heal
Fetch me there though
You know about lingering hitboxes. Yeah. Yeah, of course I do
What the fuck is he on about
Is that a little thingy? Oh, I can't reach him. He stole her thingy my bobbers
I don't know. It feels like competitive gaming and aren't something to be mixed feels like it's less
I feel like I would get and I'm not being funny if we did a blue stream like that
I feel like I would get so fucking competitive that I wouldn't even like I wouldn't even be able to enjoy
the activity, you know
Because I'm just too competitive. I'm like, no, I want to win and then when I start seeing defeat on my screen
I'll be rage. I'll be like reeflands. Why are you why are you letting me lose? Like what the fuck is going on?
Why are you not bringing me the best? I need 10 out of 10 gameplay. What's going on here?
I don't know how I knew he was there about
I'd like to see you try and get an Isaac clear without
I'll need to test if I'm comfortable enough to sit for a long time like that
So I know for a fact
Um
That the clam can't handle something like that
There is a possibility
Of the
But it would be
I don't know if there's a way to set it up that it can be done for free
Like I don't know
I
Fetch me their ink honestly me and apology. Fetch me their ink
Lumber foot lumber foot. Oh, yes, because the runes are the lumber foot since Scotland
Sorry, I'm being a little heater. I like her character. It's cute and all but it's just every time without fail
Oh my god, is that a Scottish person in a video game? Let's make them
I hope no Dutch people are watching. Don't read the screen goddamn
Oh
Arise me hearty
Pitch me there
Needs a mod where college or a dog
Whoa, what's the little inklings are coming at me? Well, why would we have any reason to dodge?
I see she's still going. Yeah, I'm playing with my replay
I'm enjoying this game. This is a good stream snipe game. It's very different as well
Bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk
I think is it's like a brainless game where it can just keep tapping and whacking. I'm like, yeah, I like this
Yeah, I like this game
Find the entrance to the excavation site. I guess it's not that
Ray feeling do you need assistance?
Do you need an evac site? No, we're good. Come on this way
If you want to do it for free you could post the controlling a variant link and then post new link
Oh
Wait, so I can give like a minute
Oh, don't we go I guess
Oh, no, I forgot the drinking potion. Oh dry. Okay. It's fine. It's fine. It's not a big deal. I haven't I have a med kit
I have a med kit. It's fine
I wasn't paying attention
That's force not healing
I got ammo at least
I don't know if I come across another healing thing I might just pop this med kit on me
And then
Infections cleanse
Are they set?
I didn't even know the monsters could get sick in this game, but
Oh
They're they're gunking on me
Not the good kind the icky kitty. Ow ow it burns
Get me out of here. It's burning me
Okay, I think I'm gonna heal
It's sick
Okay, there we go
Whoo, you stop that
Ow it's not happening
Uh, I'm gonna just let them do it. They seem to know what they're doing. I'm gonna just swing on the rats. I'll let them do this
Or
Explode the pimples
It's a bubble here. Okay, make it
Mummy to become a vermin tide beat of it. Oh, I could not make content out of this
Are you joking?
Hey guys joining Coles here with another
Uh vermin tide playthrough. Today, we're gonna be playing easy mode solo. Oh super scary playing solo vermin tide
That's right. I'm not getting the help of the replaying. Oh
Oh, I'm such a brave girl like what how would I make content out of that?
Oh, here's where to find the totems by the way
Like I can only pick up one at a time
It's not gonna I can't make good vermin tide easy solo. You're crazy literally what content can I make from this?
I start rambling about the lore of like the actual
What's he got you shatey's
The bravest girl in all the land you played this without reeflings you're crazy truly it's impossible
Okay, I need to remember to put that talent point on
I should sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm I'm getting tunnel visions by myself
Honestly, I definitely want to try out that witch character. She seems to be like scary dude
I can't remember if she can't be used like if you use her too long you start taking damage yourself
Or maybe like when she's fire only
My memory is big
Escape to the surface. We're escaping. We're escaping, but will we turn? Okay
The whole place is coming down
I
Don't see the grass see the gas wrap
Secret tunnel secret tunnel to escape to the surface secret secret secret tunnel
Oh
My god, I'm getting scared the screen is rumbling is this pain?
I'm getting nervous. We actually when we go
Rattling where I just see regular one
Stand up shape up or shut up
Oh
I love the Gatlin so much
I love it. I need more Gatlin and Molly
We did it another one. We're actually gonna finish the campaign
Easy
Good job
We're gonna finish the freaking campaign because we're so mlg pro festering grounds act three more like
Uh
More like done. Thank you. I'll be here all day. Thank you
I'm starting to lose the ability to talk and to
Vocabulary my words
But that's not gonna stop me inking ground act me
More like the pestering ground
Do you prefer a Gatlin over a leaflin?
I mean after the videos that I saw today. I feel like
With the strength if you will of how fast one can shoot one leafling can shoot in theory is the same
If not more dangerous than the Gatlin
The only thing is you're one pumping done. I think
so
Uh
I don't know if I was like to celebrate that but I technically have five special kill. No
Lemon
You asshole, how could you do this to me? Why would you get five special kills?
Lemon, how could you do this to me?
I
Tied I technically have a revive so I'll take that
Snape a rifle leafling honestly real I'm sure
Okay, is there any leafling that leaves claim to the I've not played with you yet
suspicious
Russian name. Okay. I'm okay
Uh
We did it. We did it
Snackery. Great. Is anyone slamming claim laying laying claim that does not play with me
What
Is no one claiming that they have
I
Is random Russian name
I'll leave if needed
No one else is online that hasn't played
On the friends list random. What the fuck? Sorry. I'm just judging all your games right now. Guilty gear strive
Titanfall 2
Red M forbidden dead rp 3.1 out now. What are you? Are you advertising?
What are you playing right random Russian name? Are you even online?
No, there's no privy ether online, so I don't know how you set that friend quick gg to the team
Titanfall 2 booth
I mean
Okay, if no one is claiming in chat and repeat that they're new then
I have to do a repeat run
Don't judge a fellow for playing Titanfall 2 that game slot is good. Oh, is it on sale? Okay. Well, uh, we'll probably end up playing
Uh, I already put the Titanfall 2 campaign down again. I want to play again
Okay, I don't think there's anything in particular I'm gonna get this
Somehow asked in one four four can't join
Oh, do you want in?
right the triple
who's
right whoever was the
The latest player is between Cali Hydro Recon
Uh
Would it be
Cali it would actually be you
Question mark it is Cali. You're the most recent player that's played with me
Does that make sense?
Uh, if I could be really rude Cali Nancy to leave and then uh, ruski priviet you can come in
I don't see you and my friends
I already left before you said anything. Oh, thank you for understanding
Zion have you playing
So I'm having a look at the how many teams I've had one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
I've had twelve teams so far
Zarian you've not played
No, you haven't
Should we would have to use our star for multiplayer in Titanfall? Oh, I don't know
I haven't yet. No, I didn't think you had right so Cali you came out
Zarian you came in
Oh, thank you imperial monarch for the gifted membership. I appreciate it congrats to who caught up with your face
um
How many refunds can carry mommy through legit? We're gonna find out so we're gonna finish
By starting you next round
I am okay
You can join
Who you you can join
You need to snipe in through the lobby. So what we'll do we'll finish the campaign and then
we'll muck about um
And see if we can do a hard mode, but don't pick up any tones or I'm gonna cry no more tone picking up
Okay, uh, there's no way I even have a clue what your name says it could be much the most
Unsupported, I'm just gonna put russian
Russian refling
So the team is hydro russian
And together we make
What do we make
Uh
We make
love
A team love. Sorry. It's such a shit name. I can't think of anything off the top of my head
Okay, I was like the mission and we will go in because we
Bruh, we're literally about to finish
Party doesn't meet requirements. Oh, oh
Oh, no. Oh such a shame that the party can't did you buy the game? Did you buy the game?
Just a stream snake. Why are you level one? Be honest? You're making me nervous
I get nervous when you guys buy games just to play with me for the first time in case it's a disappointment
Oh, I didn't do a skill point
I'll keep for you
You've had mobile level one don't buy games just to play with me
It makes me worried that you're not gonna enjoy the game
I would buy any game for you. Oh, yeah. How about you buy this?
On the house
They might be playing on a new character if they have to swap off their main, yeah
Okay, we're playing easy mode here's the plenty so i'm gonna be extra cocky and never use block at all
Even though I hardly use block at all
Buy that how much it's free
On the house
Love is free
Okay
Swinging my thingy my barber. I'll take your whole stock. Oh
Then maybe I should make a cute little video game about low
And that'll be the currency and then they'll be like how much is the love and then by the end of the game
You realize that it's not about
Uh
Oh my god. Oh, I can make an any cap. Oh my god. I can make any game. I want
Well, I will make it. I'll hire a dev team
I'll hire a dev team deal
Deal. Oh, yeah
Thank you
Really legend and don't oh me
I'll take 14 don't worry. I've had this game for years. Just haven't played it in a bit. That's why I
I explore too much about him
How much magic my stuff is
God I love the guns. They're so effective in this game. Sorry. I'm getting distracted. I don't think I'm supposed to be here
Are you squiddin me right now?
Tbh I already had vermin tied to but hadn't played it yet
Thanks for the excuse to play warhammer fantasy game instead of dark time long
Did I bring him back over to the more fantasy side of it instead of the the guns and
futuristic
It never occurred to me that it was called warhammer 40 because k because it was 40 the year 40,000 like
I'm a dumb dumb. It didn't occur to me
Thank oh my god, no, I forgot how to stay there
Leave me alone, please social distancing, please
Oh my god, are you okay?
You can absolutely wall it but I'm getting walled too actually speaking about taking a ball looking on a wall of it
Um
Darkened reaper surely that's how I see it kopium. I think that's it. Yes. It's actually a different universe. Ah, okay
This music is going 10. I don't even know instrument that is so I don't like it
Deal I have heels for anyone that's
Oh
I'm placing in Dyson
It's a stress instrument. I just please stress honestly
It's the same one for the tamed missions in assassin's street brotherhood whenever there's a tamed mission. It always goes
Rip and tear for me
Hydration check
I have a little
Oh, no, we've gone for toms. I know we're on easy mode, but
I love this. I wish I could use this gun all the time. It wasn't like, uh a wee bit of ammo
Oh
Maybe jangle in middle. It's giving her so cute with her christening arm
I'm with clan
Skyrim
skirt ryer
Death to the man man thing. Wait, you're on the enemy team. Why would you be on the enemy team?
Why would you be on the enemy team?
It's starting to give me how many rats you've killed. I think you will enjoy engineer. Get the real gatlin done
And
The dwarf mining game
Deep world galactic
I used to play tourbjorn in overwatch
Tourbjorn ready to twerk
I can ditch the grim
No in this the gun. Oh when he jerked his pincers
Trust me. I'm an engineer. What's the heck just happened here? Trust me. I'm an engineer
Well, if they're not drinking it, I'll drink bottoms up
Stony's gonna be so confused with the warhammer 40k faction
Oh, no, I can hear the grabby one. Hold on
I
Tooted
Maybe so quiet that it wouldn't even been picked up in
In deep rock. It's the soldier that has a gatlin. Yeah
Yeah, I gotta play that game
I'm you know, she's not oh, you don't have to tell me twice. I don't know how to highlight that stuff you guys
I don't know
Hey, no, you're a rock star. Get your game on. Let's go
Why we're at straight swamp
Oh, I just realized I'm doing an ASMR stream tomorrow with I can like my webcam
Oh, I'm getting a wee bit burn. Wee bit chilly everyone back off at back off
That's why I use my ultimate when you all start getting a bit too close. Um, I
Will show my schedule right at the start of stream
But then I'll like take off the screen and you know show the juicy thighs because that's what people be here for
And I respect it and then I'll talk about it
Because I've got a membership stream where I'm writing scripts
I am praying I get enough sleep that I'm cool use of enough because um, you guys gave me a script idea
I wanted to do for this month
I can't remember what it was
But I really wanted to do it out. Thank you. Um
Oh, you gave me a plot I really wanted to do and I forgot
Oh
The doughnut stacking one no, that's a youtube one
That one is more that one can't really be written into a script like it has to be done in the moment
Because if if I read it from a script
Like
Haven't you noted like eight of them down? I didn't note the last one down that I wanted to do
I decided the park bench is out of my
Abilities right now to do it justice, but there is a plot you guys gave me that I really like and of course I've forgotten it
Pretty sure it's the kissing one
Hold on a minute my brain my the electricity of my brain is starting to
move a little bit between
brain cells and wrinkles
I think
It was a kissing one
And I tie you down
And make you
Oh, I dry. Yes, I dry
You
I dry bump you and keep kissing you until you
Do your thing
Yeah
Because I've not been doing any kissing because I'm really bad at writing it
So I wanted to do a whole dedicated script to it because I thought that would be very sweet
Oh
Sorry, I oh sorry. I thought I just let that keg on fire, but it's your hair. I literally
Thought I let your fire in here there
Okay, uh, that's what we I hope to write about tomorrow if I'm not too tired. I just need to sleep
Like as I said after the stream I'm gonna sleep and then I'm gonna wake up
And do something and push something
And then put the shorts on the girls channels
And then order some emotes
What
That was a good game
Stop it
There's med kits here, which makes me think that is the boss fight
Have a great rest of the stream. I'll check out the what after sleep well rest well
or
Deal with adult responsibilities. Well, thank you for hanging again. Anyone that needs to rest, please don't worry
Um, you're not gonna miss out on much. This is the second last mission
And then we do the last mission
and then
Uh, we're gonna
That's it
Like we're gonna muck about and see if we can maybe do one of the levels higher than they are in difficulty
Or maybe we'll try like insane difficulty. I don't think it's possible
If you're on easy says what we're making it. Oh, maybe I should heal
Getting tired darling
Okay, I'll pop this
That's so blinding you didn't have to do that. No, no really don't blame me again
Um
Let me use the grind for higher level power. I am so she can even do legendary. Oh, I forgot about that
draft
I think I could go to the next level whatever comes next. I'm sure I've probably got enough right copium
I
Actually quite, uh, I admire that leveling up system where you can't just do hard right away because you need to
um
I believe yeah, baby
Um, I like that kind of thing where you have to work your way up before you even get the rewards for doing the hard stuff
and
It's rather satisfying
As champion 200 or 300
and
You'd know better than me unfortunately
Oh, we're going to do a defy. Are we ready reeflings?
I
They let us over cage just like the animals we are
That did nothing
Oh
Okay, that was rich
So does this not penetrate his armor it doesn't
Ow, stop it
I don't have a bomb
Stop why does he keep throwing us halfway across the map? That's so stinky
Stop it
I'm
Why are we supposed to do he keeps doing this away?
Oh, I hit him in the head okay his head took it
Over teabagging him, okay
Mummy see mummy do
Your gun has low penetration
What did you why am I getting gun shamed?
My gun has low penetration
Shocking
Okay, actually good night then. Okay. Good night. Thank you for playing and hanging
Rest well little reeflings that need to sleep. Okay. Good night
See you in your dreams
Because I'm going to be nothing too and I'm going to come haunt your dreams. I'm gonna high
My accent's back again right anyway, and now to teach you some real scots. So canny cannot
Denny do not well any will not
Your gun is good for bumping damage into unarmored targets only oh, we're done
Oh my god
Deep fried chaos warrior
We did it. We did it. We're on the last mission. We did it. We did it. We're on the last
Can I shoot out of the bowl?
Oh, I can't shoot
Oh, I've got an achievement complete act three
right glend rumble
The war camp gg
Okay
Last mission we're doing it now. Does anyone have claim to the throne?
That they've not played with me yet any claimers any pro claimers
I'm going to do a few more rounds
Anyway, I'm just mucking about
Shawnee and her dreams come here and let mummy hear for you
Come here and let mummy care for you
That's right
Claim your spot now or forever hold your peace amen. I got a strong hold but
Right
You know what this is starting to feel targeted now
This feels targeted. How not one accolade to my name
I
500 milk mummy's gun doesn't need it reefland's handle the penetration around here. Oh, oh that's smooth. I like that
I'd like to hop in for a higher difficulty. Yes, you can more than certainly try that
Yeah, you did good. Nobody died
Did somebody die?
I feel like I'm at a few. I cannot wait to watch the hobbit movie with you
Okay, right
Inventory talent points finally
Deal 40 more damage to staggered enemies each hit against the staggered adds to the count of stagger bonus
The first enemy hit always counts as staggered
Right
Increased total power level by seven. This is calculated before other buffs are applied
It's targeted I think
I don't know if there was like a
I'm like no, I don't okay. I have 217 hero power
and
Okay, I don't there's no new friend request
I don't think there's anyone in here. A lot of people didn't like hobbit bandrate it. No, I don't think there's any claimers. I think
Wait, hold on. Not yet. I just want to see highest obtainable
Okay, whatever
uh
Yes, anyone can come in almost come in
Because there's no claimers to the throne. Okay
It's that a deed deed of valor
God, that's what everyone used to call valor when it first came out. They were like saying it like that
Hello any increase
hydration food check uh eight earlier. Don't worry. I promise I've not been going
Six hours. We've been playing together for this fantastic
aim
I already got some warm tuna and you go to sleep. Good night. Good night. I look forward to seeing what you do after stream when I get up
You have some cruel waste records from a book this
or
we
came with a hug too
Uh, what do I click?
Challenges
Claim
I can get chess
Okay, that's fine
kill bod var and
Yeah, that was I ain't reading that. Good luck. Is that all my reward?
I am clean something I got more art from discovering art
So
You need to clean chair
Is that a real life thing you mean?
Okay, I will put on anything that says upgrades
Not that this
And then
And then sure
And then charm
Another one that levels me up. I'm at hero power two to eat. That's not bad
Oh, no, my gatlin isn't my gatlin. Sorry. Yatlin you're out. I want my gatlin back
Give me that one
Three and one member let's go
Wait it registered that it's been more than a month
I use green now
Mmm
Act two now hot tool
Uh, oh wait membership. I don't do things. Oh, you're all green
So, let me get this straight. You're not
For the last time green power, but you're not fleshed. Right. There's the gang gang gang gang
Okay, there's no one claiming this wrong. Help me gorex and I don't know any longer
Okay, we've got there
Wait, did you shorten your name so it comes on screen?
I think you did because now it fits on screen
Lanny boy and cali
I'm gonna call us the experience. Okay
Ta-da, experience team. No, I switched character
Okay, I've done that. I guess this is the last mission we did it
We will play the rest together
Thank god. Sorry. Thank god. Someone's on a low account. I don't want to play the hard one. Um, we will play
the three other chapters
Together at a later date. Um
Just I would like to get some variety on the stream side game
My shell is still the same. It's okay. It doesn't matter what color your shell is
As long as you let me rub it
I'm gonna cook dinner later strunnion. The what?
Why did you call my reeflings?
Uh
Any chance of dark tide? Actually, yes
Oh wait, did someone lag out? Oh someone lagged out. Hold on. Let me cancel someone lagged out
Head out cancel. I've tend to cancel. Right. Popo. I broke
a reefling DC
Surely he meant rappers and m&m
Surely
Just know he missed one later on crap
Probably because we like hip-hop around these parts. Why yes, of course
Sure sure
Not to be confused with thank you and mandarin which is sure sure
Sure sure. Oh my god all the poses you want to go to the tower what tower up here
Come here
Where
We're you're what do you mean come here you're up there
There's someone
I'm being trolled reefling you're trolling me. What am I doing here? I can't even get up jump up on the shelves
The one brick a shelf that is out. Are you trolling?
I'm being trolled
I'm being trolled you're trolling me, right?
This is a this is a prank
This is a prank
How right go and come down and show me what you did come down and show me what you did, right?
Oh for fuck's sake, right
Right. No, that's just cheesy doodling. I'm getting pushed by something the game just hates me
Okay, and now it does it
Right, and then how'd I get up here?
bro
What
Mysterious tunnel
You don't have to tell me twice
This there's a hidden tunnel
Castle up in here
I'm sorry
There's a hidden tunnel. You're there. What'd I come out?
Is this is this hidden lower
What am I supposed to do in here? It's a bed. Are we humping? Is that what we're doing? Are we all humping here?
Oh, is there something to do is it lower?
There's ink on the canvas
Is that is that why we're here? We're humping on the bed. Are we humping beyond it?
I don't know if we're humping or not. Is that why I'm here
I'm not gonna question that I'm just here for a good time at the end of the day
I don't I mean, I don't know why I'm here. I don't know why I've been brought here. I don't exactly brought against my will
I mean, it's a tower what you're supposed to rescue me from it
Nothing else. Oh, right. Okay. Okay. Sorry. I thought there was like some like something I have to touch or interact with
Just showing you there's a little little hidden thing. Okay
Okay, we're doing it
The we're doing the last mission the
Skitter gate. Okay. The time has come people the gate guards have been thinned
The raw blood forces lack leadership and dear old
Rat
Uh is some self congratulatory victory speech. This is our chance to destroy the gate
Now just let me finish before you start screaming bloody murder
You must go through the gate and travel to north sea
It's the only way so listen carefully if you don't do exactly as I say you won't be coming back
That's rather scary
Okay, let's go
The final mission is a big one
I think it was supposed to be fun
It's loners to be believed the skitter gates no longer guarded
It's
I'm not yawning because I'm bored. I'm yawning because I'm tired
There'll be no peace until we destroy the track
I was gonna try a harder difficulty like we just muck about for like maybe another half an hour or whatever
I don't know how long this mission I assume because it's the last one
I
Nothing over there. I thought that was the way that's not that he's not doing it. Just the fake way
This is the way
Okay, pull the lever refling
Correct lever
She's bored of it. No, stop it
What's that? Oh, it's a loot wrap
We're what stop it. You do nothing. Do we rather fix me?
I'm not bored. I'm falling young if I was bored
I'd
fucking walk
I'll stream for two minutes and be like
I do love that gun
My compliments to the chef that designed it truly a satisfying weapon get me on dark tide right now
I'll see what it's about as I said, I'll look up a video. Um
Is it this it's not the same gameplay in the future what guns is it?
I mean if it is sorry different universe, but we in a different timeline
I mean, I wouldn't hate it at all
I'll eat the blunt force attack is enough to just do them in
I
Don't know why I felt so sick at the start of stream, but I feel fine now that was really bizarre
I don't know why I felt so ill. I feel fine now
I'm just an I'm unhealthy being my hp bar is rather low in real life, which is strange because I've not
Really had to deal with it too much
I'm pinned. I'm pinned because of this freaking thing
Um
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. I got a bit panicky. I got a wee bit panicky, but it's okay. I dealt with it like a big girl
Oh, there's something going for me. What?
you
Maybe it was a rooflings withdrawal symptoms. We have too much of a pool on each other
I'd imagine that
We're needed to get used to that again after yesterday
Oh
Wow the game literally tells you not to heal small wins
Oh my god, do you guys want to do the honors or?
Oh
It's like a pool mechanic. Okay, I'll do the honors even though I didn't get us here
Okay, so they have access to electricity
This is rather uh
Rather intricate for the rats to come up with I have to admit
Go through the gate
Oh
Why does this seem like a terrible idea? Oh, by the way, go through the gate of the enemy
Drop it you hurt me
Mummy has the honor of filling the lever
Oh, is it magic?
That's getting really bright. So motherfucker am I in? Okay. Jeez. That was so bright
I
Couldn't even look at the damn screen there. I forget again and I'll go off. We're gamers. We're in dark rooms
Development teams, please understand who's playing your games. It's not people playing in broad sunlight. What the fuck?
Knock it off. Well, if I become president, that's the first thing I'm changing. I'm out
I'm banning freaking flash and
That's
I
Showing for president
Oh, I'm gonna go against the boss. That's right. Oh, I learned so much. I'm blocking and staggering
Make light mode illegal I'd vote for you for that. Yeah
I
And game dev teams hate her because she spoke the truth
Just because you don't want to admit it
Scaven lore wise are the most intelligent species in this universe that makes me insane machines that can rival magic
But they are back stabby so they always kind of cause their own downfall
For being silly billies basically
I think he's like stanley parable
I've never played it. I see vtuber's play it. So I don't I don't know if it's an access like an easy accessible game
You would love stanley parable
Oh
It's a single player store game it's accessible you walk around and it's just a cracking joke
Hi, today's my birthday
Where's your my little pony profile picture? What the heck?
Only one person's gonna get that straight for it's also so happy birthday by the way
Um
Stanley pario is very weird but funny especially if you go and blame very okay. Okay, right no more spot
Maybe we'll give that a check. I don't is it like I can finish it and wrap up and get all achievements
Or is it just kind of like one of those games like
Suica where you put it on for like a couple of hours to entertain yourself and
You can get into it as much as you desire or not
My little pony birthday boy
Come on. Good thing
It's a casual narrative game. So there's no real loose. Okay. Okay a game. I can't loosen is easily accessible
Oh my it's got me written all over it
You mean I don't have to try hard. I mean even I'm not sure I call this gameplay tryhard
Oh
That didn't work good
I know it's not penetrating but I can't help but want to scream free
I'm burning alive and becoming human jerky right now
I
Got the squadron they're carried out. I really want those purple weapons back. I'm not allowed thumbs
Okay, I yanked it because obviously it's very important for me to have ammo even though I'm not the gun specialist
I thought you meant easily accessible. It's like infinite engine. It's like no spoilers, you know
If you got all achievements, you have to change your PC's time setting. Oh, no. All right, okay
We're not going for full achievements, but I'll I'll muck about on it. Oh, I didn't realize I was one of the grabbers
I'm sorry. I got a jump here. Okay reach the southern gate. Okay
We are now in the tundra
Because look at how much ice is here
Not again, okay
Stop it. I'm mucking about
No, right. That's what you're getting altered right now. Everyone's getting a spank spank spank spank
If you're staggered you're getting spank
Twice as hard actually. I think I have like 60 spank on the stagger
There's just grips at enemies everywhere. They're just being shitting
You know what I'm glad they can enjoy the scenery
I'm gonna enjoy the scenery too. Mm beautiful. Not one plant in existence in the tundra
I'm sat there ever for a minute. Okay, you know what? I wish this was a game
It's just a uh slashy
It's not a shooter. Where the heck did my refunds go? Oh, there they go. Okay. Thank you for your uh escort
Yeah, you like that. You like it. You're my escort. Are you squidding me right now?
This game can be pretty tough. Some of these reflames are just very good at this game
I myself am just average
That's okay. You don't have to be mlg pro just to play it
Hey
Stash power. Thank you for the support
No, I'm having fun just looking about
Oh
Oh my gosh
Let's not fall off the map. No darlin
I was big big boom
I start I might start another one
Ah
Wrong don't do that again
Portion don't waste it
Don't waste the potion
No, you don't want to waste the potion. Are we about to do a battle dumb?
No, I like easier games though. I'd say I'm definitely average gamer too. I just like clean
Oh
Like if that feels that it's like the restocking on supermarket simulator
It's satisfying and I'm not going to argue against it. I'm
I
Although I have to admit this sword is so big that I sometimes think I've accidentally got a bro and arrow out like in skyrim
Sure, I'll pick up one of you. Oh, no, I didn't do that
I want that one. I'm just picking it up. I'll pick
We're at a blood camp
But are we going to survive is the question drum roll
Games are way more fun when you don't take them too few. Yeah, I've definitely been enjoying that
That's right. I did a 360 drink the ale pick up the
All right, where's the boss fight bring him on
Bring on the boat. Oh, no right in front of me though. Well, that was cheeky don't do that
Let's go
How did you spawn that freaking tree and honestly
I don't know what I'm supposed to whack at everything saying he's armored up the wazoo
That just keeps going for it. Or is there a weak spot I need to go for?
He's not got a head
He didn't have it
Yep, if you guys are happy, I'm happy. I don't understand what occurred in that fight
I think the best thing about this game is that every class is viable even at higher difficulty to get to a lot of different play styles
I just see
They yelled out for wasting supplies. I'm sorry. Oh, we know I need to take this one so I can heal the reasons because I can't heal them with a drop
All heavy attacks pierce armor. Okay. I'm blunt blunt blood bludgering him today
I don't ever use that word. So that was that that was hard on the tongue
What's whispering
Sassy bucka. Oh, I found the stairs
Let's go across
I'm going up the stairs. I'm exploring up the stairs
We're supposed to return to the gate now, but there's no aggro to it's just
Blood joining yeah
Like when it's a blunt attack
Like a hammer is considered blunt, right?
So
He is so weak to
shoot in attacks like that
Where we're going?
Don't this me
And is it through a game?
Enking him to death
I
Wonder if I had a if I was in a video game that would be my attack because I'm a cold fish
So obviously I can ink like that
Uh, I get and like if you upgraded my ink, I guess it would be like it takes over your mind and breaks you type thing
Oh
I get stronger and stronger until you like can't resist it every time you level it up
And then like at the point there's like no enemies that are mean to me because I'm so
I'm so
I'm so ink. Okay. That's my sentence. Thank you everyone. I'll wrap up the stream there. I'm so ink
I'm so ink
Baby, you stole my heart up. I'm so
We can go back to the gate
And
Aggressively inked on you
Why do that in game when you can do it and realize me first me first?
Okay, I line up one by one. You're all getting inked on
Oh, we beat it up. Oh, I like that. I want to beat up all of them
I
Actually like the lore that they can't like come to an agreement and they're so smart that they sabotage themselves
Over like silliness. I quite like that
That's good
I'm helping I'm helping
Uh, am I getting gas?
Whoa, what's going on?
Okay, everyone close your eyes
Uh, are they stuck?
I'm
I'm protected
I'm pretty abandoned them a lot of enemies spawn behind
I'm not gonna abandon the people the only reason I got this far into the game
Ready, let's go right close your eyes though because it's so blending to the same thing
I didn't even notice there was like
Wait, whoa, why did she sound so slow? Did the voiceline mess up?
I refuse to close my eyes
Oh, it's the rat from the star
Oh my god, they're a jewel. Oh, that's not good. How are you supposed to win? I look like uh, I um
Oh
Oh my gosh, that's like annihilation
Ow
I literally can't even get close to him to wall of him
Uh, oh, I'm getting pushed. I'm getting I'm
Oh
What's going on? I literally can't do anything. Okay, you're up
Uh, sorry, I suck right now. I'm like doing so bad. I don't really
Okay, okay, okay, it's fine. It's fine. Everything's fine. Go panic. Did we kill him? I'm just spanking him
I am kind of fuzzled. I think
Can I melee him? I can okay, so get rekt, bro
Uh, I don't even know if I can reach him in time
I'm impressed
What is going on
I'm trying. I don't know if he's even taken any damage
Ow
Okay, thank goodness I have heals, but I have a terrible feeling if we weren't playing on easy mode right now
I'd be a goner
Okay, I'm staying in this corner because he keeps teleporting to every other corner. I this is my corner. I'm gonna attack him when it shows up
He's literally going mental
Every corner but the one that I want to attack him in basically
You have to dodge while blocking
Everybody's staying one corner. I agree with that
Uh
Oh, and he spawns in my corner the moment I look away for five seconds
I see how it is. I see how it is. You wait for I'm one of you
Watch out
Yeah, higher difficulty a single poke from a random rat is like 50 HP. Bruh, I don't know why
I'm a bit nervous to play the harder modes after this
This is my corner you may not like it
I
Did it I did it I hit him
The back stabbing and legendary mode is here I'd imagine so literally like if you can't even see
Oh
Okay, I like how they're that's his finishing move
We did it
We destroyed one enemy
Okay, things are blowing up not to be dramatic, but let's get move on
Am I going the wrong way?
No, I'm not
Getting too bit too hard
I hit from the 7 of 40
I've no idea how the HP values work. I guess I'm like what 100 HP
I almost fell off the map there. He's feeling poor
A little to the right a little to the right. I like to move. I like to
Hey, okay
You
Okay, we can do it we can do it
Oh my god, we did it your character class is 125
I'm not winning on any other level
Or did I just miss it?
Oh, there's more oh, I just said escape, okay, uh the wayward stone would be nice
Uh, we're putting a lot of faith into this
That which was
Get me on that wayward stone
Oh my gosh. All right, hold on. Let me let me hit him. What pose?
I did it. I got an achievement
Yay, we finished it. We destroyed this getter gate
Oh my god, I get anything special for it. Come on. Give me something special. Did the main boss come on. Give it to me
You know, I deserve it. You know, I did it
Peasant box my spoils of war
You chest up
Ran Ranold's gift who's ran old
And why is he giving me again?
That's a good pup throwing it. No, I'm getting out not yet
I did it. I did something
No way on my last friend I did something to actually help my team. I wasn't an anchor
Oh, yeah, I wasn't an anchor. I wasn't an anchor
MVP most valuable player. Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here all day
Uh, right. Okay
Okay, here's the agendination. We're gonna keep playing
Uh, we're gonna muck about on harder difficulties
Not for too long though, because I'm a bit sweepy, but I'm gonna quickly go for a pee. Is that okay?
You're the real MVP moment. I carried that game. Oh, yeah. Uh, I carried that game
Okay, I'm gonna very quickly go for a peep. I recommend everyone else also goes for a peep as well
It is so good head pass
Uh, yes, yes, yes. Um
I goodnight moment. Are you gonna bed rest well refling? Thank you for hanging
I'll go for a quick pee and then we'll muck about on harder difficulties whether or not something
You know, we actually get anything, but it's not gonna be for too long. Okay
We might be able to redirect. Oh, no, Mercy's not here
Is there a coming on
in 30 minutes?
Um
Good night. Mommy rest well those who sleep. Thank you so much for hanging and watching the campaign
Uh, we will do the later mission at another stream sniping team
um
Yeah
Okay, I very quickly go pee and use can squabble amongst yourself among those in but uh
New refling cycle and and I'll be I'll be right back. Okay
And nope, you can once I go pee the toilet's literally right there
Mwah
Do not miss the army life sergeant comrades in arms instead of us
You
Oh
So what's it like having actually heard sigmar's voice
You
No
I went for a pee I tangled in the toilet
It's going dark. What do you mean? It's going dark. I peed
Reflin darling my sweet pee you're okay
What's this?
Okay, I've got night refling. I don't think I've had
Oh, no, we haven't had you
Uh right
Callie you never had to
Deus we had you in the last game. Do you want to give another refling a shot?
Oh
Oh him in the pose. Oh, oh, oh, he fucking turned around
It's dark because you peed on us. What my acid pee like took away your optic ability. I said all that matters the first time
You were gone for so long
Uh
Days
Is anyone okay tell you what move out days, but if no one moves and come back in again the off
So long
We'll move back
Um, I don't know. I forgot as there is actually not that well right now. So I don't know if we'll be redirecting them to
Um, but we're gonna give hard mode a shot. Whether or not we get her in
Whoa, that's like way better than what I've got right now
I don't know that's even there
Charm
Power
I'm sure this probably isn't the best in sports stuff, but
I'm just I'm the best
Sorry
Right and then first dead you've not been in
Okay, now
What we are going
I can do champion easy once the rust is off
Right, so I was basically going to take us to the start
And then we're going to attempt champion difficulty. Okay
And if I get obliterated there's friendly fire and champion
If there's friendly fire
That means
That the biggest threat to
Like to you guys is me you do realize that right because I'm an idiot and I just swing all the way time
I'm so gonna absolutely annihilate some leaflings. I'm so sorry
Only range weapons have friendly fire
Okay, so maybe it's okay
Let's see what happens
I'm getting nervous
Okay, it's not easy mode
Pay attention use blocks
They put it in the game for a reason. Okay
They put block in the game for a reason
They put it in the game for a reason
So use that reason that the dev team put it in the game
Okay, and we're not to get lost. Okay. I'm not to get lost
I'm not lost. I'm not lost the leaflings are here
focus
Use the block if you need it. Oh
I'm so nervous
No, no not happening
Oh shit, I'm shooting at you
Okay, I'm helping I promise I'm helping
I
I don't know. I'm so nervous
I'm like both locked in and not locked in at the same time because I've just accepted that I'm rubbish at this game
I think we're okay
I'm not fully leveled up. So if we lose I'm gonna blame it and not being fully leveled up game
But we are if we're together
leaflings strong together
And relax the leaflings are within but actually though
I just intimidated by the game
I seem to be doing okay, and I have to remember we don't have to deal with the totem as well
Out well, I just got walloped that was being done
Oh
Uh, I'm guessing healing is so scarce. There's like don't even use it until you're like first home here
No, hike too. We're not we're not doing tomes
We're not doing tomes because I can hardly keep myself alive. Okay. I'm too dumb for this
Being rubberous or something is the first step to almost being good at it
Good thing I have good thing
Sure, I'll take it if they aren't
Oh my god, I don't know how you took that down. He was there once saying don't go on the next you can do it
Have no fear we've seen fear that was a nice block until I immediately messed up again
Okay, okay. Reeflings have taken that. That's good
Shit don't mind if I do
I'm missing all my shots. Okay, let's get the weapons out. Let's get the melee out
Use the block when you need to
I assume I was supposed to do that
Stop taking out a potion to attack an enemy
Oh, I'm just trying to say swipe them the now. Oh, they have so much more hp
Oh
I'm side swiping. I'm side swiping. I'm side swiping
Oh dear, I'm getting a bollocking in the back. Hold on. Are we done here?
Are we to go up survive until the gate opens? Okay, the gate hasn't opened yet, so I can just stay here swinging
Where the gate gets here or do we want to sit by the gate? I'm sitting by the gate. Is that allowed?
Oh
No
Come on
Right, put that gun away. Put it away. Stop it. Stop it. Stop this medicine
Ah, I was gonna pick you up. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I suck so bad
I can't even get to you right. I can pick you up now
Okay, up the stairs which go up the stairs
Okay, where'd you go up the stairs up the stairs you guys can use voice chat by the way
Are you guys have better comms than Oliver?
I was distracted by the blight storm
Not the brap tornado. No, because it actually is as well
If you press left down or right you dodge
Bombs here, let's hope the black powder inside is
If I die, is it like ogre ogre or is it just like the three of them have to continue without me?
They can rescue you later, okay
Ooh, I don't like the look of him
Okay
Whoo
Rather scary
I just hope my blunt attack isn't off. I do I really do
Fucking get me up there and I'm faking it
You respawn after about okay
I wondered that because one of the trinkets was like yeah, but a faster respawn
But I was like it's not like fortnite when you can call in the wee battle bus
Wow
Uh the dwarf reflin is currently berserking right now. He's on his own
Okay
Okay, it's fine. It's fine. We're doing okay. Honestly all things considered
Uh, I think this really needs to be cushioned
If you want to take it from me. Oh no, you've got you've got a book on them
Oh no way that didn't kill him
Yeah
Wow
Grabbing
Uh grab our room there's a book here
Oh
Wait that reflin's gonna get one. Is he gonna be okay?
I don't know if he's gonna get overrun
My blunt attack is when I smoke and blow that's okay
It's normal to die on higher levels don't worry too much about it. Okay
I'm just swinging in case something happens, you know
You seem to have got it
She be
She sent us to scrawny you fools
I said she be stream go. What was she up to madam the deceiver?
All right, what does she say we've been lied to by madam was that mistake
I
She be in her room. Thank you for the reader. Right. She smacked her Tamagotchi chair give it a spanking
I remember my Tamagotchi died and pretty much
Thanks to take it and then I used to say the teacher. I need both the toilet and I'd go feed it during school
That's a cheeky thing oh
I almost got done I almost got done in
Okay, that's why you swing
We're currently playing a game called vermin tight 2
And for stream sniping
Uh, I've made a new steam account so we can play a ton of more games together without having to worry about anything
Um, let's skip the grims for today
Yeah, I think for this map, um, we finished the first campaign mode
We are going to be playing vermin tight 2 at a later date to finish finish all the default content
Obviously, they've got dlc content
Which I'm not going to be buying because I already bought the base price of the game
but um
Yeah, I've just been playing my refunds for almost seven hours. I'm talking about we're playing
I didn't save properly. I'm sorry. Runs away in tears
Save what? I'm so confused
Did the Tamagotchi profit sweet cloth?
Oh, right I'm not doing that
No, I'm blocking
No, I don't think I have the stamina for this
You can play dlc as long as the host owns that
That's okay shibi. We love you no matter what. This is true
You only played the first campaign, there's still three others on yes
I'm going to play them with uh, the next time we stream snipe
I'll pick a different game, but like in the future we'll play this game again. Um
Um
You'll get there
Wow
We're playing champions mode, which means everything's a lot
meaner and not as nice to us
and I am trying to
Not die basically, but everyone's really not feeling well. Do you want this healing potion?
I can give you it. I don't know how to drop it
Oh, I just used the ultimate
I'm a wasted ultimate. Have fun reeflings
You get them
Right, someone take that and then someone heal with that potion
Okay, I have the book
I've got a go and I have a fun hang out. Good luck. Thank you
I don't know why I didn't react to that at all
Thank you, thank you
He won't trouble us no more. Yes, I will whack them with the book. Why not?
Me
It's our treachery finale of pelish on champions. Wait the ending to this one
Have I picked the worst map to do this?
I mean I gave him a wall at the best I could. All right, there we go. I guess we just keep going we keep moving
I'm moving I'm going
Look at all that temporary HP P though
I'm absolutely getting it
Terror of treachery is another map. Okay, tiki. Thank god
Surely the first game is the easiest to win on champions
I
I'm chopping I'm chopping I have extra damage against those who are knocked down
Oh, sorry
I forgot I can't shoot through teammates. I'm sorry. I just walloped him
I was like, oh that's strange. I've never heard him say that voice line before
That check your aim one. Yeah, because I literally just shot right through your like flesh and bone
She V did some turret reading. Mummy is carving a path
I'm so sorry. I don't know what turret guards mean
Maybe I shouldn't have opened this right away
Yeah, it was very nice. Oh, I'm glad you have fun together here. Um
That's cute. Uh, I don't know if there are as well enough to
And
Your weapon does really little friendly fire you would run out of I'm we're killing
Check your aim
Like from the painting of well that very I don't want to be mean
Because if she be genuinely likes that stuff, I'm not gonna be like a thinker about it
It's just like my only experience is balutro
And the the binding of Isaac and I went, oh my god, the lover's card. Oh two two red hearts to replenish my health. I'll use it
Like oh the hermit card. Oh my god
I can go into the shop for free without using a key the access unless I'm on the first floor like
Unfortunately, I don't know
Oh my god, this is a lot I'm trying
We're half health, that's not bad
Okay, they're coming behind as well just the one year wee bit. Oh my god, I need reload
Sorry, that was the worst reload time ever
Oh, fuck. I don't know where we win
Okay, right everyone heal up if you need to heal up
I will hold the book and then someone can hold a med kit
I really need it
It's so much more fun when more enemies are on the screen. Did I not just turn into a pixel?
Because the bitrate can't keep up with all the movement
She got the lover's card. Oh did I?
So what I get is my HP gonna go up now because I've not got good HP in real life at the moment
I love this card. A wild card. Sorry
A wild card isn't a thing. It's fine
The bitrate starts to tank when you swing
Does it? Oh my god, are we staying in this corner?
Oh my god, they know the strats the reflins know the strats. We're supposed to be in the storm in the corner
You have two hearts down main angels. Oh, that was so sweet reflin
All right, hold on. I need to wait. No
I might protect me my
Oh, no way we get that no way
Okay, I'm knocking them on their arses
Are we supposed to like move up and down here or not really?
Oh
I'm stuck in that. I don't know about you guys
Uh
Male stress male stress
Are we not supposed to be in here anymore? I don't know you guys you're moving out. I'm just copying what you do
You know you're back in here. Okay. I'm back in here too
I
We're fine. Just turtle up all like that terminology just hurt a lot
You haven't saved from it until you see shade milk, uh, chaos form
What does that mean?
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, uh, something's happening
I can't read I can't see I can't see
I can't see I can't help. I can't do anything
It's all coming apart. I need my replays
Oh my gosh, please
Oh, thank god, you guys don't suck
Thank god, you guys are actually good at this game because I know what sure is heli
I
I'm just staying underneath. Okay. I can't
I'm just staying underneath. I'm a good little streamer. I listen to what they're gonna tell me
I can't see him
You can't see any of the enemies for that
Shit they all have shielded up
Okay, every look nice
How long is this section? I don't want to survive, but I'm getting nervous because
I
The beacons are lit scrawny poles for eight. I
Oh
Uh, I'm going back in the corner. I think I don't know
Is that up yet?
Am I going in the corner? I don't know
Ah, they're spawning in our corner. What the heck? Oh, do we prevent them from spawning right there for here?
Hey, we were here first
Literally kids game. We were first back off. This is our spot, man
Right that that it done
I assume that's it done
Since you guys are out here
Oh
My god, we did it that was so stressful never again. That was so stressful. I'm just working to like
Oh my god, we did it gambasie
It's like halo reach survive until you die that was terrifying
Crazy I was crazy one. I was in the corner a rubber corner fell to scaven and scaven's made me crazy crazy
I might fell so badly
Thank you
Oh mo molo for the pee. Yeah, I thought if you do you're getting done for
So next mission easier difficulty
I think I have time
Wait unless the zero is up. I think the zero is not well
Oh, she's up. Okay. No, I take it back. I think this is oh, did I do anything?
Headshots 183 by accident. Okay. We did it. We completed one champion and all of that
Right, so what I'll do I'm now going to unfriend you all live right in front of your face
Uh, right. How does it is it just like one by one?
Oh, do I have to go on your pro? Oh, I don't want if your profile says something though. I don't want to it's like
I'll tell you what
Well, I'll hate the screen and I'll unfriend everyone and then I'll show the screen and show you is okay
She hates us. No, I don't hate you
Right, let me do that
Okay, and then let me make myself bigger so you're entertained jingle jingle jingle
Hey, I don't in case there's something on your profile. That's like personal
Wait head out unfriend
Wait, there isn't like a simple way to unfriend
Hey, I'm not gonna be here for ages
Unblock unfriend remove. Oh my god, right
I have to manually go and everyone's profile in order to do this. Okay. Well, if anyone feels like unfriending me to make this
Uh process a lot faster. That'd be amazing. That'd be so cool. Oh
Okay
Uh, or does it if you go to their profile and click the three dots
Yeah, I'm having to like open up the profile and then get it to load and then click and then
unfriend remove friend
Okay
Oh god, this is gonna take me so long
Please if you're online unlist me
Make me un your friend. That's not even a sentence. Do you want to try again? No
I
Sorry, I've been I've been talking a long
The problem with the empire, right with the soldiers with those who give the orders most are honest
I
Yeah, well, maybe I did my part you can remove from friends. Let's rate click
It's making me open up the profile. Hold on. I'll try this right click
Wait a long thing
Oh, come on. I'm not that bad at steam. I'm uh
Right click
Congratulations
Congratulations little seaweed on beating the game and becoming a blooming tide champion trophy more
You know, why the heck is my why are my
My little
Why are my stuff I was gonna cut off?
I'm cutting them off. Thank you tyrian chain. It was so good. I really enjoyed it
Oh my god, this is taking me forever
You profile
Loading click the three dots unfriend remove friend. Okay close
Open view profile
I'm like, oh my god, if it's a through the account, can I just not do this?
But uh, I don't want to create any brain worms. So I respect
I'm all about the respect
It's just taking a bit longer than I entered feed. I will redirect into azura
Um, so just give me a moment and you will be redirected into actual gameplay and not just a black screen and a feature with model
Don't get me wrong. That can be content, but me
I'm not like that. I'm born
Do do do
Okay, I've almost removed everyone that's offline and hopes that everyone that's online removes me makes this process faster
um
Almost
I unfriended strong different friends the less in the scene have been unfriended. No, don't cry. We flin
We'll do more stream snipe stuff. As I said, we'll probably do left for dead together because
Well, you know how I always like oh, I want to play borderlands with vtubers that are endurance
well
In the most respectful way
It's not a problem if I play it with you guys
because like I can just set a timer
And then we'll play like an hour and then we swap out and that kind of thing, you know
So then we can play like all the harder games that I wouldn't originally have like
It would have been really awkward to play with like other vtubers. You know
You know, you know, this makes me mummy's gone from projectile vomit. Oh dear
Um, no dear
That'll go in right I'm now doing the people who are afk
So all the people that weren't online and now unfriended now i'm doing afk
And then i'm doing whoever's in the game because they're highlighted to me right now
I wonder can your account
Yeah, no, uh, surely steen wouldn't ban your account because you add people play with them and then remove them
At the end of the playstation. That doesn't sound like something they would report as like suspicious community
suspicious like activity on an account, right?
So
Um
Someone's called super awesome friendable reef link. Did you just change that stuff when from maybe as a friend
As there is like yes, she is I am redirecting into her successfully on a moment. That's really funny
and
But yes, I think we'll be able to
Play more difficult games like I think borderlands 2 is much better for stream sniping than it is like play a series of
are kind of
I am aware that when you watch a collaboration stream, it's it's hard to
interact to talk to
You know be a part of it because you're kind of
You're watching it more than you are into
Well, like when it's like a one-on-one stream a more personal stream type thing that is
Like
Obviously, I can like you jail the time and
me monia and all of that whereas like when it's a collab it's
harder
Okay, I think I did it. I think I think I did it. Hold on. Let me let me boot the game back up
Okay, now i'm too big for the game
Okay, I made myself small but just uh proof
Uh, I said like two or four people are in here, but I don't know who the hell's in this room because it's just me
Uh, other than the ghost of Christmas past
Come on. She unfriended me. Yeah
But as far as i'm aware that means like no one's
On the friends list. I don't see anything
That's the specialist search friends
The
The ghost of inking pass. I mean in collabs the chat is a bit left out because it's obviously you have to communicate. Yes
and like
I'm probably like after this month. I'm probably just gonna stick to like collabing with the girls. Um
We all kind of seem to be on the same page for the most. I said she was she was fantastic and there is quite social as well
Um, she even got rid of the superdifferent
None of us
Unfriended again. Nobody loves me. But yeah that just a poof. I ain't doing anything weird in the background
um
It was probably me because I left a message on the chat
I'm unfriended. I'll be back for the next playstation. Yes, we will play this game again. Please don't think
I'm not playing this game because it
Uh, I thoroughly enjoyed that. I genuinely did not expect to
Enjoy it as much as I did and I am so glad that um, I've figured out a way to enable us to stream
Snipe on these kinds of games as well
because I have to admit if we were just left to the stream sniping games that are um
How you call it that are
Like the lobby code only or like good luck
We'll all just enter this lobby at the same time and hopefully we all connect like that's it's not easy
It's not easy doing it that way
Um, sorry the last group is called the champions. Okay
Right in order of appearance
Uh, please don't feel bad if you can't you can stream snipe this time. Are we just having fun? We're having a good time together
Okay. Oh wait, hold on
Uh, hold on. What's my layout? Oh, no
Nope, that's my background theme
Uh
Okay, that looks more put together
Okay, why is the chat messed up at the top thing? Whatever. Um
Okay, uh, I'll say special. Thank you for everyone that stream sniped if you couldn't stream snipe
Please don't worry. I like to do stream sniping every week for the most part depending on the situation in case something
You know comes up. I might not have time. Um, but just to recap on who was helping me through the campaign
and frog on toast low key
lame phoenix and you guys were called the babies question mark
zero
Got goddamn rabies and first ed is called hydrophobic and then an angry face
But then cure because we we called you cure at one point
Mr. Own
Two one
John refling omni
I called you mr. Om Ling
And then the bone zone came up with in vitamin c leni boy
half in
rider
hardly even nor
rubbish name
I should be embarrassed
uh, diddy child's brad and recon crusader
disher
Diss her diss her then d like all your in the star you name
hydro ruin exescalation
dsx
mima
sama
I've scribbled out gaping the big wet cave. Oh the splunkers
Okay, it was the big wet cave and then it became the gaping wet cave and then it became the splunkers that makes more sense
Okay, um
And then quest callie and garfunkel were the veterans and then the disconnectors and then they're forgotten because I didn't name these very well
I'm sorry. Okay, then tiger site stash power
and
do
emo
Do do demo or do demo
Uh, the green green red gang because you guys were literally green green and red. She forgot I named them
Um, and then gazillionaire child demo head empty no thoughts
You guys were called doko equals coco exclamation mark because mommy doko mommy coco
Yeah, I'm right here
Then peppermint stash power and half in you guys were called glake it
But then you turned into the posers because we all start posing at one point
um
vader pt
lucky moe and salty lemon were called
dad's lucky citrines
Uh, zarian hydro and then the russian riflin
pvp
Um, it's just called love because I couldn't really figure out anything else. Um, and then deus eggs
uh, mima sama
lenny
I've called lenny. Was it lenny? Well, it was lenny. Wasn't that it was
I'm sure it was am I going crazy? I hope your name done wrong. Um
And salty lemon no wait wrong wrong
Lenny and head empty were the experience and then last but certainly not least
Nate rifling cali and first dead were the champions because you literally made me win as a champion
And that was our streamstaping event
We have successfully
So
Um, we have successfully done helm guard and next time we play this game, we're gonna play these ones
Because they're all really super small
So we could do it all in one go again, and then that'll be our streamstaping adventures on this game
Unless shot like these dlc's are recommended, but
I am a bit me if it's dlc like if it ain't in the base game
okay
Personally, I like the team that had strongy in it. Thank you rifling
I enjoyed that team too because all the dreams all the dreams all the teams were a dream to be with
aim
Fun streaming fun stream. I'm gonna go eat cake now. Now. I'm gonna pass out for a nap and then when I wake up. I'm gonna
Do things
On my alternative to where good night
Um, please. Thank you so so much for stream sniping. Thank you for watching. Thank you for lurking in the shadows
And all the support you guys have been for right side
Um, I had such a fun time and I can't wait for an extreme sniping adventures
I will see you tomorrow for some thai cam cupping ASMR if you don't mind if I do and I don't mind if you do
Aim always fun with you. You do not eat cake. You bake it. We inking tonight, but
Inkling a mo. I love that mo so much. It's so good. Mommy's leaving in a minute. Well
I might be leaving but another mommy's gonna take care of you if any the mother of humanity azura delay
Who's gonna take care of you? She is playing a game called buckshot roulette, which multiplayer is coming to
I'm gonna fuck you all up in multiplayer. That's all I'm saying. Not only am I gonna fuck other retubers up in that game
I'm gonna fuck you all up too in uh
The game because I'm gonna be writing down everything and five heads and that stuff real quick
Me after seeing stroneys cake pic. Oh, he's inkling a goat mama time unity
I
Demand failure unity
And now you post the unity and you know what I'm a post the unity. I can't wait to get that commission
It's so cute
Okay, I'm a redirect into azura. I'm gonna get a nap and then
Do something that rhymes with the word nap
After and then post it. Okay. I love you. Thank you so so much for the absolute fantastic stream
I I thoroughly enjoyed that stream. I hope equally you enjoyed it too because I
As I said, I do I love the games where I can literally play with me
It feels very nice very my heart is very full. I am full of love
I hope you equally feel that love and if this isn't your kind of game to stream snipe
I hope in the future I will play a game that is accessible to you both and fun to you. Okay
Thank you so so much reefland. I will see your adorable face tomorrow whilst I smush it in between my thighs. Okay
I give you a kiss. Okay
Oh wait, I'll do the kisses for how many runs we had one how many teams one two three four five six seven eight
Nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen. We did fourteen successful missions. Okay
um
Me
Okay, four mwah five mwah six mwah seven mwah eight mwah
nine
Ten
Eleven mwah twelve mwah thirteen
Fourteen
And a bonus kiss because we never lost a mission
Mwah
Now please do enjoy a zero delay to your heart's content
I will verify and testify that I'm successfully redirecting to her on my end, but visually
um
It
It might be busted because I've redirected a few times and it just never works. I don't know why it just never works
So I will post her link just in case but thank you so so much reeflands. I'll see you goofy goober tomorrow
Okay, have a good night. Make sure to hydrate and breast and eat up and all that goodness and stretch your legs if you need a big stretch
Okay
See you tomorrow